[Musique]
bienvenue nous sommes en direct de la
dixième manifestation de Paris c'est la
dixième manifestation à Paris vous
pouvez retrouver aujourd'hui ce direct
nous allons suivre le cortège tout au
long de la journée vous le voyez
derrière moi c'est l'avant du cortège
l'interdical d'où Laurent Berger et
dedans ils étaient exprimé il y a
quelques instants et je vous laisse
retrouver tout de suite en plateau
Thibaut Gauthier qui est avec Yves très
art merci Vincent roseron on l'entend on
le voit le mouvement contre la réforme
des retraites se durcit confirmation
aujourd'hui ou début du déclin de la
motivation des Français qui descendent
dans dans la rue c'est ce que nous
serons après avoir passé l'après-midi
ensemble
à suivre cette nouvelle journée de
manifestation et des 14 heures bienvenue
sur le Figaro live tous les journalistes
spécialisés du Figaro viendront sur ce
plateau pour nous aider à mieux
comprendre les derniers rebondissements
autour de la réforme des retraites
bonjour ifrez Merci
directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
Figaro j'ai plein de questions et
d'abord on va sur le terrain et on
retrouve Damien Damien canivevez Damien
bonjour dites-moi tout je veux connaître
le parcours le dispositif ce qu'il y a
déjà du monde autour de vous
bonjour Thibault bonjour à toutes et à
tous Je vous trouve actuellement
boulevard Voltaire à quelques mètres de
la tête de cortège composé
essentiellement des partenaires sociaux
des leaders syndicaux boulevard Voltaire
c'est à partir de DC à Paris que le
cortège va s'élancer à partir de 14h là
dans quelques instants le cortège va
démarrer place de la République à Paris
et va rejoindre la place de la Nation en
passant par ce boulevard Voltaire il
faut savoir qu'un parcours de délestage
aussi a été prévu par la préfecture de
police de Paris qui passait
essentiellement par la place de la
Bastille il est un peu plus long
celui-ci puisque le parcours principal
fait un peu plus de 3 km ce qui
représente à peu près 40 minutes de
marche mais vous imaginez bien que ça va
durer un peu plus longtemps
l'encadrement policier il est inédit ici
à Paris 5500 policiers et gendarmes vont
encadrer ce cortège qui sera composé
jusqu'à 100 000 manifestants c'est ce
qu'attendent les services de
renseignement mais je peux vous assurer
que pour le moment c'est très clairsevé
dans les rangs nous avons traversé la
place de la République à Paris et nous
sommes ici boulevard vol les rangs ne
sont pas encore resserrés les gens sont
en train d'arriver et on sent aussi un
changement de doctrine peut-être en
particulier sur la police nationale
puisque vous pouvez le constater
derrière moi il y a une soixantaine de
policiers et gendarmes qui sont en train
de bloquer ce boulevard Voltaire ils
sont visibles ce qui n'était pas
forcément le cas au cours des
manifestations précédentes il se faisait
plutôt discret et je peux vous assurer
que nous-mêmes on a été contrôlé à deux
reprises boulevard Saint-Martin parce
que nous sommes arrivés place de la
République à Paris ça témoigne peut-être
de l'état d'esprit tendu des policiers
aujourd'hui qui attendent de nombreux
casseurs une fois encore aujourd'hui
donc dans les rues de la capitale et on
entend derrière vous les cornemuses
d'Amiens Canivez tout près de CCAS Yves
en partant sur le terrain dans un
instant avec Vincent roseron mais nous
voilà reparti dans une nouvelle journée
de manifestation
c'est un peu différent là depuis jeudi
dernier oui c'est un peu différent parce
qu'il y a eu des violences des violences
urbaines jeudi dernier qui ont pas mal
alimenté la chronique et qui ont
peut-être fait peur d'ailleurs à les
manifestants en tous les cas qui ont
révolté d'autres observateurs et puis il
y a eu les violences du week-end aussi
qui faut ajouter à cela et oui
c'est un cadre différent mais ça montre
quand même que dans cette société il y a
des gens extrêmement violents prêts en
découdre et qui sont dans une atmosphère
de guerre civile il faut le dire comme
ça parce que les images qu'on a vu
samedi sont des images absolument
ahurissantes et là alors de deux choses
l'une on sait maintenant en province
dans les grandes villes à Marseille à
Bordeaux à Lyon à Rennes qui a moins de
monde semble-t-il
les autres villes ont lieu les matins
voilà
de deux choses l'une soit assez
violentes sont fait peur à aux
manifestants
dans tous les cas on décourageait les
manifestants de rejoindre les cortèges
ou alors ou alors et bien ça veut dire
qu'on est on commence à être dans un
déclin de la de la protestation contre
les retraites parce que c'est la dixième
journée et que beaucoup de salariés
peut-être ou beaucoup de de personnes
estiment que finalement les dés sont les
dés sont lancés et que il y a plus grand
chose à obtenir du gouvernement qui
reste et du président de la République
qui reste assez ferme sur ses positions
Vincent roseron on vous retrouve sur le
terrain alors vous vous êtes pas loin
des des manifestants et des leaders
syndicaux des leaders politiques est-ce
que vous avez pu en interroger certains
alors eux ils sont toujours là ils nous
disent que certains sont peut-être un
peu découragé ce disque rien ne peut
changer eux j'imagine les leaders
syndicaux espèrent pouvoir retourner la
situation
oui bien sûr il dort syndicaux ne lâche
pas vous voyez Laurent Berger sur ces
images le cortège qui a commencé à
avancer il y a quelques instants je dois
me décaler d'ailleurs un tout petit peu
le cortège qui a commencé sa progression
de mon côté qui avance petit à petit
comme vous le voyez et leader syndicaux
il leur syndicaux ils continuent d'y
croire alors aujourd'hui chose assez
spéciale c'est à dire que la CGT
n'est pas là en tant que Alex Philippe
Martinez puisqu'il a Clermont-Ferrand en
ce moment pour un congrès donc par
exemple le service d'ordre de la CGT
n'est pas présent ce qui d'ailleurs
inquiète un petit peu côté de la de la
CGT de la de l'Inter cervicale c'est
Laurent Berger qui disait aujourd'hui
qu'il voulait être il veut toujours
mettre en pause cette réforme de
retraite pour pouvoir rediscuter pour
offrir une porte de sortie au
gouvernement mais Olivier Véran lui a
répondu aujourd'hui à la sortie du
Conseil des ministres a priori ce sera
non
[Musique]
merci Vincent Rozon Yves est-ce que
aujourd'hui on manifeste encore contre
la réforme des retraites ou c'est tout
autre chose
si la la manifestation reste calme comme
ça en renféré derrière ces leaders
syndicaux on peut considérer que c'est
la réforme des retraites qui est quand
même au cœur du sujet si effectivement
ça dégénère que ça va un peu dans tous
les sens on peut on peut extrapoler et
se dire que cette cette contestation
elle dépasse de loin et d'ailleurs quoi
qu'il arrive elle dépasse quand même la
réforme des retraites je pense que
dedans il y a beaucoup de Français enfin
beaucoup de Français qui font grève ou
qui défilent et qui sont un peu révoltés
même si le mot est peut-être un peu dur
contre l'usage du 49-3 au gilet jaune
qui a dérangé notamment beaucoup dans le
public jeune et puis il y a aussi une
part de Français qui défilent et qui
sont qui n'aiment pas Macron et une
espèce de haine de détestation du
président de la République qui les fait
sortir dehors alors après gilet jaune
c'est pour ça que je vous pose cette
question
c'est pas tout à fait ce qu'on a
constaté je dis je dis on a constaté
les gilets jaunes faut pas oublier que
les gilets jaunes ce sont des gens qui
sont pas des jeunes personnes ce sont
des gens qui avaient entre 35 et 65 ans
qui était ruraux partout mais voilà qui
était souvent d'ailleurs avec des
emplois des emplois
intérimaires ou des emplois à faible
rémunération là ce qu'on a vu la semaine
dernière c'est pas du tout du gilet
jaune qui cassait qui mettait le bazar
dans les villes c'était des gens souvent
très très jeunes associés ou derrière
des Black Blocs mais en tous les cas
c'était pas du tout la clientèle les
gilets jaunes il y en avait peut-être
des gilets jaunes mais c'est pas
l'essentiel de ce qui a été constaté en
tous les cas par les forces de police
oui je vous parlais de gilets jaunes
parce que cette question de la
revendication souvenez-vous les gilets
jaunes on savait plus vraiment ce qui
demandait voilà c'est en ça que j'ai
fait un paysage évidemment que le profil
est très différent et la cause des parts
de ces manifestants
est-ce que entre jeudi et aujourd'hui
petite différence une petite nuance
l'annulation de la visite de Charles III
pour la première fois le gouvernement
l'exécutif a été objet de répondre à la
rue alors évidemment pas sur leur
revendications mais répondre à la rue et
changer son agenda à cause de ce qui s'y
passait est-ce que ça c'est un petit
tour dans un petit défi la première
réponse avant d'autre ça restera
évidemment comme un événement marquant
mais on peut pas dire que ça a
échangeait grand chose dans la France
manifestante et les revendications des
Français en fait ça sans doute perturbé
ça sans doute
aspirer un sentiment d'humiliation de
honte à quelques Français qui étaient
attachés à cette visite parce que il y a
beaucoup de prestige qui l'entourent
évidemment mais on peut pas dire que ça
ça a changé la phase des choses pas du
tout ça un vrai semblablement quand même
atteint l'image du gouvernement qui est
un gouvernement du coup sur la défensive
parce que incapable de pouvoir recevoir
cette tête couronnée dans de bonnes
conditions avec le faste qui avait qui
va avec mais on peut pas dire que ça a
échanger ces choses et c'est pas parce
que c'est le 3 n'est pas venu que la
journée d'aujourd'hui ça ne
conditionnait pas la journée
d'aujourd'hui
s'il était venu s'il était venu
peut-être que aujourd'hui ça aurait
généré puisqu'il serait encore là il
aurait à Bordeaux aujourd'hui après le
dîner qui devait y avoir lieu le banquet
d'État hier à Versailles peut-être que
là ça aurait changé la l'humeur des
manifestants ça les aurait tenté euh
c'est la tentation était grande de faire
davantage de bazar nous sommes sur
Youtube nous sommes sur le cigare au
point fr vous réagissez vous n'hésitez
surtout pas on passe l'après-midi
ensemble pour suivre cette journée de de
manifestation et de mobilisation petite
différence sur cette manifestation par
rapport au précédentes hier le ministre
de l'Intérieur s'est exprimé il a parlé
avant
la manif est-ce que ça change
vous savez là on est dans un processus
long hein c'est pas comme on était au
début de du mouvement là maintenant
c'est une partie de ping-pong vous avez
vu il y a il y a aujourd'hui ce matin un
échange important entre Laurent Berger
le patron de la CFDT qui demande et qui
propose d'abord de faire une pause qui
propose une médiation au pouvoir
exécutif laquelle médiation est refusée
par
Olivier vérande porte-parole du
gouvernement qui estime que et il a pas
tout à fait tort que pour parler aux
syndicats ils ont pas besoin au pouvoir
exécutif de médiateur donc c'est c'est
un dialogue de sourd à l'envers qui est
en train de se ce ce passé ce produit
c'est à dire que il se parle mais ils
font il fait une de pas se comprendre
vous voyez ce que je veux dire donc
voilà
d'incarner l'ordre l'autorité Gérald
Darmanin qui vient la veille d'une
manifestation expliquait le dispositif
qui sera déployé et comme très différent
ça Emmanuel Macron est-ce qu'il a fait
le choix d'un carnet de l'ordre là
vraiment bien sûr il a intérêt à
l'incarner lors de l'autorité et puis
peut-être que il y a aussi la volonté de
la part du ministre de l'Intérieur qui
est une transparence parce que les
attaques ont été nombreuses depuis la
semaine dernière
a estimé que Ben cette violence
légitime qui est exercée par la police
et les forces de l'ordre et bien est
excessive et puis on reparle encore de
violences policières comme on avait
parlé d'ailleurs du temps les gilets
jaunes et ça pour le ministre de
l'intérieur c'est inacceptable on peut
pas parler de violence policière alors
alors que c'est même policiers et c'est
même Forza Lord sont la cible d'attaque
absolument innommable de la part des
manifestants je salue Rome 37 91 bonjour
Ns sur le
[Musique]
à trois semaines c'est encore long donc
c'est encore très long effectivement
c'est susceptible justement d'user un
peu l'ardeur des manifestants parce que
trois semaines c'est effectivement très
long faut pas oublier que les jours de
grève ne sont plus payés aujourd'hui
donc ça représente pas rien pour nombre
de de salariés et donc le gouvernement
joue là-dessus et évidemment qui joue
là-dessus il a il aurait tort de pas
s'en servir la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel dont on peut dont on a
du mal à anticiper
quel sera est-ce que ça sera un rejet
complet de la réforme puisqu'il paraît
quand même un peu incertain en revanche
est-ce que ça va porter sur des points
très importants je doute que ça porte de
toute manière sur la mesure qui met les
gens dans la rue c'est à dire cette
mesure d'âge
légal de départ à la retraite j'ai lu un
peu partout mais vous allez me dire il
serait rare vous qui avez connu
peut-être pas non je vous charrie mais
68 de Gaulle 68 puisque je peux vous
dire que j'étais à l'école à l'époque à
l'école primaire bien et que mon école a
été fermé pendant un mois alors à
l'époque
grande manifestation partout en France
et quelques mois après au mois de juin
de Gaulle convoque des législatives et
Diane largement avec cette ce besoin des
Français de dire on en a marre
maintenant du bazar on veut l'autorité
est-ce que c'est ce que peut vouloir
jouer Emmanuel alors
il y a deux plusieurs choses qui sont un
peu distinctes d'abord c'est pas la même
période du tout les années 60 c'était
encore une période
d'une certaine façon avec un rapport
entre génération c'est une c'est quand
même une manifestation en grande manière
enfin une expression et une explosion
générationnelle quand même à 68 c'est
pas ça commence pas par les le monde
salarié ça commence par les étudiants et
ça commence par le les étudiants qui
mettent en l'air tout l'ordre gaullien
l'autorité de papa et maman tout ça
c'est c'est très différent de ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui bien sûr la deuxième
chose c'est que Macron n'est pas de
Gaulle je vais pas vous la prendre il a
pas le passé de De Gaulle ça c'est c'est
une deuxième chose la troisième chose
qui est très importante c'est quand même
68 vous avez une alternative vous avez
une droite et une gauche alors certes
vous avez la gauche qui est dans la rue
à l'époque la plus la plus ardente c'est
une gauche qui est assez radicale mais
vous avez aussi une gauche
social-démocrate vous avez une gauche
Mitterrand Mendès France ils sont là et
puis donc vous avez une alternative
aujourd'hui le problème c'est que vous
ou vous le gouvernement tombe
aujourd'hui la majorité
présidentielle s'il y a des élections
législatives
perd la majorité mais est-ce que vous
avez une alternative non il y a pas
d'alternative
on peut faire l'alternance il est là le
sujet aussi c'est que aujourd'hui c'est
là la fragilité de notre de
de la situation qu'on est en train de
vivre c'est qu'on voit pas très bien qui
pourrait incarner un nouvel une nouvelle
autorité un nouvel ordre dans la
situation actuelle et ça c'est une un
grand un grand problème et puis bon on
va pas on va pas se nier la réalité
c'est que en mai 68 c'est une certaine
façon c'est une révolution entre
guillemets une révolte heureuse on veut
plus de liberté il y a on est dans les
trente glorieuses là on est quand même
dans une situation économique qui n'a
rien à voir bien sûr avec notamment
cette phase et cette période d'inflation
qui d'ailleurs empêcherait selon
certains chercheurs les Français
descendent dans la rue parce que oui
vous le disiez c'est cher ça coûte cher
de faire de faire grève on va retrouver
dans un instant Damien Canivez parce que
on parle de cette nouvelle journée de
manifestation et on se demande
évidemment s'il pourrait y avoir de
nouveau incidents on espère que ce ne
sera pas le cas pareil il y a un instant
et c'est vous qui l'avez évoqué ce qui
s'est passé dans les Deux-Sèvres à
Sainte-Soline ce week-end
c'est lié tout ça non c'est pas
évidemment que les motifs sont pas les
mêmes parce que ça ne solide il s'agit
de se poser à la création de ce qu'on
appelle une bassine pour faire gros gros
pour pour aller vite une réserve d'eau
pour les temps les temps difficiles de
sécheresse pour les agriculteurs pour
certains agriculteurs
évidemment que les motivations je dirais
de la de la manifestation ne sont pas
les mêmes mais mais l'état d'esprit de
certains est le même c'est-à-dire le
terme d'esprit qui consiste à en
découdre avec l'ordre établi et avec une
organisation je dirais qui ne convient
plus à certains et qui remet en question
si vous voulez là l'autorité telle
qu'elle s'exerce aujourd'hui et cet état
d'esprit on est obligé de faire un lien
entre ce qui s'est passé à
Sainte-Souline ce samedi et ce qui s'est
passé jeudi dernier et l'espoir qui ont
précédé d'ailleurs cette image de la
place de la République qui semble loin
nous verrons alors que c'est toujours un
peu du moment les rues adjacentes nous
aurons les chiffres en fin de journée
mais là vous avez raison Yves ce n'est
pas la France
et on va en parler on en parlera tout au
long de l'après-midi parce que Philippe
partenaire ne sera plus secrétaire
général de la CGT dimanche soir grande
question également Damien Canivez vous
vous êtes justement aux abords de cette
place de la République avec beaucoup de
force de l'ordre autour de vous j'ai
l'impression vous lisiez lors des
précédentes manifestations on les voyait
très peu les CRS les gendarmes mobiles
là ils sont clairement présents
ils sont clairement présents Thibault et
c'est en ça que la stratégie de la
préfecture de police a très certainement
changé depuis la semaine dernière
pourquoi parce que leur enseignement
territorial s'attend la présence de
nombreux casseurs et juste derrière moi
et c'est en ça que la doctrine est
différente c'est qu'effectivement vous
voyez ce cordon de policier de gendarmes
qui est en train de précéder le cortège
de la manifestation qui se trouve à
quelques mètres derrière peut-être que
la stratégie cette fois ci c'est de
faire en sorte que et bien le Black Bloc
ne se forme pas parce qu'on le sait que
c'est devant les cortèges on sait que
c'est le cortège on sait que le cortège
et excusez moi parce qu'il y a toujours
des manifestants qui souhaitent parler
dans le micro vous imaginez bien le les
Black Blocs se forment toujours devant
le cortège syndical et cette fois-ci
c'est effectivement
c'est la police qui décide de c'est la
police cette fois-ci qui se trouve juste
devant le cortège pour le moment
effectivement comme le rappeler cette
dame il n'y a pas de Black Bloc
à première vue mais en tout cas voilà on
sent qu'il y a une certaine tension
si vous remarquerez que tout est fermé
parce que la préfecture de police a
demandé
[Musique]
ensemble et puis on retrouvera tout à
l'heure ils vont bien compris que il y
avait peut-être
une stratégie dans l'attitude des forces
de l'ordre non peut-être qu'ils ont
ajusté effectivement leur leur tactique
de maintien de l'ordre
ça serait la moindre des choses
d'ailleurs parce que on peut pas dire
que la semaine dernière jeudi dernier
est laissé un souvenir de grandes de
grands succès donc même si encore une
fois il faut pas oublier que les forces
de l'ordre pour elle c'est extrêmement
difficile alors qu'elles sont sans arrêt
provoquer par des fauteurs de troubles
qui n'ont rien à voir beaucoup d'entre
eux a été manifestants et qui et bien ne
cherche qu'une chose c'est en découdre
avec les forces de l'ordre et qui sont
parfois avec des caractères et des
tempéraments des des actions qui sont
parfois les actions presque criminelles
je vous rappelle quand même ce ce ce ce
gendarme je crois que c'était un
gendarme je crois ou un policier
effondré qui a vu qu'on a vu s'effondrer
sous le coup d'une pierre qui lui a été
lancé à la tête alors oui le
gouvernement utilise un ton martial ces
images hier le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui s'est
présenté devant la presse tout à l'heure
Olivier Vérand qui a répondu très
fermement aux manifestants est-ce qu'on
essaye aussi un peu d'apaiser Elisabeth
borne a dit j'utiliserai plus le le 49.3
est-ce que ça ça peut non mais non mais
c'est un peu ridicule d'avoir dit ça
parce que d'abord elle se prive d'un
outil qui peut être fort utile elle a
dit elle ne l'utiliserait plus le 49-3
or texte budgétaire parce que vous savez
que 49-3 vous pouvez l'utiliser pour les
têtes de budgétaire et puis le reste du
temps pendant la session vous avez le
droit de l'utiliser une fois sexe qui
n'a rien à voir avec donc elle pourrait
utiliser ce que financier mais elle a
par principe elle a voulu soigner une
image mais c'est un peu ridicule parce
que ça ça d'abord ça ne change rien à
mon avis étant donné que le texte en
question qui est récriminé c'est celui
des retraites et qu'il a été adopté par
49-3 et puis c'est elle se elle se elle
se bride je dirais inutilement pour
l'avenir
ce 49.3 il faudrait le repenser une
crise peut tellement les choses
probablement pas non non probablement
pas parce que écoutez il faut aussi qu'à
pouvoir exécutif et les moyens dans
certains cas et on le voit sur le plan
financier de faire passer ses textes
si on garde cette même constitution en
tous les cas il est certain que des
blocages à venir sont encore à prévoir
en dehors même de ce pouvoir exécutif là
si on change de majorité et ça peut
c'est toujours un
instrument qui peut être
utile et après tout somme toute il a été
prévu depuis
1958 et la constitution d'un cinquième
république je vois pas pourquoi on en
changerait subitement comme ça pour les
beaux yeux de la princesse j'ai
l'impression que déjà des petits
mouvements autour de Damien Canivez on
va retrouver on la retrouver et c'est
toujours une indication il a de la
police autour de lui
mais vous voyez la petite différence
regardez ce
CRS ou ce gendarme mobile alors je sais
pas moi j'ai toujours du mal à la
différence son casque c'est toujours une
une indication ça veut dire qu'il y a de
petits mouvements d'Amiens
gendarmerie nationale absolument
Thibault vous avez tout compris jusque
là la manifestation n'était pas très
tendue c'est à dire que voilà tout se
passait plutôt dans une ambiance
correcte et depuis quelques secondes les
gendarmes ont décidé de remettre leur
casque ça en dit long sur ce qui se
passe au niveau de la tête de cortège
des éléments radicaux sont
vraisemblablement arrivés et sont
peut-être prêts à effectivement en
découdre avec les forces de l'ordre
c'est ce qui attendu de toute façon
c'est ce que le renseignement
territorial avait indiqué qu'il y aurait
plusieurs centaines de de casseurs ici à
Paris alors des précautions ont été pris
en amont puisque la gendarmerie a
effectué plusieurs contrôles aux abords
de la place de la République à Paris
pour fouiller les sacs notamment c'est
ce qui a été notre cas boulevard
Saint-Martin mais voilà la police là on
compte une soixantaine de gendarmes qui
sont vraiment qui font face aux
manifestants et qui les précèdent très
clairement ce qui n'était pas forcément
le cas au cours des des dernières
semaines pourquoi font-ils cela parce
que le black bloc lorsqu'il se constitue
le fait généralement devant la tête de
cortège syndical et peut-être que la
stratégie cette fois-ci c'est d'éviter
justement que ces militants radicaux ne
se rassemblent et peut-être les
disperser avant même qu'ils aient le
temps de commettre des dégradations dans
la ville de Paris alors c'est vrai que
l'ambiance ici est assez particulière
parce que vous le voyez sur les images
de Julien Leclerc les commerces sont
tous fermés ils ont répondu
favorablement l'appel de la préfecture
de police de Paris qui leur a indiqué de
baisser le rideau pour éviter
effectivement que des dégradations ne
soient commises dans leur dans leurs
établissements la grande majorité
d'entre eux effectivement ont baissé le
rideau pour éviter que des vitrines ne
soient ne soient cassées c'est assez
étonnant et d'ailleurs ça en dit long
sur la la stratégie aussi des des
militants radicaux au tout début on a
identifié une dizaine de militants
d'ultra gauche qui était là et on les
voit assez loin finalement ils ont ils
sont tous de noir vêtus avec des
cagoules des masques et plus la
manifestation arrive et plus ce
protège qui se trouve devant la tête
syndicale ce ce grossit et on sent une
tension une tension qui monte raison
pour laquelle les gendarmes ont vous
l'avez vu visser leur casque sur la tête
pour poursuivre un seul objectif éviter
que les dégradations qu'on a connu la
semaine dernière ne se reproduisent dans
les rues de la capitale
la même canivee ne faisons pas de
catastrophisme n'anticipons pas trop
pour l'instant tout est calme illustré
Emmanuel Macron dans un sommet à
Bruxelles vendredi a dit qu'il voulait
parler avec l'intersyndical et pourquoi
faire ils ont vraiment envie de lui
parler Emmanuel Macron parler de quoi
d'ailleurs il a dit qu'il voulait parler
à la terre syndicale mais parler la
terre syndicale après la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel et là la Laurent
Berger lui a envoyé la balle aujourd'hui
en disant mais moi pourquoi on n'aurait
pas un médiateur pour des médiateurs
pour essayer de raccorder le dialogue et
le le l'exécutif par la voix de Olivier
Véran lui a répondu à berger en lui
disant bah non on n'a pas besoin de
médiateur pour parler
Emmanuel Macron
se parle mais personne ne se comprend on
est d'accord que que si je parle ce sera
pas pour remettre la retraite à 62 ans
ça c'est ce que demande Laurent Berger
c'est comme ça qu'on peut l'interpréter
sont à nouveau maillot de violence
qu'est-ce qu'il peut faire
pas tellement je pense pas qu'il fasse
une pause non je ne pense pas qu'il
accepte quelconque médiation d'ailleurs
qui pour m'aider pour servir de
médiateur
c'est toujours lui qu'on sort du chapeau
oui sauf que là ça serait un peu
compliqué puisque c'est quand même une
composante de sa majorité
et donc les autres solutions c'est de
changer de gouvernement je vois pas en
quoi ça pourrait changer faire une
dissolution
je vois pas pourquoi ici prêter
référendum non plus dans la mesure où il
attend toujours cette décision du
Conseil constitutionnel donc ben on va
voir ce qui va se passer mais je je
doute que il bouge il bouge beaucoup il
doit partir il doit partir en Chine
débuteries dans plus il doit partir en
Chine début avril effectivement il a
commencé le Conseil constitutionnel
devrait rendre ça sa décision vers le 18
ou 20 avril donc ça serait après son
séjour en Chine merci beaucoup merci
frère merci d'être venu lancer ce live
cet après-midi de manifestation on
retrouve Vincent roserand sur place
Vincent Jean-Luc Mélenchon serait dans
la manifestation aujourd'hui parce qu'il
est pas toujours à Paris le leader des
insoumis
non puisqu'il est souvent à Marseille le
milliardaire soumis vous le savez là où
il avait élu député mais aujourd'hui il
semblerait qu'il arrive bientôt au point
d'insoumis c'est ce qu'on nous a dit en
tout cas il vient de se passer une scène
assez
on va dire inhabituel parce que vous
savez les politiques restent un peu loin
du cortège ne rentre pas dedans et là il
y a un cortège lycéen qui est passé et
qui a en fait demandé à Louis Boyard que
vous voyez sur ces images un peu au fond
Louis Boyard et qui lui ont demandé de
rejoindre leur cortège sur des suivis 5
minutes de selfie et ensuite il a
regagné sa tribune et tout le monde est
reparti donc voilà a priori on la la
popularité de Louis Goya auprès des
jeunes manifestants et bien là et comme
vous le disiez par contre tout à l'heure
excusez-moi c'est Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
devrait être là d'ici quelques instants
et on écoutera évidemment Jean-Luc
Mélenchon le leader des insoumis le
leader de la gauche
s'il venait d'arriver à votre micro
Vincent roseron vous nous l'avez promis
on l'écoutera Thomas en grand bonjour
bonjour journaliste au service
économique du Figaro spécialiste des
questions autour des syndicats alors
encore une journée à l'appel des
syndicats dites moi beaucoup penser que
cette intersyndicale allait explosé pas
du tout et bah écoute prof que non c'est
ce qu'il disait eux-mêmes tout le monde
notamment du côté du gouvernement fait
le pari que chaque jour on est on va
voir une baisse drastique de la
mobilisation c'est effectivement ce qui
avait laissé penser les dernières
journées qui avaient eu lieu mi-mars et
puis finalement là depuis la journée
précédente a été celle de jeudi a quand
même été un franc succès
en termes de mobilisation on en pense
qu'on veut ils ont re dépassé le million
largement ils ont fait à peu près le
meilleur que les que les que les
meilleures journées en fait voilà et
celle là effectivement d'après alors les
premières remontées ceux qui ont ça sera
un peu en dessous de jeudi mais ça a
l'air d'être quand même une grosse
journée aussi effectivement pour être
passé on a vu moins de monde place de la
République en bon état alors difficile à
dire effectivement il y aura peut-être
effectivement moins de monde que que je
dis mais en tout cas en passant
effectivement ça te donnait quand même
une impression de
quand même de forte fréquentation donc
il est possible qu'il y ait une grosse
journée en perspective expliquez-moi ils
sont là la CGT à Paris ou pas j'ai pas
tout compris ils n'y sont pas alors bon
je vois un ballon oui oui bien sûr alors
en fait il va il va avoir effectivement
des des membres de la CGT notamment
effectivement la CGT a appelé à
manifester partout dans toutes les
villes donc effectivement certains
militants drapeau autour c'est pour ça
que je connais pas la CGT reste quand
même un gros syndicat quoi qu'il arrive
le fait est que effectivement par contre
tous les cadres là par exemple dans la
tête de cortège il y avait quelques
représentants CGT mais tous les quatre
sont effectivement tous à
Clermont-Ferrand depuis lundi
pour le concret de la CGT et ils sont
allés manifester ce matin et
Clermont-Ferrand il y avait Philippe
Martinez il y avait
je voudrais qu'on en reparle tout à
l'heure mais sur cette sur cette
manifestation aussi on voit que ça se
remplit on voit l'image en haut à gauche
quand même les raisons des rares semble
se resserrer quel est l'état d'esprit
des syndicats on y croit vraiment il
pense vraiment qu'ils vont pouvoir faire
reculer le gouvernement et empêcher le
report de l'âge légal au départ
officiellement oui même je pense qu'ils
ont toujours un espoir alors il y a
immisent toujours une petite pièce sur
le Conseil constitue constitutionnel
pardon il semble avoir quand même enfin
ils estiment avoir des arguments très
sérieux à la fois sur le fond et sur la
forme des outils utilisés par le
gouvernement pour arriver à ses fins
donc ils ne perdent pas espoir que le
Conseil constitutionnel qui doit donner
sa réponse plus tard le 21 mettra un
bémol cette réforme il y a effectivement
plus tard encore la question du Rip
voilà donc
le référendum d'initiative partagé voilà
donc bon ça c'est à plus long terme mais
c'est en plus ça demande très 5 millions
de signatures donc même si la mesure a
l'air un populaire c'est quand même pas
facile à obtenir mais en tout cas à plus
court terme on y a quand même un
sentiment de
enfin un sentiment que ils peuvent
encore faire reculer le gouvernement et
ils y croient ils ont notamment laissé
une sorte de pseudo porte de sortie au
gouvernement mettant en pause voilà
exactement alors après avoir rejeté la
main tendue d'Elisabeth borne il y a
quelques jours qui se disait prête à les
recevoir pour parler tout sauf des
retraites bon bien sûr ils n'ont pas
pris cette main tendue par contre ils
ont à leur tour tendu leur propre main
en disant on est prêt à discuter à
condition que vous fassiez pause sur les
64 ans donc pour le moment Olivier Véran
le porte-parole du gouvernement à
répondu à une fin de nos recevoir à
cette proposition donc c'était tout à
l'heure vous l'avez vécu sur le figure
ou quoi voilà donc officiellement en
apparence chacun comme sur ces positions
et la situation dites quand même
réchauffe un petit peu ben ça veut pas
rien dire bien sûr de toute façon ça
serait complètement utopique après des
mois à
de bras de fer très fort de voilà et
puis chaque camp a construit
on arrête et puis surtout que c'est
comme tout conflit à la fin si il y a
une solution ça sera probablement une
solution une sorte d'entre-deux qui
permettra de ménager les émotions une
sorte en même temps effectivement mais
voilà donc peu probable qu'effectivement
un des deux camps d'un jour au lendemain
se disent bon bah écoutez vous m'avez
convaincu j'abandonne tout un point à
vous j'ai des chiffres à 14h je pense
moins de manifestants alors 272000
manifestants à 14h on baisse par rapport
au précédentes mobilisation ce que je
peux vous dire c'est qu'à la même heure
le 23 mars il y avait 398 000
manifestants
une forte différence et
700 le 7 mars 510 000 donc d'accord
sera forte à Paris peut-être que toutes
les villes n'ont pas été recensées pour
l'instant les chiffres sont assez clairs
baissent du nombre de manifestants à 14h
partout en France est-ce que les
syndicats ont encore la main sur la
mobilisation c'était très tendu jeudi
dernier pour l'instant pas
d'échauffourés à Paris en tout cas il y
en a eu ailleurs en région est-ce que
les manifestants les syndicats tiennent
encore ces manifs alors en tout cas pour
ce qui est des grandes journées de
mobilisation parce qu'on a vu ce
multiplier tout un tas d'initiatives
effectivement complètement hors de
l'organisation des syndicats qui est un
peu tous les jours en petits groupes
explosé ou là effectivement les
syndicats reconnaissants ils ont en
général aucun contrôle et voilà donc ça
c'est la même manière pas envie de
s'enlever de ces autres manifestations
en tout cas voilà ça se fait sans eux
quoi qu'il arrive
en général c'est peut-être ça peut être
des publics plus radicaux aussi donc
peut-être que de toute façon même si les
syndicats organisés on y n'arriverait
pas à les contrôler donc il y a
peut-être ça pour ce qui est des grandes
journées de mobilisation effectivement
celle de la semaine dernière à Paris
c'est fini un panneau de boudin si on
peut dire y compris le
cortège de tête où sont les syndicats
sont faits on fait bousculer pas fini en
ordre de marche dispersée à l'Opéra
bousculer par qui parlent les forces par
les la violence par voilà je pense des
ils se sont trouvés un peu entre deux
feux voilà c'est vrai qu'il y avait on a
vu des scènes sur les derniers mètres du
cortège de la semaine dernière ou
c'était un peu apocalyptique voilà donc
ils ont pas été totalement épargnés
après comme il pointe c'est vrai que il
y a ce moment-là ce lieu là qui est
toujours
plus ou moins conflictuelle y compris
dans les journées précédentes il y avait
des Black Blocs et des gilets jaunes
radicalisés il y a eu des petits soucis
voilà c'était très marginal voilà eux ce
qui m'aide quand même en avance et que
déjà dans la plupart des villes où ils
organisent il y a moins il y a moins de
conflits et surtout si on se recule
enfin c'est ce qu'il dit si on se recule
on prend 50 mètres d'écart avec le
cortège de tête on se retrouve au milieu
de toutes ces personnes qui manifestent
qui manifestent pacifiquement et
là-dessus il y a un contrôle il y a une
organisation
il y a toutes ces choses-là on
retrouvera une Damien canive vs parce
que nous sommes sur le terrain
aujourd'hui évidemment pour suivre cette
dixième journée de mobilisation vous
voyez les images de la manifestation
parisienne pour l'instant tout se passe
bien et la place de la République semble
se remplir progressivement
quel a été la réaction des syndicats
après les après les violences de jeudi
est-ce qu'on condamne clairement ou pas
on gagne clairement surtout du côté
réformiste on a trop conscience les
réformistes notamment la CFDT notamment
mais même tous les syndicats ont
condamné de toute façon depuis le début
ils appellent à ne pas s'attaquer aux
biens et aux personnes comme ils non et
puis surtout c'est une obligation parce
que il y a trop la question de l'opinion
publique de l'image populaire on sait
que ce qui peut permettre à ce mouvement
d'être aussi gros c'est le fait qu'on y
retrouve des publics qui sont différents
des militants habituels des gens qui ont
l'habitude des zones de friction de des
périodes de forte tension si on veut si
on veut voir des seniors des familles ou
des choses comme ça faire nombre vous
imaginez bien qu'effectivement on peut
pas les syndicats peuvent pas se
permettre de donner une impression
d'insécurité
donc effectivement à côté de ça on a vu
quand même des mots qui sont apparus
alors effectivement là par contre plus
du côté des radicaux notamment chez
solidaires mais même une petite phrase
par-ci par là de Laurent Berger qui
pointait aussi la responsabilité de
certains membres des forces de l'ordre
de Laurent Berger même Laurent Berger a
eu une petite phrase effectivement
la question de violence policières ça
c'est fait partie vraiment de leurs
habitudes mais aussi y compris on a vu
Laurent Berger donc de la CFDT dire en a
renvoyé de dos à dos certains éléments
il a bien sûr jamais pointé
l'intégralité de des forces de l'ordre
comme étant responsables mais voilà
certains éléments y compris l'ordre et
bien sûr des des manifestants enfin des
Black Blocs et tout ça comme étant de
part et d'autre un peu responsables
aussi de gestes déplacés de violence et
de choses comme ça est-ce que certains
cautionnent on se souvient des mots
d'Olivier matheux notamment l'un des
prétendants au poste de Philippe
Martinez dimanche
dans la CGT dire
nous premier degré nous on est prêt à
mettre le feu quoi on est prêt à aller
au combat on est prêt à se battre oui
alors c'est vendredi qui que l'élection
aura lieu enfin plutôt que le résultat
sera connu alors c'est alors c'est
effectivement pas du tout le message
officiel de l'Inter syndical c'est même
un terme qui condamne faut savoir
qu'Olivier matheux d'un fait partie des
plus radicaux d'un des syndicats donc
bon on a affaire à quand même une frange
très minoritaire et très particulière ou
en plus voilà comme vous l'avez dit il y
a toute cette question du congrès de la
CGT derrière Olivier matheux est un
opposant déclaré à Philippe Martinez
d'ailleurs on a vu là on avait première
tour bah ça a commencé effectivement
hier du congrès de la CT c'est très
tendu ça je veux qu'on parle du congrès
de la CGT mais moi je veux qu'on ouvre
une page sur cette question d'accord
mais en tout cas ce qui était attendu
c'est des tensions il y a des histoires
de guerre enfin guerre larvet entre les
deux
matheux par ce genre d'annonce il sait
ce qui risque et il a fait complètement
conscience voilà on parlait des gros
bras de la CGT souvent vous savez qui
tiennent ces manifs
qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé ils étaient
là sur les paris ils ont disparu ils
sont débordés ou pardon pour ma question
ils laissent faire les gros bras de la
CGT bah là aujourd'hui ils sont pas là
surtout parce que enfin là effectivement
cette semaine et c'est quelque chose je
pense qui doit jouer dans l'inquiétude
des forces de l'ordre et d'ailleurs qui
jouent aussi qui est une inquiétude
aussi c'est certains autres syndicats le
service d'ordre de la CGT c'est 2-1 le
plus nombreux et de deux le plus
expérimenté voilà c'est un gros syndicat
il y a un gros syndicat qui a l'habitude
des manifestations des défilés
et des zones de tension donc en fait son
service d'ordre est quand même assez
réputé au sein des des autres syndicats
au sein de la police parce qu'en fait
ils ont été débordés et effectivement je
dis ils ont été débordés enfin en tout
cas il y a eu une perte de contrôle le
service d'or n'a pas su bien canaliser
les Black Blocs et
éventuellement certains gilets jaunes
radicalisés voilà alors
reste savoir aussi
ce qu'ils auraient pu faire ce qui s'est
passé aussi du côté des forces de
l'ordre rien n'est clair chacun sa
version donc
pas facile de d'avoir le fin mot de
l'histoire une chose est sûre là
aujourd'hui ils ne sont pas là vu qu'ils
sont soit Clermont-Ferrand soit ils
n'ont pas forcément en tout cas la CGT
n'étant pas une des grandes
organisatrices aujourd'hui voilà ils
sont absents et effectivement ça va
clairement ça se faisait déjà ressentir
sur le cortège de tête ou d'autres ont
essayé de prendre la relève mais quand
même expliqué quelqu'un de la CFTC déjà
nous on est un petit syndicat mais
disait-il et deux nous c'est pas
tellement notre mode opératoire
habituelle les grandes les grands
défilés donc notre service d'ordre n'a
pas pour habitude de enfin de ne pas ne
sont pas expert dans le maintien de
l'ordre de
de ce genre de d'événements alors sachez
Thomas que certains députés modem donc
de la majorité serait favorable à cette
médiation donc
[Musique]
proposé par Laurent Berger une médiation
entre interditale et le gouvernement
mais d'ailleurs effectivement là tout à
l'heure en Asie interrogeant Laurent
bercha a bien dit oui Olivier verrand
a donné l'impression enfin à claquer la
porte sur le coup ils n'ont pas encore
envoyé le courrier le fameux courrier où
ils vont officialiser cette demande donc
déjà ils aient eux-mêmes disaient qu'ils
étaient surpris de recevoir un nom avant
d'avoir fait la demande c'est ce qu'ils
disent facile mais si on fait
publiquement
c'est toujours les batailles de Coop
mais surtout ils disent oui on va quand
même faire ce courrier parce que
malgré le nom
d'Olivier Véran on ne perd pas espoir
que
que une fois qu'on aura bien détaillé
notre demande et tout ça dans le
courrier finalement le gouvernement
peut-être laisse finalement apportant
ouverte l'image de la place de la
République qui se remplit petit à petit
je vais vous montrer une autre image
parce qu'on attend
Jean-Luc Mélenchon Vincent rosera tant
son micro tous les journalistes sont
réunis et ATT la réaction du leader des
insoumis qui n'est pour l'instant pas là
vous voyez cette image quelques instants
Jean-Luc Mélenchon sera à ce micro nous
verrons ce qu'il a à nous dire le leader
de la gauche en attendant on retrouve
Damien Canivez Damien le défilé et
lancer oui je le vois
comment il l'ambiance pour l'instant
ça se déroule dans le calme pour
l'instant Tibo Gautier nous sommes
toujours boulevard Voltaire nous sommes
peut-être puisque la manifestation est
très courte aujourd'hui à la moitié du
parcours il faut savoir qu'on s'est
lancé quand même boulevard Voltaire
puisque le cortège c'était déjà avancé
avant même de commencer place de la
République je vous rappelle que le point
de de chute de cette manifestation c'est
place de la Nation et vous le voyez sur
les images de Julien Leclerc le la tête
de cortège syndical va arriver après
cortège constitué essentiellement de
gilets jaunes et de jeunes militants
vient de passer sous notre nez environ
composé peut-être de 1000 personnes on a
vu des gilets jaunes dont l'un est très
connu vous savez Jérôme Rodriguez ce
militant qui s'est fait connaître
pendant la crise des gilets jaunes et
qui a qui a perdu son œil il était dans
ce cortège qui vient de passer sous
notre nez mouniolo également autre
figure des gilets jaunes qui a été
arrêté d'ailleurs pendant pendant cette
période puisqu'elle était accusée par la
police de déclencher les violences de
Black Bloc et en guise de clin d'oeil à
la même imprimé sur une feuille qu'elle
brandit d'ailleurs pendant sa marche un
parapluie arc-en-ciel puisque elle était
accusée par les policiers et les
gendarmes de déclencher des violences
dès lors qu'elle brandissait son
parapluie arc-en-ciel en hauteur et
voilà elle est là elle également et là
vous voyez voilà la CFTC qui arrive le
syndicat réformiste avec les leaders
syndicaux qui sont toujours de toute
façon encadrés par un service de
sécurité mise en place par les syndicats
qui est assez imposant pour l'instant
tout ce déroule dans le calme mais ce
qu'on peut noter et c'est peut-être ceux
qui diffèrent par rapport à ce qu'on a
pu constater au cours des dernières
semaines c'est que la réforme des
retraites n'est pas dans de nombreuses
bouches aujourd'hui on entend plutôt des
slogans anti Macron des slogans
Antipolis donc on a le sentiment ici que
la colère s'était tendue à bien d'autres
domaines que simplement la réforme des
retraites
allez on le sent ça peut être est-ce que
les syndicats eux
ont bien compris que la réforme des
retraites vous dites que non
officiellement non ils veulent le
retrait de la réforme il a compris que
ce serait difficile de faire reculer le
gouvernement et veut surfer sur sur
renouveau des syndicats parce qu'il y a
quelques temps on les disait non
tout à fait ils vivent un vrai nouveau
de longtemps déjà ils ont prouvé ça je
pense que c'est déjà une victoire pour
eux qu'il savait faire monter un
mouvement le faire grossir l'inscrire
dans le temps et qui se déroule à peu
près calmement parce que c'est vrai que
les prés quand même dans la grande
Histoire des choses
par rapport à ce que on aurait pu
craindre le
tout se passe quand même un peu près
correctement
ils perdent les syndicats perdent quand
même pas de vue le fait que à la fin
c'est quand même les 64 ans qui jouent
parce que justement toujours dans cet
objectif
de renaissance des syndicats une
victoire aussi faible soit-elle mais une
victoire et un retrait donc un retrait
des 64 ans serait un coup de boost
beaucoup plus important que toutes les
manifestations bien organisées pour eux
donc ils espèrent ils font quand même
tout pour arriver à leur fin
effectivement après il ne nie pas que
les gens soient aussi présents pour
d'autres choses il pointe effectivement
l'inflation les pertes de pouvoir
d'achat qui sont aussi des des choses
qui peuvent pousser ou de nombreux
Français adjoindre à ces défilés
c'est défilé sur la forme des retraites
vous voyez sur cette image Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui est présent et on va
rester avec avec Vincent roseron puisque
le leader de la France insoumise devrait
s'exprimer dans un instant on voit
plusieurs députés de la France insoumise
avec lui il me semble que c'était avec
Coquerel de dos on le voit Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui semble prendre la parole
comment on rend on l'écoute
allez c'est bon là
alors siège qui me lance là
si j'étais pas besoin de médiation et
Elisabeth borne a dit on mettra pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
encore un peu je rappelle
je crois que
l'attitude de Madame borne
ne nous laisse au fond la possibilité
que d'un seul mot d'ordre qu'elle s'en
aille elle et sa réforme et je crois que
c'était utile que des propositions
soient faites
Laurent Berger la flèche j'en ai fait
moi aussi une qui était de remettre tout
le dossier des retraites au conseil
d'administration de la sécurité sociale
et ce pouvoir ne veut
rien sinon que de faire passer de force
son texte par conséquent
depuis le soir du 49-3 et de la motion
de censure surtout la France marche hors
des clous
et c'est à nous de trouver un chemin
mais il ne nous en est pas laissé
d'autres que de répéter retrait retrait
retrait inlassablement et de nous en
donner les moyens par tous les moyens
pacifiques et démocratiques qui sont à
notre portée la grève la manifestation
le blocage les rassemblements les
assemblées citoyennes de manière à être
à la hauteur de la liberté que nous
réclamons je rappelle que nous ne sommes
pas dans une querelle si j'ose dire ou
une
une dispute ordinaire nous parlons de
deux ans de vie qui sont dérobées
aux salariés c'est de ça dont on parle
le sujet ça n'est ni madame borne ni ses
fantasme ni monsieur Macron et ses
fantasmes et leurs besoins à tous les
deux incompréhensibles d'une autorité
brutale qu'ils affirment de manière
provocatrice c'est le droit que ces
personnes se sont données contre toute
majorité parlementaire et populaire de
voler deux ans de vie aux gens voilà ce
dont ne veut pas le peuple français et
j'espère que cette manifestation
aujourd'hui qui va être très ample qui
voit l'entrée massive de la Genèse dans
la lutte va se dérouler tout au long
dans le sang-froid et le contrôle par
nous-mêmes face à toutes les
provocations je demande à tout le monde
de bien comprendre qu'un ministre de
l'Intérieur qui est capable d'organiser
un traquenard comme celui qui a été mis
en place afin de Soline est absolument
capable de toutes les provocations à
chacun d'entre nous de faire preuve de
sang-froid et de volonté d'action
Pacifique car la violence et le moyen
qu'utilise le ministre de l'Intérieur
pour invisibiliser le mouvement social
et la propre maîtrise que ce mouvement a
de l'huile
du modèle dit qu'il faut prendre cette
main tendue de Laurent Berger est-ce que
c'est un tournant est-ce que la majorité
est en train de se fissurer alors je
pense qu'il y a dans la majorité des
gens qui ont déjà été élus et qui avant
d'être ministre ou président de la
République on fait l'expérience du
suffrage universel du rapport de
conviction alors ces gens-là sont
beaucoup plus normaux que les illuminés
qui nous dirigent et ils se rendent
compte que ici c'est la France et c'est
pas un pays qui se mène à coup de trick
il faut quel que soit la force qu'on
reconnaît à la loi et l'idée qu'on sait
de la Constitution il faut aussi qu'il y
a un consentement à l'autorité c'est la
règle de toute manière de toute façon de
de gouverner un grand peuple voilà donc
je qu'en effet beaucoup de gens dans la
majorité
relatives car vous voudrez bien vous
rappeler qu'il n'y a pas de majorité ce
disque tout ça est fou que cette manière
de provoquer continuellement le peuple
français ne mène nulle part
quoi
mais protéger
mais c'est une activité c'est la lutte
la liberté elle ne se négocie pas elle
se pratique la pratique de notre liberté
c'est que nous voulons pas de la
retraite à 64 ans ça me paraît clair il
n'y a pas de légitimité parlementaire
nous sommes paraît-il une démocratie
nous sommes en train d'évoluer vers un
mode autoritaire que tout le monde
constate et est violent autoritaire et
violent et donc que faut-il faire et
bien continuer c'est la seule chose qui
est à notre portée qu'est-ce que vous
voulez qu'on fasse d'autres et bien
c'est une volonté contre une autre celle
du peuple français contre capucins de
personnes au gouvernement qui prétendent
avoir le dernier mot qui ne l'auront pas
donc je le redis la lutte continue elle
doit continuer jusqu'au retrait et
puisque les deux vont ensemble le
retrait et le départ de Madame born
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que nous
fassions d'autres que de maintenir notre
avis et bien le voici il est dans la rue
quel est votre meilleur arme le Conseil
constitutionnel ou les manifestations
dans la rue
la meilleure garantie que l'on est c'est
de s'occuper soi-même de ses affaires et
il est évident que
le meilleur dispositif qu'on a c'est la
grève c'est l'assemblée citoyenne qui
bloque à rond-point ce sont ces choses
là après le Conseil constitutionnel
évidemment un très grand pouvoir le
Conseil constitutionnel a déjà abrogé un
24 décembre toute une loi de finance
alors pardon parce que ça n'avait pas
respecté la forme par conséquent le
Conseil constitutionnel peut
parfaitement dire que comme ce
gouvernement a pour la première fois de
l'histoire les Boutabout tous les
dispositifs autoritaires ils annulent
parce que c'est pas ça une démocratie
parlementaire mais mais quand va-t-on
s'arrêter
écoutez j'ai tellement vu de choses au
long de ma vie de militants que je suis
très surpris du temps qu'on prend
vis-à-vis de moi et des insoumis
alors nous voici accusés d'à peu près
tout bon j'y vois une diversion mais je
me dis à la fin ça se termine comment
est-ce qu'ils ont en plus la tension
d'interdire les insoumis est-ce que le
président Macron s'imagine qu'il va
appliquer l'article 16 pour lutter
contre le dangereux révolutionnaire que
je suis en effet et d'autres enfin tout
ça est une mauvaise plaisanterie il est
temps maintenant de traiter le seul et
unique problème qu'il a sous les yeux
c'est-à-dire ces millions de braves gens
qui ne veulent pas de la retraite à 64
ans vous avez compris cette fois-ci
Président on n'en veut pas voilà voilà
qui est simple et clair et ça va durer
le temps qu'il faudra on en veut pas
voilà une suspension vous irez à défaut
d'un retrait une suspension de deux
moules apparemment je ne suis pas invité
à négocier ni moi ni les insoumis ni la
nuit Pesse alors que ce dont c'est le
rôle s'en charge et nous verrons bien ce
que nous verrons voilà ils prennent leur
responsabilités moi je prends les
miennes au nom de mes amis insoumis qui
est d'appeler à la lutte et à la
persévérance dans la lutte après
nous verrons nous suivons
les institutions lui répondaient quoi il
a pas tort mais nous n'y avons jamais
cru donc c'est pas une nouveauté c'est
marqué dans notre programme nous sommes
partisans du passage à une sixième
république et savez-vous pourquoi c'est
parce que nous considérons que la
Cinquième République a un contenu
monarchique qui vient d'éclater sous les
yeux de tout le monde pendant cette
affaire de retraite mais par contre ce
que je peux dire c'est que n'étant pas
partisan de la Cinquième République il
me semble que je la respecte davantage
que le Président de la République
lui-même parce que si quelqu'un est en
train d'élégitimer les institutions
c'est bien lui avec les méthodes
brutales qui l'utilisent voilà
c'est bon merci à tout le monde
[Musique]
très favorable le fait que certains
politiques s'en mêlent et surtout tous
les syndicats n'ont pas la même
proximité avec les mêmes partis
politiques donc dans le fait de vouloir
maintenir un inter syndical uni il a été
estimé préférable par tout le monde de
maintenir les
la France insoumise en particulier et
même les politiques en général hors des
cortèges enfin prêt libre à eux de venir
de manifester mais ils ne feront ils ne
sont pas les bienvenus dans le cortège
de tête on retrouve les syndicats bon
premier on en parle
semaine décisif pour la CGT
expliquez-moi ce qui se passe tout
simplement ce qui se passe c'est que
Philippe Martinez a annoncé de longue
date qu'il ne serait qu'il ne serait pas
candidat à sa propre succession son
mandat de 3 ans arrive à son terme il a
proposé une personne pour le remplacer
une dénommée Marie buisson qui vient de
l'éducation nationale voilà cette Ré
avec plusieurs mois un peu pour enfin le
film Martinet a essayé de lui mettre le
pied à l'étrier plusieurs mois voilà
pour pour en faire une candidate
légitime à son poste on la voit très peu
et on la voit très peu elle imprime pas
est-ce que c'est parce qu'elle est pas à
l'aise devant les caméras est-ce que je
n'en sais rien ça j'avoue que j'ai pas
le pas le fin mot de l'histoire le tout
est que elle n'a pas su euh
imposer sa légitimité il y a tout un
courant au sein de la CGT qui est
beaucoup plus radical que Philippe
Martinez c'est possible voilà et qui
préférerait voir quelqu'un de plus à
leur image à la tête de de la CGT et
donc tout ça a couvé pendant très
longtemps parce que comme la CGT c'est
bien le faire on fait pas trop éclater
les choses officiellement être plutôt en
coulisse donc pour le moment
on avait vend de réunions qui se passait
mal de choses comme ça mais ça restait
au sein des des organes internes et donc
depuis lundi le fameux 53e congrès qui
doivent voilà il y a un congrès il y a
le Congrès qui commence lundi
effectivement ça commence dans lundi qui
se termine vendredi et voilà qui là
cette fois toutes les toutes les colères
toutes les toutes les luttes qui étaient
un peu cachés ressortent au grand jour
et donc effectivement on voit des
tensions entre plusieurs courants en
ACGT voilà qui ont commencé des lundis
et qui pourrait continuer vendredi soir
il y aura un nouveau secrétaire général
à la CGT vendredi matin même vendredi
matin l'annonce doit avoir lieu le
vendredi matin si tout se passe bien
donc vous m'avez parlé de Marie buisson
qui finalement semble retrouver un peu
en difficulté alors qu'elle avait
visiblement une avenue pour succéder à
Philippe Martinez on évoquait Olivier
matheux tout à l'heure et il y a
d'autres noms un autre nom qui est
ressorti celui Céline verzedetti
exactement donc Marie buisson et ses
libertés sont les deux candidatures les
plus sérieux si je veux dire Olivier
matheux étant quand même je vous ai trop
radical voilà alors bon on est la CGT à
l'habitude de créer des surprises on se
rappelle qu'en 2013 plusieurs candidats
étaient aussi
en position pour prendre le poste et
puis finalement c'est un Thierry Lepan
qui sortait un peu de nulle part qui
avait fini par l'avoir donc je j'ai pas
de boule de cristal je me méfierai mais
à l'heure actuelle les deux candidatures
les plus sérieux sont effectivement donc
celle de Marie buisson poussée par le
bureau actuel dont Philippe Martinez et
donc Céline Verzeletti à la fois pas
trop éloigné du bureau actuel et en même
temps
ayant un profil jugé plus compatible
plus
vindicatif et qui donc conviendrait
mieux pour faire une sorte de synthèse
entre les différents courants il va
disparaître presque du jour au lendemain
si les partenaires c'est à dire que s'il
y a une nouvelle manifestation la
semaine prochaine ce qui peut être le
cas Thomas on n'imagine pas les
syndicats de dire ça y est on arrête
dans la tête du cortège à côté de
Laurent Berger il y aura une autre
personnalité il y aura effectivement une
autre personnalité alors techniquement
même aujourd'hui enfin Philippe Martinez
n'est déjà plus le secrétaire général de
la société le premier jour du concret
donc hier on élit un Comité pour la
durée du Congrès qui donc est venu
remplacer et Martinez donc bien sûr
surtout en l'absence d'un autre
secrétaire général il était la
personnalité publique numéro 1 à
Clermont-Ferrand donc il a toujours été
très visible mais effectivement
il a dit qu'il continuerait à manifester
mais il n'aura plus le même rôle dès la
semaine prochaine effectivement grand
j'ai une dernière question avant de vous
relâcher il est 15h03 nous sommes en
direct pour suivre cette nouvelle
journée de manifestation il y a beaucoup
de jeunes dans la la manifestation
depuis l'utilisation du 49-3 il d'après
deux semaines
le nombre de jeunes dans les cortèges
ont explosé ça c'est à prendre en compte
évidemment parce que dans l'Inter
syndical il y a les syndicats de jeunes
tout à fait tout à fait alors aussi
alors il y a effectivement le 49.3 qui a
dû pousser beaucoup de jeunes
sur un moment plus inquiet pour la
démocratie pour leur retraite dans la
rue mais surtout de façon beaucoup plus
de terre à terre il y a les épreuves du
bac oui qui sont passés les épreuves
spécialisées et forcément forcément
une fois libéré de cette contrainte les
jeunes enfin les organisations jeunes il
est jeune en général ce sont plus
massivement mobilisés voilà
effectivement c'est un bol d'air assez
salvateur pour les syndicats puisque
là où certains travailleurs pouvaient
commencer à attirer la langue
financièrement et puis après plusieurs
semaines de mobilisation grève et ben
toutes ces personnes qui baissent un peu
les bras ont été remplacés par une
arrivée effectivement massive de jeunes
qu'on voit qu'on voit très clairement
dans les cortèges qui sont pas mal mis
en avant par les syndicats merci
beaucoup
en grand d'être venu sur ce plateau
alors ce que je vous propose c'est qu'on
garde cette cette image évidemment de la
rue parce que c'est très important cette
nouvelle journée de mobilisation la
dixième contre la réforme des retraites
et puis on écoute ce qu'il se passe à
l'Assemblée nationale parce qu'il y a
les questions au Gouvernement cet
après-midi les questions qui ont
l'imagine seront axés sur cette réforme
des retraites merci beaucoup Thomas
grand on jette une oreille à l'Assemblée
nationale et puis on revient dans
quelques instants la capitalisation la
capacité à préparer leur avenir la
capacité à investir ils l'ont ils l'ont
toujours eu et ils seront toujours
sortir ce qui m'intéresse et ce qui
m'inquiète le plus sont ceux justement
qui n'ont pas les moyens de préparer
l'avenir et c'est pour eux que nous
sauvons ce système de retraite c'est
parce que la réforme que nous portons
permet de conserver un système de
retraite qui leur permettra eux les plus
fragiles d'avoir un revenu descend une
fois lors du repos arrivée
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
allez-y monstres
que les propos du groupe GDR
n'appelaient aucune réponse du
gouvernement
la seule réponse qui vaille pour nous
désormais c'est le vote des Français
seuls dénouement démocratique dont nous
ne doutons pas qu'il sanctionne
définitivement le retrait de cette
réforme
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Marie Fiévet
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer ce samedi
25 mars à Sainte-Soline nos efforts nos
forces de l'ordre ont été la cible de
plusieurs milliers d'individus radicaux
violents
infiltrés dans les manifestation non
autorisée contre les réserves de
substitution et armées de cocktail
Molotov de mortier de hache et d'autres
projectiles très dangereux
face à cette violence résultat d'une
tristesse accablante nous avons assisté
à des scènes d'affrontements choquantes
au cours desquelles des véhicules de nos
forces de l'ordre ont été incendiés et
de nombreuses personnes blessées
je tiens d'ailleurs au nom du groupe
Renaissance à souhaiter un bon
établissement à tous les blessés ainsi
qu'à apporter nos soutiens à nos forces
de l'ordre pour leur engagement
qui
[Applaudissements]
récupère j'ai aussi une pensée pour nos
sapeurs-pompiers des Deux-Sèvres et pour
le SAMU qui a su répondre présent mais
également pour nous agriculteurs qui
subissent depuis plusieurs mois
dégradation et menaces face à ces images
intolérables et à l'inverse des élus de
la nupes présents à manifestation ou qui
se réjouissent des ordres sociales au
point de lancer des fake news en allant
jusqu'à annoncer hier la mort d'un
manifestants j'en appelle à l'apaisement
et à la raison
non non déplaise à certains notre
démocratie prévoit le droit aux
opposants de manifester pacifiquement
mais en aucun cas l'usage de la violence
et les manifestations illégales ainsi
Monsieur le Ministre pourriez-vous nous
indiquer quelle mesure vendez-vous
prendre face à des événements d'une
violence inacceptable personne au-dessus
de nos lois et de telles affrontements
ne peuvent et ne doivent se reproduire
quelle mesure prévoyez-vous vis-à-vis
des organisateurs tels que les
collectifs bassines non merci ou encore
l'association le soulèvement de la terre
qui était à l'initiative de cette
manifestation bien qu'elle soit
interdite je vous remercie je vous
remercie mon cher collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente permettez-moi
madame la Présidente tout d'abord
d'avoir au nom de l'après ministre et du
gouvernement une pensée pour le maréchal
des logis chefs Arnaud blanc militaire
du GIGN mort en mission voilà quelques
jours malheureusement en Guyane
[Applaudissements]
merci pour pour lui pour le GIGN et pour
sa famille monsieur le député vous
m'interrogez dans votre département vous
le savez ce week-end c'est passé des
événements inqualifiables la préfète des
Deux-Sèvres depuis plusieurs jours
depuis le 17 mars avait interdite la
manifestation à Sainte-Soline et aux
abords de sainte Soline et par deux
conférences de presse et par celle de
Monsieur le Procureur de la République
chacun connaissait cette interdiction de
manifestation nous avons parce que nous
savions malheureusement depuis six mois
et le premier événement à Sainte Céline
qui avait déjà fait naître 61 gendarmes
blessés dans plusieurs très gravement
des confrontations radicales avec comme
vous l'avez dit des violences
inacceptables contre les biens et
surtout contre les personnes évidemment
les 47 militaires de la gendarmerie mais
également plusieurs manifestants et je
veux aussi avoir une pensée pour ceux
qui luttent pour la vie en ce moment et
pour les blesser et je veux dire bien
évidemment notre compassion à chacune et
chacun puisque aucune cause ne peut
justifier ces violences cependant je
constate comme vous l'extrême violence
de certains groupuscules ont les
services de renseignement des montres
qui sont à la fois fichés par les
services de renseignement parfois depuis
de très nombreuses années et qui sont
responsables de grandes violences et je
pense notamment évidemment au groupement
de faits des soulèvements de la terre
plusieurs envahissements d'entreprises
plusieurs exactions fortes contre les
forces de l'ordre plusieurs destructions
de biens plusieurs des centaines de
gendarmes ou de policiers blessés
plusieurs en effet appel à
l'insurrection j'ai donc décidé
d'engager la dissolution des
soulèvements de la terre
que je proposerai après contradictoire à
un prochain conseil des ministres
je
[Musique]
je vous rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de
Gérald Darmanin le ministre de
l'Intérieur depuis l'Assemblée nationale
où se déroule en ce moment les questions
au Gouvernement Christophe Cornavin
bonjour bonjour tiens c'est lié tout ça
sans solide les manifestations de jeudi
dernier il y a un climat de violence en
ce moment oui en fait les pouvoirs
publics pensent qu'il y a une alliance
objective en tout cas vers avec le
ciment de l'ultra gauche entre
les échos guerriers et les casseurs de
sainte Soline et les et les apôtres de
la guérilla urbaine à Paris c'est les
mêmes c'est les mêmes personnes
d'ailleurs le préfet de police pas plus
tard que que samedi avait déjà anticipé
le fait que les émeutiers de
sainte-soling viennent gonfler les rangs
de la de la de la manifestation des
casseurs de la manifestation
d'aujourd'hui à Paris et là on vient de
je vais recevoir un message de la qui
alors où l'on parle me dit qu'il y a un
bloc de plusieurs centaines de personnes
qui viennent se constituer et qui se
colle à la tête du cortège syndical et
il est en train de tenter de bloquer la
progression d'un manifestance
c'est-à-dire que on a on risque quand
même pour l'instant même si sur les sur
nos images c'est ça l'assemble plutôt
calme on peut quand même se préparer à
une fin de de manifestation agitée il
faut quand même savoir que on l'avait vu
la semaine dernière place de l'Opéra
dans la dernière manif il y a eu de
jeudi il y a eu 450
il y avait eu plus de 900 feux qui avait
été allumés sur le le
parcours du défilé à Sainte Soline en
fait c'est c'est la même chose
c'est-à-dire que moi j'ai noté là il y a
eu un petit bilan qui a été fait juste
avant
les manifestations à Sainte Soline pour
essayer de désarmer les les gens qui qui
voulaient qui voulaient s'en prendre au
gendarmes et avant même qu'ils passent à
la source les forces de l'ordre leur ont
retiré 62 couteaux 67 boules de pétanque
avant même qu'il passe à la sauce 62
couteaux 67 boules de pétanque 6 bidons
d'essence d'une dizaine de pierres et de
parpaing des haches 13h et machette des
matraques des battes de baseball des
bombes aérosols et près de 70 équipement
et une centaine de de d'outils diverses
et variés qui normalement certes à faire
de l'agriculture mais en l'espèce était
plutôt là pour faire mal aux forces de
l'ordre donc c'est à dire qu'en fait on
est vraiment sur une espèce de de de de
contest constellation rouge et noir que
l'on a vu à l'oeuvre à Paris jeudi que
l'on a vu à l'œuvre à Sainte Soline ce
week-end et que nous risquons hélas de
revoir de nouveau à l'oeuvre ce soir
dans la capitale si effectivement ce
premier bloc là qui est en train de se
former passe à l'action nous avons ces
images en direct pour l'instant les
images place de la République des images
dans le cortège en haut à droite et puis
l'Assemblée nationale ou se déroule en
ce moment les questions gouvernement
nous verrons dans un instant si nous
avons des questions sur cette réforme
des retraites à Elisabeth borne
notamment on a entendu il y a un instant
Gérald Darmanin donc vous me dites que
les manifestants de sainte-solin ce
week-end sont les mêmes que les casseurs
sont les mêmes que ceux que nous avons
vu jeudi et que nous verrons peut-être
plus tard dans la journée alors ce sont
peut-être pas forcément tous les mêmes
c'est-à-dire que en fait dans la dans la
manifestation de jeudi nous on avait
interrogé les notamment les forces de
l'ordre qui avait procédé aux quelques
450 interpellations et il
il savait que dans une grande majorité
des cas ceux qui a été interpellé
c'était à ceux qui étaient les plus
novices les moins expérimentés ceux qui
ne connaissent pas justement ces
techniques de guérir urbaine dont on
parlait à l'instant et donc beaucoup de
Lyciens beaucoup de collégiens
qui sont venus
finalement je chat à la souris et
parfois aller plus en avant encore
contre les forces de l'ordre mais
avant autour de il y a des des meneurs
et ces meneurs là qui comme l'a dit
préfet de police qui est assez bien
renseigné j'imagine
font un peu ce greffe un petit peu
surtout tous les mouvements sociaux qui
sont de nature à pouvoir semer le trou
derrière c'est à dire que entre vous et
moi je pense que ils sont pas Thibault
forcément tout à fait préoccupé par la
pénibilité au travail ou par l'âge pivot
64 ans vraiment pas de réforme des
retraites sur cette question mais plus
du tout c'est à dire qu'en fait eux ils
sont dans une logique qui est celle de
la de la de la casse de la casse
républicaine de la de de de l'attaque
contre les symboles du capitalisme
contre les les assauts contre les forces
de l'ordre et peu importe finalement la
cause pourvu qu'ils aient l'ivresse de
la violence et et là on est
véritablement dans ce dans ce schéma là
et et et et et ce n'est pas forcément
qu'un fanman Français parce que on s'est
rendu compte qu'à sainte Soline et les
étranges il y avait des étrangers
notamment des des Italiens des Allemands
il faut quand même rappeler que le
berceau a des Black Blocs sont que ces
fameux schwarzen block dont on a déjà
parlé à Berlin dans les années à
expliquer voilà dans le Barlin dans les
années 80 donc des donc c'est vraiment
le perso des Black Blocs et et talent et
il y a encore des des éléments qui ont
qui ont franchi le rein pour être pour
être dans les Deux-Sèvres ce week-end et
qu'on attend et là ça à Paris parce que
il y a cette cette culture européenne de
la de la détestation du capitalisme ou
qu'il soit que ce soit dans les grands
sommets internationaux l'OTAN le G7 etc
etc nous sommes toujours en direct avec
Erik sotti qui pose une question au
gouvernement vous avez aperçu en haut à
droite Fabien Roussel il y a quelques
instants on essaiera de l'entendre n'est
pas loin on essaiera d'interroger le
leader des comics qui n'est visiblement
pas dans l'Assemblée nationale
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui
on est entré dans autre chose depuis
jeudi dernier et j'en reviens à
Christophe assez manifestations avec un
symbole hier Gérald Darmanin le ministre
de l'Intérieur vous voyez ici à l'image
en direct c'est exprimé il est venu
avant la manifestation ça c'était une
première pourquoi pour montrer que
l'ordre est à l'état en fait il est
d'après moi il est venu pour pour deux
raisons c'est à dire que
il a de hier vous l'avez peut-être
remarqué de ni beaucoup de solennités à
sa prise de parole c'est-à-dire que il
aurait pu le faire comme il aurait pu le
faire à l'occasion au gouvernement il
aurait pu le faire
là
le pupitre à Bovo il venait de il venait
de rencontrer les directeurs généraux de
la police et de la gendarmerie les
responsables des services de
renseignement et l'idée était selon moi
de dire deux choses un c'était pour
solenniser un peu
l'idée selon laquelle effectivement on a
changé de on a changé de paradigme en
quelques jours c'est à dire que depuis
trois mois qui est lancé ce mouvement de
protestation sociale tout le monde se
félicitait du calme relatif et de
l'esprit de Concorde qui pouvait même si
évidemment des noms régulièrement ici on
en parlait on voyait quelques
affrontements très minimes et puis tout
rentrer dans le calme assez vite et tout
d'un coup il y a eu cette ce fameux 16
tout à fait niveau se basculement du 16
mars qui
tout d'un coup c'est c'est traduit par
une espèce de bouffée de violence c'est
le jour de l'utilisation du 49-3 voilà
avec 40 je peux vous le dire d'ailleurs
nous étions avec Julien Leclerc qui est
dans la manifestations aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée nationale ce jour-là nous
sommes partis place de la Concorde donc
tout de suite le soir il y a eu un
rassemblement avec tout de suite des
jeunes et tout de suite des violences
oui c'est à dire qu'en brandissant le
49-3 j'ai l'impression que le sang le
savoir le gouvernement a appuyé sur un
sur un bouton qui est qui a déclenché la
violence Christophe on y revient
évidemment mais d'abord on va sur le
terrain Vincent roserand vous êtes avec
Fabien Roussel il n'est pas dans
l'hémicycle aujourd'hui le leader des
communistes il et même d'ailleurs que il
ne voyait plus vraiment à quoi ça
servait de siéger dans le à l'Assemblée
nationale puisque l'assemblée n'était
plus écoutée
[Musique]
là finalement la réforme des retraites
depuis peu de temps oui il y a une
convergence depuis qu'il a suscité la
colère des Français avec l'usage du 49-3
oui il y a une convergence de plus en
plus grande entre les jeunes et le monde
du travail c'est une nouveauté dans le
mouvement aujourd'hui les jeunes c'est
vraiment la est-ce qu'il pourrait faire
basculer cette réforme des retraites
c'est l'enjeu vous permettez que j'aille
saluer bien sûr
alors comme vous voyez voilà ce sont les
jeunes communistes qui sont là
c'est le cortège de la communiste et
donc forcément Fabien Roussel va les
saluer comme c'est le cas à chaque
manifestation il y aura des avis qui
revenaient juste après
merci Vincent Rozon il a peut-être
encore de questions
ça devient Roussel il s'est enfui on le
voit
en fond ça veut dire Rousselle le point
levé alors on parlait de ces
manifestations de Gérald Darmanin qui
est venu hier parler aux journalistes
s'adresser aux Français d'une certaine
manière parce que de nombreux casseurs
sont attendus est-ce que vous avez des
chiffres 1400 c'est ça
effectivement près d'un près d'un
millier de casseurs c'est paradoxalement
un peu moins que ce que le nombre de
casseurs qui avait été répertorié le
jeudi dernier parce qu'on parlait plutôt
de 2500 mais après il faut savoir il
faut voir quels sont le profil des
casseurs parce que jeudi dernier donc
comme on l'a on l'a souligné parmi les
casseurs il y a figurait quand même pas
mal de pas mal de jeunes qui étaient pas
forcément donc très aguerris si
effectivement sur le millet de casseurs
là on a véritablement des gens qui sont
aux techniques
des Black Blocs dont qu'on a pu à
présenter actuellement je pense là
effectivement il y aura beaucoup de fil
à retordre pour les pour les forces de
l'ordre Christophe Fabien Roussel a tenu
progressive les revenus Vincent s'il
vous plaît posez cette question à Fabien
Roussel demandez-lui de préciser sa
pensée lorsqu'il nous a dit j'hésite à
siéger encore au Parlement parce que ça
ne sert plus à grand chose peut-il nous
dire ce qu'il voulait dire par là oui
l'accélération de la réforme
oui alors je vais essayer de lui poser
la question
vous vous interrogez d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui vous n'êtes pas à
l'Assemblée nationale et vous interrogé
sur votre rôle à l'Assemblée nationale
récemment c'est ça ouais aujourd'hui oui
je fais le choix délibéré d'être ici
avec les salariés et la jeunesse mais le
groupe communiste et GDR est présent
puisque mes collègues ubervulfranc
Sébastien Jumel interrogero le
gouvernement encore une fois
pour leur demander de retirer cette
réforme et nous ne lâcherons rien
là-dessus nous continuerons nous
continuerons tous ensemble de demander
le retrait de la réforme à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est pour ça que je vous dis
que le gouvernement est dans une
position intelable je vois pas comment
ils peuvent mettre à l'ordre du jour des
textes de loi important et y compris une
réforme institutionnelle c'est
impossible pour ils sont coincés et
c'est quoi la suite alors on attend je
vous conseille constitutionnel et on
continue à faire des manifestations si
le gouvernement ne veut pas rester
immobile comme il le disent qu'il retire
leur réformes et puis on va travailler
mais là pour l'instant c'est pas
possible mais vous avez entendu Olivier
Véran ce midi Olivier du soft c'est
Emmanuel Macron est-ce que vous y croyez
non mais Olivier vérances apporte-parole
une porte que de la parole c'est du vent
et donc j'attends maintenant que le
Président de la République prennent une
décision d'accepter la main tendue des
syndicats de se mettre autour de la
table
et d'annoncer la suspension de la
réforme merci beaucoup
en bâton alors des armes par destination
notamment des des pédales de vélo qui
peuvent ceux qui peuvent se manipuler en
comme une espèce de rouet pour pour
frapper sur les forces on les avait pas
encore vu celle-là il y a même des
tenues il y a une photo là qui vient
d'être diffusé d'un manifestant qui qui
est venu
soi-disant
protesté contre la femme des retraites
mais sur lui il a une véritable tenue de
de Robocop avec des avec une avec des
joues des genouillères des coudières une
espèce de protège thorax des épaulettes
etc
quasiment toutes les manifestations
ensemble depuis le mois de janvier vous
me disiez oui quelques interpellations
une vingtaine une trentaine on a
retrouvé quelques là c'est tout à fait
autre chose là on change là on est
vraiment on a changé de on a changé de
de dimensions de braquet on est passé
sur des sur des gens qui vraiment faire
mal il faut quand même rappeler que
depuis le 16 mars dernier le ministère
de l'Intérieur a fait état de
891 policiers et gendarmes
blessés dans le cadre d'action violente
qui sont généralement menés
en dehors des cortèges traditionnels
mais lors donc des cortèges sauvages ce
qui fait du 90
90 victimes par jour dans les forces de
l'ordre
donc il y a vraiment il y a vraiment on
a changé de cap et c'est pour ça que
pour finir et répondre plus précisément
à votre question si le ministre de
l'Intérieur à a pris la parole c'est
pour attirer l'attention hier voilà à la
place de la Place Beauvau c'est juste
pour pour montrer que on est quand même
on est rentré dans quelque chose de
différent que le que le pays est en
train de chavirer ou en tout cas
pourrait chavirer dans un dans un
épisode qui pourra prendre des
formations incontrôlables et donc ça lui
a permis de d'appeler au calme d'appeler
au calme les manifestants d'appeler au
calme les syndicats peut-être lui aussi
le le la sagesse ou en tout cas le
professionnelisme des syndicats mais
c'est aussi une posture politique le
gouvernement veut incarner l'ordre et
alors si on va dans la posture politique
on peut effectivement dire qu'il y a une
incarnation de l'ordre et puis on peut
amener plus loin c'est que en disant ça
on peut imaginer que le gouvernement
cherche aussi à faire en sorte de vider
la salle faire en sorte que plus on dise
qu'une manifestation violente moins
il y aura de monde parce que bah oui et
d'ailleurs c'est c'est vrai parce que
à force de dire que les que les cortèges
sont devenus
hyper dangereux et qui à chaque fois un
grand nombre de blessés les retraités
qui étaient là pendant notamment les
quatre cinq six septième et 8e journée
nationale d'action ne sont plus là les
familles ont disparu aussi du décor ne
reste maintenant que les militants
syndicaux et les casseurs qui qui
veulent en découdre à la tête du cortège
et ça c'est tout à fait nouveau je
voudrais juste souligner une dernière
chose qui est importante dans le corps
dans le cortège parisien je ne sais pas
si on peut avoir cette cette
confirmation depuis le terrain avec nos
reporteurs mais il est
il est il est apparu notamment sur les
sur les réseaux sociaux et j'ai pas
confirmation police non plus mais ça a
l'air sérieux que le service d'ordre de
la CGT qui est extrêmement précieux dans
ce genre de de de de de de garantie de
de calme dans le ne sera pas là
aujourd'hui alors je vous convient tout
de suite puisque Thomas grand est avec
nous il y a de ça une petite demi-heure
spécialiste des syndicats nous expliquer
que non le service de l'ordre de la CGT
n'était pas présent pour la simple et
bonne raison qu'il y a un congrès de la
CGT ce week-end que ce congrès a lieu à
Clermont-Ferrand et que donc la CG est à
Clermont-Ferrand depuis lundi donc non
en effet Christophe je vous confirme il
n'y a pas de des gros bras de la CGT
comme comme on les appelle
donc c'est vraiment une information qui
est assez inquiétante parce que
ils étaient là ça n'a pas serviable
grand chose
d'endiguer totalement la montée de
violence non ça n'a pas permis mais
pendant les 8 premiers jours je peux
vous promettre que ça a beaucoup aidé et
le fait que le fait qu'elle ne soit pas
là ben ça peut ça peut laisser
apparaître des failles assez importantes
dans le dans le dans le dans le dans la
dans le dans la dans le dans les rangs
des manifestants traditionnels que bien
sûr cherche à pénétrer en permanence les
casseurs parce que pour eux c'est
véritablement il se sert beaucoup de la
foule d'entraînement donc c'est à dire
de ceux qui seraient là pour manifester
pacifiquement à la base voyons c'est
violence pourrait suivre les questions
alors que le service d'art de j'étais
lui retient ce genre de débordement
la CGT a tout intérêt à ce que ce
mouvement reste reste un mouvement
social ou des revendications puissent
s'exprimer de manière
claire et intelligible et à partir du
moment où les Black Blocs confisquent la
parole et l'intention des médias
évidemment pour pour la CGT pour toutes
les organisations pour toute la terre
syndicale c'est une catastrophe et donc
le fait que les services d'ordre
puissent garantir l'intégrité du du
cordon du du défilé habituel c'est
absolument essentiel s'il y a pas ça les
Black Box risque de passer à l'action et
de retourner après dans parmi la foule
pour se cacher et faire comme ça des
stops and go
technique de harcèlement et après
trouver refuge dans les parmi les
manifestants et ce serait extrêmement
dur à gérer derrière on a eu des
chiffres 13000 policiers et gendarmes
déployés par tout en France la dernière
fois qu'il y avait autant de moyens
c'était lors de la demi-finale France
Maroc au modèle 2022
[Musique]
parce qu'en fait parce que ça veut dire
que vous avez quand même c'est 13000
personnes en plus parce que c'est pas
13000 policiers pour toute la France
c'est 13000 personnes qui sont figées
sur cette mission là d'accord
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait après il y a
tous les autres policiers qui font
habituels de circulation
anti-criminalité en cas de PSG etc que
là il y a on a de dire que là je pense
que le ministère de l'Intérieur a puisé
dans ces dans ces réserves pour pour
pouvoir mettre sur l'étagère autant
d'hommes ça veut dire c'est 90 unités de
force mobile c'est à dire 80 ensemble
soit de gendarmes mobiles soit de CRS
qui ont été qui ont été mobilisés
aujourd'hui ça fait 5500 personnes à
Paris
faut pas complètement saturé de deux
chiffres mais il faut quand même
considérer que effectivement c'est c'est
des ambiances de de finale ou de
demi-finale de la Coupe du monde ça va
être CDC des très très grands événements
comme le 14 juillet ou voilà c'est c'est
on est vraiment à l'acné d'une
mobilisation policière et et a priori je
pense que c'est aussi un signe de la de
la fin si une forme de crainte
qu'actuellement l'exécutif de voir tout
d'un coup ce mouvement complètement
dévissé quoi donc et c'est pour ça
qu'ils mettent le paquet que les soldats
question de me rappeliez ce que vous
nous avez dit en arrivant sur ce live
vous avez une boucle avec toutes les
informations une boucle de message un
bloc un black bloc ce serait constitué
alors pour l'instant nous on n'a pas
d'image moi dans la boue dans un instant
si lui il a vu quelque chose qu'est-ce
qu'on vous dit sur cette bique donc à
14h38 donc un peu moins d'une heure
presque une heure un bloc de plusieurs
c'est joli un bloc de plusieurs
centaines de personnes c'est constitué
ils le cortège syndical de tête il
bloque la progression des manifestants
sur l'itinéraires à ce stade peu après
cette même boucle police fait état de à
15 heures donc il y a une demi-heure de
18 interpellés ce que veut dire qu'on
n'est pas non plus encore dans quelque
chose de de particulièrement dentiste on
peut pas dire mais 18 interpellés ça
montre que déjà il y a comme un
frémissement
et on voit qu'il y a un itinéraire bis
qui vient d'être utilisé c'est à dire
que manifestement je vois à 15h11 donc à
20 minutes il y a eu une
séparation du cortège alors généralement
c'est pour éviter les thromboses faire
en sorte que quand le cortège s'il est
dans une dans un axe il ne soit pas trop
ralenti voir à l'arrêt il faut parce que
l'idée c'est qu'il faut qu'il reste un
peu dynamique qui continue à avancer
parce que jusqu'à maintenant le préfet
de police a toujours fait en sorte que
et parfois dans la douleur on l'a vu
jeudi le dernier que les cortèges
arrivent à bon terme et là il faut
absolument qu'ils arrivent à la à la
nation quitte à ce qu'il se sépare en
deux en deux branches merci beaucoup
Christophe Cornavin on va rejoindre tout
de suite Damien Canivez Damien comment
ça se passe autour de vous Christophe
nous disait qu'il y avait
potentiellement la formation d'un blog
d'un black bloc est-ce que c'est le cas
est-ce que pour l'instant c'est calme
nous avons des images nous sur ce ces
quatre écrans qui montrent que tout se
passe plutôt bien dites nous ce qu'il en
est Damien
c'est vrai que ça se passe plutôt dans
le calme pour le moment cette
manifestation Thibault Gauthier alors
peut-être que les contrôles en amont de
la de la manifestation donc Christophe
cordemain vient de parler ont porté
leurs fruits puisque 6400 contrôle ont
été effectués dans les nôtres je vous
rappelle puisque on a été contrôlé à
titre personnel à deux reprises ce qui
prouve bien que la police était
extrêmement présente aux abords de la
place de la République et je parle bien
de contrôle parce qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'arrestation préventive vous savez que
des leaders syndicaux enfin des leaders
de gauche notamment et et certains
militants ont accusé la préfecture de
police de Paris de de d'effectuer des
des arrestations préventives chose que
le préfet de tourisme a démenti et bien
il n'y a pas eu effectivement
d'arrestation préventive sous notre et
il faut dire que aujourd'hui le préfet
de police est regardé de très près
puisque la Défenseur des droits clair et
don est a priori la préfecture de police
de Paris elle a été invitée par le
préfet de police pour voir comment les
forces de l'ordre travailler sur le
terrain et peut-être aussi esclier à
cette à ce changement de doctrine mais
pour le moment vous le voyez sur les
images de Julien Leclerc nous sommes
arrivés place de la Nation point final
de cette manifestation et tout se
déroule pour le moment dans le calme
Christophe Cornavin avait parfaitement
raison de parler de Black Bloc qui s'est
constitué d'ailleurs assez tôt dans
cette manifestation puisque on a vu des
éléments voilà radicaux en habits en
noir comme on a l'habitude de le voir
maintenant depuis plusieurs semaines
dans les manifestations mais ils ne sont
pas passés à l'action voilà alors
peut-être que la stratégie de la police
a porté ses fruits peut-être le fait
d'encadrer cette manifestation comme ils
l'ont fait avec le cordon de gendarmerie
a fonctionné en attendant c'est plutôt
calme les manifestants sont au centre de
cette place de la Nation et sont en
train voilà de de terminer leur marche
qui s'est amorcée tout à l'heure place
de la République à 14h à Paris
nous dit que certains manifestants sont
déjà arrivés place de la Nation alors il
y a deux itinéraires un qui partaient de
best de République directement vers la
place de la Nation qui contournait par
la place de la Bastille donc vous voyez
encore mal de monde dans les dans les
cortèges pour barietti bonjour
journaliste au service société du Figaro
spécialiste des des questions de
jeunesse d'éducation ils sont là les
jeunes ils sont là ils sont là on
l'avait déjà vu jeudi dernier et puis là
ils sont de retour dans les rues ce
mardi pour la dixième journée de
mobilisation c'est pas forcément
d'ailleurs leur dixième journée de
mobilisation ce qu'on va le voir
ensemble je pense ça fait pas si
longtemps que ça qu'il y a autant de
jeunes mobilisés
de passer ces dernières semaines une
petite idée mais vous allez nous
expliquer tout ça pour que les jeunes se
mobilisent tout à coup alors le gros
virage c'est vraiment la semaine
dernière on a bien vu avec tout ce qui
s'est passé autour notamment de
l'utilisation par le gouvernement à
l'Assemblée du 49-3 ça c'est vrai que ça
a beaucoup des plus à pas mal de gens
d'ailleurs mais y compris aux jeunes ce
week-end il y a quelque chose qui est
venu par-dessus c'est tout ce qui s'est
passé autour de la méga bassine de
sainte Soline toutes les violences qui a
eu c'est vrai que là les jeunes on sent
qu'ils sont entrés dans une contestation
non pas tellement du projet de réforme
des retraites un petit peu mais c'est
lointain pour beaucoup d'entre eux mais
aussi contre vraiment tout le système
contre le régime contre Emmanuel Macron
d'ailleurs on le voit dans les slogans
au-delà des retraites on appelle à des
choses beaucoup plus larges à une
mobilisation de la jeunesse beaucoup
plus large
mais je regardais cette image en haut à
gauche Damien canivelle il y a un
instant nous expliquer que la
manifestation arrive la nation certains
ne sont pas encore parti comme vous
voyez de la place de la République
l'utilisation de ce 49-3 ça a tout
déclenché
on sent que c'est et d'ailleurs on le
sent aussi bien dans la bouche des
étudiants des lycéens des jeunes
mobilisés que de leur responsables
syndicaux de jeunesse etc que c'est
vraiment ça qui a fait qui a fait
basculer un peu le mouvement d'ailleurs
beaucoup de gens l'attendaient parce que
c'est vrai que quand la jeunesse se
mobilise comme d'ailleurs parfois
d'autres tranches de la société mais
c'est toujours un signal que voilà ça
prend de l'ampleur et là c'est vrai
qu'on a l'impression que c'est ce qui se
passe il faudra attendre ce soir pour
voir vraiment si la mobilisation a
augmenté selon
une note du renseignement territorial
qui était cité par nos confrères de BFM
de renseignement territorial avait
estimé à 30000 le nombre de jeunes
mobilisés jeudi et il s'attendait un
doublement un triplement de la situation
après il faudra vraiment voir ce soir
enfin en fin de journée
il faudra voir en fin de en fin de
parcours en fin de journée pour voir
notamment ce qui se passe dans parfois
les violences et les débordements qui
ont lieu à la fin des cortèges
ça se manifeste comment dans dans les
lycées par exemple est-ce qu'il y a des
blocages alors dans les lycées oui le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale
faisait état de 53 incidences matin ça
c'est les chiffres du ministère les
organisations syndicales
alors dans les incidents pour vous
détailler il y a selon le ministère 14
blocages 27 blocages filtrant donc on
laisse entrer certains élèves mais pas
d'autres cette tentative de blocage donc
qui ont échoué et cinq autres formes de
perturbations si ça peut être des choses
diverses des rassemblements des coupures
d'électricité etc etc ça c'est les
chiffres du ministère c'est moins un que
que ceux de jeudi puisque le ministère
faisait état de 78 incidents le matin
148 réévalués plus tard dans la journée
et selon les organisations lycéennes on
est plutôt à 450 500 lycées mobilisés
bloqués donc vous voyez comme un peu
parfois souvent les chiffres entre les
syndicats et les policiers ici les
chiffres entre le ministère et les
syndicats c'est très différent mais en
tout cas il y a des blocages il y a des
mouvements un peu partout en France
j'arrive pas à me rendre compte c'est
important 60 50 60 70
non on est quand même loin de Mai 68
mais après c'est toujours très difficile
de savoir exactement ce qui se passe
d'autant plus que et c'est encore plus
vrai on y viendra peut-être tout à
l'heure avec l'enseignement supérieur
c'est encore plus vrai là il peut avoir
plusieurs antennes plusieurs sites
plusieurs campus donc est-ce que parce
que un site est bloqué vous dites toutes
l'université est bloquée pas forcément
enfin c'est vraiment compliqué à
chiffrer
des blocages ont été bloqués ah ça c'est
notamment oui Assas Dauphine Cergy la
semaine dernière c'était le cas là on
voit encore un qui a des établissements
bloqués aujourd'hui je pense à plusieurs
IEP ainsi tu d'études politiques à
plusieurs sites de l'Université Paris un
Panthéon Sorbonne enfin voilà on voit
qu'il y a des établissements perturbés
mais alors là c'est encore plus
difficile comme je disais à l'instant le
ministère d'enseignement supérieur ne
donne même pas de chiffres donc on en
est vraiment réduit à faire un peu le
tour des réseaux sociaux de nos
correspondants sur place pour savoir ce
qui se passe un petit peu dans chaque
établissement on se souvient de blocus
challenge ce hashtag lancé par Louis
Boyard le député de la France insoumise
n'a pas vraiment marché visiblement non
alors c'est vrai que ça c'est quelque
chose qui avait fait beaucoup parler
parce que ça plaît vraiment à quelque
chose voilà la méthode et puis le fait
que ça soit un député de la nation qui
appelle assez rassemblement voilà
qui était lui-même qui était lui-même
président d'un syndical lycéen donc
voilà c'est vrai que il faut vraiment
aller regarder dans chaque chaque ville
parfois chaque quartier ce qui se passe
mais ce qui est intéressant à constater
c'est que au-delà des étudiants et des
lycéens c'est aussi des jeunes
travailleurs des jeunes salariés ou des
jeunes sans activité qui se qui se
mobilisent donc c'est vrai que c'est
peut-être pas exactement en tout cas
jusqu'ici ça n'était pas forcément un
mouvement lycéen ou étudiant d'abord
plutôt un mouvement de jeunes après
avoir dans les semaines à venir comment
ça va se transformer j'ai trois
informations à vous donner je reprends
mes questions Audes ça vient de tomber
la grève des éboueurs à Paris est
suspendu à partir de demain à la
première information
en direct également la gare
Saint-Charles à Marseille et bloqué
alors on se parle il est 15h43 et puis
les premiers incidents ont eu à Bordeaux
vous pouvez retrouver tout ça sur Le
Figaro.fr dans le direct texte le live
texte comme on l'appelle vous trouvez ça
très facilement juste au-dessus juste en
dessous de notre live vidéo sur le
Figaro pour un FR en parlant des des
lycées on a parlé tout à l'heure les
profs les enseignants ils sont pas
vraiment en grève alors très peu c'est
vrai que ils ont été très mobilisés le
premier jour des manifestations donc le
19 janvier ils étaient 38% donc ça peut
citer c'était beaucoup et 38% encore une
fois selon le ministère les syndicats
avaient annoncé beaucoup plus mais là
aujourd'hui selon le ministère toujours
ils ne sont que 8% un peu plus de 8%
donc c'est très peu on peut s'interroger
on peut se demander pourquoi comme
d'autres corps de métier c'est la
dixième journée de mobilisation il
commence à avoir de la fatigue de la
lassitude et puis ils viennent
évidemment un vrai impact sur les fiches
de paix c'est pas c'est pas anodin donc
c'est comme ça que que les syndicats
l'expliquent mais c'est sûr que voilà 8%
c'est pour pour les grévistes pour les
mobiliser c'est pas une bonne nouvelle
parce que c'est pas un très bon
chiffrement que les transports sont des
métiers qui sont assez leaders dans la
contestation sociale les profs non en
tout cas c'est vrai alors ils sont
beaucoup moins syndiqués qu'avant
aujourd'hui c'est un corps moins
syndiqué mais qui reste quand même plus
indiqué que d'autres en tout cas on voit
une vraie différence donc je vous
parlais par rapport au 19 janvier mais
même par rapport à jeudi dernier ils
étaient encore 21% selon le ministère là
on passe à 8% c'est vrai qu'on voit une
vraie différence certains ont demandé
alors Laurent Berger notamment
le patron de la CFDT avait appelé à ne
pas bloquer le bac il y a un double
discours d'une certaine manière dans cet
appartement syndicale parce que
c'est pas de personnes
l'étudiants et lycéens qui eux demandent
à bloquer mais en même temps on dit non
il faut passer le bac alors ça ça peut
alors ce qui s'est passé la semaine
dernière c'est un peu particulier parce
que c'est vrai que c'est rarissime que
les organisations syndicales qu'elles
soient de jeunesse ou d'adultes
appellent à bloquer les épreuves du bac
parce que c'est très impopulaire et puis
ça met vraiment en danger des choses que
les professeurs les élèves ont travaillé
pendant des mois sur lesquels vous
travaillez pendant des mois et des mois
donc ce qui s'est passé la semaine
dernière il y avait les premières
épreuves anticipées du enfin pas
anticiper les premières épreuves du bac
qui se tenaient en mars c'était une
première cette année et ça a été très
peu perturbé tout à fait il y a une
réforme
mais on sentait que voilà le mouvement
est un peu partagé certains disaient
c'est l'occasion de monter d'un cran
dans la mobilisation et de se faire
entendre et puis beaucoup la majorité
disait non mais on veut pas perturber
les épreuves du bac et d'ailleurs ça
c'est plutôt bien passé tout à l'heure
je vous parlais d'ailleurs des blocages
filtrants de certains établissements
c'est notamment parce que cette semaine
il y a encore des épreuves des épreuves
orales ou des épreuves d'expérimentation
conscience notamment et donc dans
certains lycées les mobiliser laissent
passer les élèves qui ont leur épreuve
de bac aujourd'hui
sur les réseaux sociaux on se plaint
évidemment de violence policières est-ce
que ça peut pousser les jeunes à
descendre plus largement dans la rue
est-ce que c'est mobilisateur ça oui
alors d'un côté ça ça effrait moi je
parlais avec un certain nombre de jeunes
qui disaient bon ben voilà moi je n'ai
pas envie que que ça m'arrive à moi
d'être délaissé ou voilà et à la fois ça
ça les révolte aussi et c'est vrai que
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure sur
ce qui s'est passé jeudi dernier donc le
49-3 ce qui s'est passé jeudi dernier
pendant les mobilisations en marge des
mobilisations et ce qui s'est passé à
Sainte-Soline les jeunes ils en parlent
ouvertement dans le communiqué de
l'Inter syndicale qui date de la semaine
dernière on évoquait ce côté
dénonciation de des violences commisses
par les forces de l'ordre et donc ça
c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose qui
peut pousser la jeunesse à se mobiliser
quand il y a des jeunes dans une
manifestation
qui peuvent être plus violents que
certains est-ce que c'est difficile
d'intervenir pour les forces de l'or on
imagine que ça c'est une vraie question
alors vous parlez de devant les
établissements
politique la stratégie on
imagine qu'il faudrait demander plutôt à
mes collègues de la police
d'occasion de le rappeler ça reste
illégal mais évidemment il faut faire ça
avec beaucoup de doigtés et beaucoup de
dialogues si possible avec les
organisations syndicales et avec les
musiciens mobilisés moi je sais que du
côté des chefs d'établissement ça fait
partie des choses qui craignent le plus
les blocages parce que c'est très
difficile à maîtriser merci beaucoup
merci d'être venu nous expliquer ce
mouvement qui prend de l'ampleur dans la
jeunesse enfin nous verrons nous aurons
les chiffres ce soir sachez que dans la
fonction publique d'État les grévisses
sont au nombre de
6,5%. voilà c'est l'un des derniers
chiffres qui va nous arriver et qu'on
retrouve Vincent roseron sur place
Saint-Vincent vous êtes dans ce cortège
est-ce que vous voyez des jeunes autour
de vous quelle est la sociologie de
cette de cette manif du jour
[Musique]
et bah la chirurgie de la minute du jour
alors je n'attends bien que vous en
parler parce que justement on voit de
variété sur le plateau la manifestation
c'est un peu arrêtée avec ce cortège de
jeunes justement de la des syndicales
lycéens que vous pouvez voir ici qui
manifeste et sinon globalement ils sont
moins nombreux en tout cas les jeunes
qui étaient jeudi jeudi c'était vraiment
très impressionnant c'était vraiment la
première fois qu'il y avait autant de
jeunes dans les manifestations de
lycéens d'étudiants là on voit qu'il y
en a quand même un peu moins mais ils
sont tout de même présent aujourd'hui
dans cette manifestation
on se battre merci beaucoup Vincent on
vient d'arriver dans un ensemble on voit
beaucoup de jeunes autour de vous j'ai
l'impression
d'image que nous vous rapportez bonjour
Arthur bonjour Thibault bonjour à tous
on prévoit une mobilisation légèrement
en baisse aujourd'hui quels étaient les
données hier soir et comme ça on va les
infirmer ou les confirmer ensuite alors
hier soir la fameuse note du
renseignement territorial qui précède
maintenant toutes les journées de
mobilisation nous donnait une fourchette
assez large entre 650 000 et 950 000
manifestants alors on se parle et avec
les premières remontées qu'on a du
terrain on peut totalement confirmer
cette fourchette la baisse de la
mobilisation est autour de -30 - 35% ce
qui va nous faire alors c'est selon nos
prévisions et c'est selon nos calculs
autour de 700720 mille manifestants 750
000 dans le dans le meilleur des cas
s'il y a une grosse mobilisation à Paris
c'est à peu près ce qu'on peut annoncer
pour la mobilisation du jour vous me
dites 700 000 c'est ça à peu près 700
je veux les comparer par rapport aux
dernières semaines ça donne quoi alors
c'est en baisse par rapport au jeudi 23
mars la dernière mobilisation c'était
1,08 millions
c'est en baisse également par rapport
aux 7 mars 1,28 millions mais c'est plus
que le 11 c'est plus que le 15 mars ça
reste une mobilisation aux alentours de
celle du 7 février oui qui était à
757000 donc ça remonte déjà dans le
mouvement c'était la troisième
mobilisation là on est à la dixième mais
ce sera quand même une mobilisation dans
la fourchette moyenne haute si je peux
me permettre est-ce qu'on peut faire des
des comparaisons dans certaines villes
est-ce qu'on a déjà des chiffres là sur
des villes de région on a déjà des
chiffres dans la plupart des grandes
villes de région on a Marseille
seulement 11000 personnes c'est en
baisse c'est un faible chiffre 10000 à
Bordeaux c'est également un faible
chiffre on a toujours une assez grande
mobilisation à Nantes dit 18000
personnes ce qui est quand même
relativement assez important on a
également quand qui se maintient autour
de 14914600
on a une forte baisse à Strasbourg
seulement 6500 les grandes villes
globalement baissent oui on peut on peut
le dire par rapport à la dernière
mobilisation mais ça reste comme je vous
le disais tout à l'heure dans la
fourchette moyenne haute à chaque fois
bon nous verrons petit à petit
les chiffres arrivés on peut retrouver
ça sur le fil data sur Le Figaro.fr ça
tout à fait vous avez des comparaisons
avec les précédentes manifestations si
le point est rouge c'est que la
mobilisation est en baisse s'il est vert
c'est qu'elle est en hausse s'il est
jaune c'est qu'il est stable c'est ça
j'aime bien tout compris
la légende
faut toujours surveiller ces villes
moyennes ou bon ça c'est un peu terminé
c'est ce qui se passait au début du
mouvement c'est vrai on en a beaucoup
parlé des villes moyennes à ce micro je
vous ai beaucoup parlé de Guéret j'en
étais sûr je vais vous réciter je ne
vais pas vous citer Guéret aujourd'hui
je suis venu avec de nouvelles villes et
effectivement ces villes moyennes se
mobilisent toujours plus en proportion
il y a moins de monde évidemment dans la
rue mais en proportion au nombre
d'habitants c'est beaucoup plus
important c'est toujours plus important
mais c'est un petit peu moins flagrant
que lors des mobilisations du 19 du 31
janvier où là vraiment c'était c'était
très très notable alors je suis venu
avec quelques villes moyennes Tarbes il
faut qu'on parle à tous nos internautes
Tarbes Tarbes 5000 personnes aujourd'hui
c'était 7000 dans le Tarn-et-Garonne
c'est la préfecture de Hautes-Pyrénées
je me trompe 5000 manifestants
aujourd'hui
77500 la semaine dernière donc c'est
c'est moins Gap dans les dans les
Hautes-Alpes 1750 contre 3000 donc vous
voyez quand même certaines baisses
Bourges préfecture du Cher 2400 contre
4300 Valenciennes 2300 aujourd'hui
contre 3100 la semaine dernière donc
vous voyez même dans ces villes moyennes
il y a vraiment une baisse de la
mobilisation d'accord bon je à
surveiller Guéret quand même est-ce
qu'on a des chiffres sur le nombre de
grévistes dans les dans les différents
secteurs oui vous le disiez tout à
l'heure avec autre barietty on a
quelques chiffres de taux de grévistes
notamment dans le premier degré dans
l'éducation nationale c'est 7,6% et dans
le second degré c'est 9,1% et c'est
quand même largement en baisse les taux
de grévistes étaient les plus hauts le
19 janvier le 31 janvier et le 7 mars là
on est dans des chiffres qui sont
vraiment très loin de ces maximum
atteint à cette date-là
dans les raffineries ça donne quoi ça ça
commence à prendre de l'ampleur on se
souvient de ce qu'il s'est passé à
l'automne dernier avec une grande partie
des pompes du pays qui était à sec vous
êtes venus les quelques semaines en me
disant
ça va pour l'instant il y a quelques
pompes à sec là ça prend de l'ampleur
oui ça prend de l'ampleur parce qu'on a
cinq des sept raffinités françaises qui
sont à l'arrêt et malgré les position ça
ne s'arrange pas selon nos calculs parce
que le ministère de la transition
énergétique ne donne plus de chiffres ce
dont selon nos calculs on est à 16,3% de
stations en difficulté
ça vous paraît un peu compliqué c'est
soit qu'elles n'ont pas d'essence soit
qu'elles n'ont pas de diesel soit
qu'elles n'ont pas les deux donc c'est
assez simple et dans ce 16,3% vous avez
des grandes disparités régionales vous
avez un quart sud-ouest et un quart
nord-est qui sont absolument pas touchés
je crois que les Landes c'est 0% donc
l'Ouest ça va le quart sud-ouest car
sud-ouest sud-ouest et nord-est d'accord
oui ok
comme ça c'est très simple à retenir et
par contre vous avez un cas nord-ouest
la Bretagne la Loire-Atlantique je pense
à la Mayenne Ille-et-Vilaine autour de
Nantes le Calvados etc on a des chiffres
la Mayenne c'est 54% de stations en
difficulté l'Ille-et-Vilaine c'est plus
de 50%, le Calvados c'est 30% donc
Nantes ren toutes ces villes tous ces
départements là sont très touchés et à
la messe vous avez le sud-est
du Rhône toute la façade méditerranéenne
qui est très très touchée on est autour
de 30 40 % en difficulté et dernier
petit point c'est Toulouse c'est plus de
45 %. ok en Haute-Garonne donc on a
quand même
l'Île-de-France plus de 30%
l'Île-de-France également commence à
être touchée 30% à Paris je crois 34
dans le Val-de-Marne qui est le
département francilien le plus touché
donc effectivement quand vous avez une
station sur trois qui est en difficulté
ça commence à se ressentir au moment où
vous voulez faire le plein Arthur
bijouta un paquet des chiffres figatar
merci de tous nous les rapporter on
retourne en instant sur le terrain
Damien canivevez on a vu il y a quelques
instants des images place de la
République où tous les manifestants
dont tous les manifestants ne sont pas
partis et vous vous êtes déjà place de
la Nation alors on prévoit on anticipe
potentiellement depuis plusieurs jours
et la venue de casseurs c'est pas le cas
pour l'instant Damien ainsi
[Applaudissements]
non c'est pas du tout le cas
effectivement
Thibault Gauthier alors c'est vrai qu'on
nous étions il y a quelques instants au
niveau de la place de la Nation ou le
cortège parisien est arrivé et là nous
avons rebroussé le chemin afin de
rejoindre la tête de cortège syndicale
voilà et là pour le moment tout le monde
est un petit peu à l'arrêt parce qu'il y
a beaucoup de monde malgré tout dans
cette manifestation à Paris alors est-ce
que les chiffres seront aussi
impressionnants que la semaine dernière
c'est la question à laquelle vous pouvez
pas encore répondre mais c'est vrai que
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de monde ici
pour l'instant sur ce sur ce boulevard
Voltaire alors comme je vous le disais
tout à l'heure c'est vrai que la colère
s'est étendue à d'autres domaines que
celui des retraites et on a vu aussi
beaucoup de slogans en lien avec ces
braves m vous savez c'est brigades de
répression des actions violentes c'est
la la section motorisée de la préfecture
de police de Paris vous savez ce sont
ces policiers qui se déplacent à moto
qui sont extrêmement mobiles lorsqu'il y
a une manifestation violente qui arrive
voilà elles sont très controversées
depuis quelques depuis quelques semaines
c'est c'est qui ont été introduits début
2019 on le rappelle par le préfet de
police à Michel Delpech et voilà il y a
beaucoup de manifestants qu'on a qu'on a
pu croiser ici ou là qui réclame la
dissolution de cette section de la de la
préfecture de police de Paris mais voyez
pour l'instant la tête de cortège est en
train d'arriver sur cette dernière
partie du boulevard Voltaire tout se
passe dans le calme jusque là pour
répondre à votre question Thibault
Gauthier est-ce que les éléments
radicaux sont là oui on les voit très
clairement on sent que une allumette
pourrait enflammer cette ambiance ici
boulevard Voltaire mais pour le moment
force de reconnaître que tout se passe
dans le calme et on a même pas vu pour
être honnête avec vous le moindre feu de
poubelle ce qui est évidemment sans
commune mesure avec ce que l'on a pu
filmer la semaine dernière dans les rues
de la capitale
on touche du bois devient un canular
pourvu que ça continue comme ça
je suis toujours avec Arthur
figata on vous donne des chiffres des
infos des données on parle de la
jeunesse les chiffres des lycées ce
qu'on en a est-ce qu'on les connaît
alors effectivement les chiffres des
lycées sont un petit peu il y a eu un
blocage des blocages un peu moindre je
crois qu'on avait un petit peu moins
d'actions
que ce soit blocage barrage filtrant
tentatives de blocage on avait un petit
peu moins d'action que jeudi 23 mais en
revanche ce à quoi s'attendait le
ministère de l'Intérieur les
renseignements territoriaux c'était une
très forte mobilisation de la jeunesse
on parlait de 30000 jeunes mobilisés
jeudi 23 mars là on en attendait 90000
on parlait d'un éventuel triplement pour
l'instant ce qu'on voit dans les
chiffres et on sait que les jeunes sont
quand même beaucoup plus mobilisés dans
les grandes villes ce que je viens de
vous dire tout à l'heure les chiffres
dans les grandes villes ne pas
impressionnant une atteigne pas la barre
de atteinte le 23 mars donc on peut
quand même on attendait une forte
mobilisation de la jeunesse elle semble
assez présente dans les cortèges mais
elles ne sont pas non plus réalisées un
véritable raz-de-marée dans les
manifestations il est presque 16h 15h59
et 54 secondes
vous suivez évidemment cette journée de
manifestation immobilisation avec ces
images dans les rues de la capitale pour
l'instant tout se passe bien et c'est
une bonne nouvelle jusqu'ici comment
c'est comment vous voulez récupérer ces
chiffres ce sont ceux du ministère de
l'Intérieur ce sont toujours ceux du
ministère de l'Intérieur ce des
préfectures se des renseignements
territoriaux j'en profite d'ailleurs
pour saluer mes collègues Nicolas Mondon
Nicole triolaire qui participe à ce
recensement avec moi et on se base tout
simplement sur les relevés de la presse
quotidienne régionale sur nos confrères
de France Bleu tous France Bleu tous les
France 3 régions etc etc qui remontent
au fur et à mesure et on va même
chercher des manifestations qui
rassemblent ce matin en Bretagne c'était
60 personnes donc on l'a rajouté dans le
tableau une nouvelle ville voilà et donc
on est maintenant à 380 villes qu'on
scrute à chaque journée de mobilisation
pour vous donner en avant-première des
estimations des chiffres et des
prévisions les syndicats les chiffres
des syndicats on peut pas les prendre en
compte ceux-là ils sont pas fiables les
chiffres syndicaux tout dépend de la
proportion et quand j'ai relevé juste
avant de venir vous voir Thibault
Montélimar je crois que c'était 2600
2800 donc vous pouvez vous dire que bon
en fonction de qui a compté etc on est
quand même d'accord sur sur un même sur
un même ordre de grandeur quand par
exemple à Marseille vous avez entre
11000 et 180 000 oui là quand même vous
pouvez pas vous mettre d'accord si un
policier voit un manifestant pendant
qu'un syndicaliste on voit 18 à ça pose
quand même question et quelques
problèmes il y a bien des cabinets
indépendants qui comptent on peut pas
trouver un juste milieu il y a beaucoup
critiques sur ces cabinets indépendants
il y a eu beaucoup de critiques sur ces
cabinets indépendants même la semaine
dernière si ma mémoire est bonne
occurrence a donné 83000 soit 40
000 quasiment en dessous du chiffre de
la préfecture de police donc
le comptage est vraiment c'est vraiment
très très très compliqué et petite
anecdote une fois à Saint-Étienne un
syndicaliste avait laissé le mégaphone
allumé et avait dit oh on va donner 50
000 preuves que
le chiffrage et le comptage n'était
quand même pas très juste et très précis
à ce moment-là merci beaucoup Arthur
byzota je vous laisse remonter collecter
toutes les données pour que vous
puissiez les donner à nos internautes du
figaro.fr vous l'avez vu il y a quelques
instants juste en haut à droite de
l'image Yannick Jadot il est aux côtés
de Vincent roseron Vincent vous avez la
main
[Applaudissements]
oui merci beaucoup Thibault
effectivement je trouve avec Yannick
jalot on va essayer de faire une
interview parce que il y a le camion
solidaire qui passe et ça fait beaucoup
de bruit comment vous jugez en tout cas
la mobilisation déjà aujourd'hui mais
elle reste énorme et vous voyez bien que
dans toutes les enquêtes d'opinion le
rejet de cette réforme est le soutien la
mobilisation continue d'augmenter alors
qu'il est déjà très très haut au fond le
président Macron et les deux options
aujourd'hui
l'entêtement qui conduit à l'embrasement
ou l'apaisement et la responsabilité il
y a une offre de l'intersyndical qui est
profondément responsable qui vise à
l'apaisement du pays pour travailler sur
les questions qui taraudent les Français
les conditions de travail les salaires
évidemment si poser la question de la
retraite du temps de travail et vous
avez un président qui pour l'instant
choisi l'embrasement c'est extrêmement
dangereux pour le pays
pourtant jusque là avec ce qu'il a dit
la semaine dernière encore scanner
aujourd'hui Olivier Véran au Conseil des
ministres ils ne vont pas prendre la
pour l'instant la main tendue des
syndicats mais qu'est-ce qu'il veut en
fait le président Macron il est tout
seul à défendre une réforme dont
personne ne veut aujourd'hui il vient à
la télé et l'opposition se trouve
renforcée il y a encore plus de Français
qui dit c'est aberrant qu'est-ce qu'il
veut il veut que le pays s'embrase il
veut fracturer le pays franchement le
pays est presque réconcilier sur l'école
sur l'hôpital sur le climat il est temps
que le Président de la République
prennent la main tendue de l'Inter
syndicale pour apaiser le pays on en a
sacrément besoin
ce sera quoi selon vous la la suite de
ce mouvement on va avoir des
manifestations jusqu'au Conseil
constitutionnel
écoutez c'est vous voyez à quel point
l'Inter syndicale a été incroyable
exemplaire depuis le début écoutez on va
suivre ce que propose l'Inter syndicale
parce qu'ils le font responsabilités ils
veulent tout faire pour que à la fois
les salariés les plus vulnérables ce
sont les carrières les plus pénibles et
plus difficiles ne soient pas percutés
par une réforme injuste et ils veulent
en même temps apaiser le pays et ben
c'est ça la responsabilité il est temps
que le président Macron revienne du côté
de la rationalité de la responsabilité
de l'apaisement parce que là il est
sacrément en train de se garer oui vous
vous c'est clair pour vous c'est que
c'est pareil il faut c'est ce que
propose la personne décale il faut
mettre sur pause cette réforme des
retraites au moins sur pause bien sûr je
veux dire écoutez moi je soutiens et les
mouvements politiques on l'a dit tout à
l'heure on soutient cette proposition de
la terre syndicale parce qu'on veut
apaiser le pays
on veut la fin des violences et on veut
que le pays ne soit plus bloqué par
cette réforme et par un président qui
est animé par son orgueil et un
entêtement qui aujourd'hui totalement
incompréhensible très bien merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
aujourd'hui voilà pour la pour ce que
disait Yannick Jadot vous comprenez en
plein soutien de l'intersyndical comme
le disait Laurent Berger a demandé une
pause sur cette réforme des retraites
pour quelques mois
comment ça va ça va bien sur ma liste au
service société du Figaro rédacteur en
chef adjoint spécialiste des questions
de sécurité dont on est un instant
Yannick Jadot c'est pas simple de se
déplacer dans les dans les manifs non
non parce que le cortège est assez dense
il y a du monde quand même aujourd'hui
moi j'y étais au départ au démarrage
j'ai remonté depuis Richard Lenoir donc
la tête de cortège jusqu'à au moment du
démarrage jusqu'à République donc c'est
vrai que la physionomie ça donnait
l'impression qu'il y avait largement
plus de 50000 personnes probablement
peut-être 80 000 peut-être même
davantage donc la physiologie d'une
grosse manifestation avec aussi en tout
cas au démarrage
peu de visages de ce que les policiers
appellent les chats maigres c'est-à-dire
chasser ces espèces de profil un peu
assez tiques comme ça de qui s'agrange
qui forment les Black Blocs le moment
venu qui se green qui change de tenue et
puis qui se mettent en ordre de bataille
malgré tout on arrive quand même à
disting un peu leur profil parce que ils
sont pas en train de chanter de rigoler
avant le début du cortège ils sont en
train de se déplacer pour essayer de en
fait d'optimiser leur formation leur
déplacements de se retrouver exactement
donc on les reconnaît parce qu'en fait
ils ont l'air très concentrés par
rapport aux autres et en fait les
policiers arrivent souvent à les
identifier à l'avance après le problème
c'est qu'ils sont mobiles et qu'on va
pas en mettre un policier derrière
chaque alors un black bloc faut savoir
que c'est en fait c'est une méthode oui
c'est ça parce que on a l'habitude de
dire ah toi tu es un black bloc non un
blog c'est l'agrégation de toutes ces
blagues bloc c'est en fait c'est c'est
la méthode c'est en fait on se met en
bloc on se met en groupe un groupe Noir
un groupe d'amands noirs Black Bloc
c'est ça et donc par disons par
assimilation on a on appelle ça les
Black Blocs comme un frigidaire est
devenu l'appareil
c'était une marque bah c'est un peu
pareil alors vous me dites
que en début de manifestation il n'y en
avait pas de visible pourtant depuis
quelques années mais je pense que en
vérité d'abord une bonne partie doit
rejoindre les cortèges au fur et à
mesure c'est
identifient pas trop au départ
d'abord parce qu'ils sont tâches par
rapport à la foule ils en ont besoin
mais en même temps ils ont besoin de la
foule en mouvement ils ont besoin que ça
stand voilà pour profiter du chaos se
déplacer plus facilement donc voilà
c'est leur manière de fonctionner plus
c'est chaotique plus ils sont dans leur
élément mais alors hier on avait les
premiers chiffres enfin les premiers
chiffres prévus par les renseignements
1000 casseurs attendus on a vu ce qu'il
s'est passé jeudi dernier on a vu ce
qu'il s'est passé ce week-end à
Sainte-Soline même si c'est un cadre
très différent il y avait quand même
cette volonté de plusieurs casseurs de
s'en prendre aux forces de l'ordre on
nous annonçait une journée noire pour
l'instant c'est pas le cas non mais
c'était pas la physionomie du cortège
franchement au départ oui j'aimerais
quand même un long passé de présence en
manifestation puisque ça fait comme plus
d'une trentaine d'années que je
travaille sur cette question là et sur
l'ordre public et sur Paris notamment et
il y a des il y a des cortèges où on
sent dès le départ que ça va mal se
passer que les profils inquiétants sont
là qui sont en nombre et d'ailleurs les
forces de l'ordre on sentis sont plus
près et un peu fébrile et ça se passe
mal là c'est pas le sentiment de la
philosophie de cette manifestation on a
le sentiment que ils sont moins nombreux
voilà et que il y a pas une fébrilité au
départ du cortège d'ailleurs il y avait
pas de feuilles il y a pas de feu de
poubelle partout à cette heure-ci vous
voyez c'est plus calme ça veut pas dire
qu'il y aura quelques il y aura quelques
desperados à la fin qui vont quand même
profiter de la nuit et de la tombée du
soir comme ça pour pouvoir
rentabiliser leur journée mais pour
l'instant en tout cas on n'a pas la
fébrilité qu'on a sur certains
déplacements comme on a pu le voir à
d'autres à d'autres rendez-vous du
moment des retraites
370 000 manifestants à l'heure où on se
parle les chiffres à 16h contre 300
contre 570 000 le 23 mars on va
retrouver dans un instant d'Amiens ce
qui est avec Julien Leclerc dans la
manifestation parce que je veux que lui
il nous explique lui dit dans la
manifestation ce qu'il voit ce qu'il
ressent et il était sur la même longueur
d'onde que vous tout à l'heure il nous
disait bon ça va on envoie des chats
maigres mais pour l'instant pas de pas
de violence je voulais qu'on parle des
forces de l'ordre comment il réagissent
les policiers les gendarmes
après ce qu'il s'est passé jeudi ce
week-end fait deux mois que ça se passe
plutôt bien est-ce que là il se sent
directement visé
je pense que l'immense majorité
a le sentiment de faire son travail et
vit les critiques qui sont faites sur
les débordements éventuels évidemment
comme une injustice
maintenant je pense que ils sont surtout
disciplinés il y a un grand décalage en
fait entre le discours syndical qui est
un discours quasiment et de certains
associatifs qui est un discours de haine
vis-à-vis de fête de l'ordre tout
simplement c'est la sémantique de la
haine d'ailleurs quand on écoute Jadot
qui est censé être à modéré et qui
utilise toujours des mots qui maximisent
le discours qui est conflictualise le
discours on voit bien qu'ils sont dans
une logique en fait de surenchère ces
gens-là et puis vous avez les policiers
quand vous les voyez en fait il y a
quand même un grand un grand
d'abord un droit à savoir faire dans
l'organisation sauf quand il leur arrive
des fois d'être dépassé parce qu'il y a
eu un problème d'anticipation de bien
prendre dans le renseignement je pense
qu'il y a de la qualité du renseignement
en amont qui est toujours pas terrible
en matière de d'ordre public ça ça fait
un moment ça fait
que tous les chiffres qu'on a les infos
qu'on a qui remontent qu'on publie la
veille sur le Figaro sur Le Figaro.fr
c'est pas très précis par rapport à
l'étranger
ce que je constate moi c'est qu'au fil
des rendez-vous quand ça va mal c'est
parce qu'on a moins on a une mauvaise
évaluation des dangers potentiels à la
fois sur le volume d'opposants et sur
son mode opératoire
donc à chaque fois ça appelle la
réflexion sur la réorganisation
dispositif en amont pour bien anticiper
les phénomènes et être prêt à intervenir
sans être obligé d'intervenir acculé
c'est-à-dire quand il y a un excès de
force comme on a pu le voir avec
certains personnes de la de la brave
aime la fameuse
là quand il y a un excès de force c'est
qu'il y a eu un
il y a eu en amont un souci de
participation c'est intéressant vous
voyez cette image en haut à gauche
m à sa fin cette brave m elle fait
parler d'elle et on va on va en discuter
dans un instant parce que ça m'intéresse
beaucoup est-ce qu'il s'y pris préparé
les forces de l'ordre depuis deux mois
ça se passait bien est-ce que il sentait
qu'à un moment ça pouvait basculer
entrer dans autre chose ce que je sais
que vous en tant que journaliste
spécialiste des questions de sécurité
vous les connaissez bien les les flics
les forces de l'ordre qu'est-ce qu'il
vous disent bah c'est assez simple
c'est assez simple c'est que ils ont
bien compris que quand un mouvement en
fait sans racines et se répète mais
c'est en fait en grosso modo c'est la
nouveauté des gilets jaunes c'est que
c'était des rendez-vous réguliers alors
le général c'était tous les samedis là
ce sont des rendez-vous qui sont
le jeudi voilà c'est un peu différent
mais grosso modo c'est un phénomène de
répétition la répétition ça amène des
phases à la fois de routine et puis
aussi des phases d'excès et bien donc
voilà ils aiment pas que les mouvements
s'installe dans la durée parce que au
moment où on pensait que ça allait se
relâcher c'est là que ça part quand
c'est parti c'est trop tard
il y a et puis il y a fait de d'usure de
lassitude les effectifs sont pas
extensibles à l'infini contrairement à
ce qu'on peut imaginer
les effectifs sont fatigués et ça augure
en plus de difficultés pour la suite
parce que quand vous utilisez
massivement les forces de de l'ordre à
faire du maintien de l'ordre semaine
après semaine vous les avez un petit peu
moins à s'occuper de la sécurité du
quotidien et des problèmes des autres
personnes qui ne manifestent pas
est-ce que la méthode de Nunez Nunez le
nouveau préfet de police de de Paris va
être à l'épreuve désormais parce que on
se souvient Didier l'Allemand qui avait
été très critiqué sur sa gestion de ces
grandes manifestations notamment celles
des gilets jaunes depuis quelques temps
Laurent Munez était plutôt saluée pour
la tenue de ces manifestations est-ce
que là cette fois on va voir si c'est
nouvelle méthode fonctionne et à ce
qu'il a une nouvelle méthode parce qu'il
aura mener sans défunt dit non non moi
je suis dans la continuité oui c'est
très difficile d'abord parce que il peut
pas se mettre dans la posture de celui
qui va donner des leçons à son
prédécesseur
retirer le tapis sous le pied à la
prochaine manifestation donc c'est sur
l'ordre public qu'on saute dans les
postes de préfet donc faut toujours être
prudent dans le récit de de l'action
policière et puis d'autre part en
matière d'abord on voit bien que c'est
pas les mêmes profils alors en une nièce
c'est un profil d'homme de réseau très
arrondi
euh voilà et donc enfin ça a pas fait un
tandem en or non plus avec Castaner
Christophe Castaner était ministre de
l'Intérieur et le rendement était si on
veut le technicien qui était secrétaire
d'État
il y a eu du poisson Droz
qui marchait pas très très bien bon
voilà il y a eu des tandem à Beauvau
c'est pas c'est pas toujours une
réussite mais en toute état de cause
dans l'actualité du moment luniez passe
pour le modéré en quelque sorte de toute
façon après évidemment le profil
l'allemand c'était pas trop compliqué
bon l'Allemand a laissé quand même des
des réformes des des modes opératoires
qui sont qui sont qui sont pas
inefficaces en matière de maintien de
l'ordre celui qui a créé les braves
voilà enfin en tout cas qui les a
pérennisé
c'était le prédécesseur qui qui avait
créé ça mais disons que l'autre la
systématisé la généraliser la
professionnaliser en quelque sorte avant
c'était plus un slogan et c'est devenu
vraiment une vraie unité sous l'Allemand
qui est motarde d'ailleurs rappelons-le
et qui a un vrai appétit pour ça
et pour l'ordre et pour la moto et donc
du résultat il a mêlé ses deux passions
voilà et donc il a créé cette unité et
donc bah oui alors pour Nunès oui
effectivement donc un profil différent
un discours différent l'allemand était
quelqu'un de d'assez provocateur
absolument absolument
et donc voilà il a créé ses unités elles
sont bien utiles aujourd'hui elles
montrent aussi leurs limites on en
reparlera sûrement puisque vous en
parler mais voilà donc les nièce c'est
quelqu'un qui va mettre il va un petit
peu moins lever le menton parce que
c'est plutôt un homme rond de consensus
etc très bien voilà et puis et puis
c'était cette aussi une décision de
mettre un peu les les forces en retrait
quand ça se passe bien c'est pas la
peine de les mettre en avant et de jouer
la provocation et l'intimidation en
quelque sorte donc il a voulu avoir un
usage plus disons plus gradué de la
force publique dans ce genre de
situation ça colle à son tempérament et
peut-être aussi aux nécessités du moment
on va me dire dans l'oreillette si on
peut retrouver Damien Canivez parce que
ce sera intéressant d'entendre sur le
terrain ce qu'il a à nous dire si tout
se passe dans le dans le calme on parle
d'un instant de la brave alors
on y va avant Damien comment ça se passe
autour de vous parce que c'était l'une
des grandes questions de cette journée
de mauvaise mobilisation de
manifestation on a vu que dans d'autres
villes
c'était parfois assez mal passé pour
l'instant à Paris tout va bien vous me
confirmez
alors écoutez tout va bien mais tout
cela est assez relatif Tibo Gauthier
parce que effectivement l'ensemble de la
manifestation s'est passée sans le
moindre chahut avec des slogans tels
qu'on a l'habitude de les entendre dans
les dans les manifestations mais depuis
quelques minutes on a le sentiment que
tout est en train de s'agiter autour de
nous
de nombreuses manifestants se sont
arrêtés à l'angle du boulevard Voltaire
et de la rue Voltaire et comme d'un seul
homme tous les éléments habillés en noir
se sont rassemblés et chantent plus fort
que tout à l'heure et on l'air de voilà
de de se préparer à quelque chose des
lunettes de plongées sont vissées au
niveau des yeux les casques sont mis
souvent sur la tête des masques aussi
qui empêchent les les fumées de
lacrymogène sont au niveau des du nez
donc on a le sentiment quelque chose est
en train de se préparer ici il y a pas
de débordement à proprement parler et
peut-être que ça va durer ainsi mais
pour l'instant en tout cas l'ambiance a
un petit peu changé ici
boulevard Voltaire je rappelle que nous
sommes là à 50 mètres de la place de la
Nation le lieu où la manifestation doit
se terminer
[Musique]
intéressant
on peut comparer cette image en bas à
droite ou celle en haut à gauche
d'ailleurs celle qui sont sur cet écran
et l'Assemblée nationale en bas à gauche
et je demandais à Ryan Becker de nous
remontrer l'autre image celle qu'on
vient de voir avec avec Damien Canivez
c'est très différent là on voit qu'il y
a des zones dans la manifestation où il
y a une forme de tension des points des
points d'agrégation c'est un peu comme
les globules blancs quand ils se
rassemblent sur un corps étranger c'est
un peu pareil un fameux de rassemblement
des globules noirs dans une
manifestation actuellement et donc voilà
c'est comme ça que ça se passe ils sont
disséminés et de temps en temps sur un
mouvement d'arrêt il se concentre il
faut savoir que peut-être Christophe
vous a dit tout à l'heure mais à la PP
ils annonçaient qu'un Black Bloc c'était
constitué voilà la préfecture de police
un black bloc c'était constituée voilà
et donc il a pas été dissous là comme ça
instantanément par l'opération du
Saint-Esprit donc bah il s'agrège il se
désagrège je pense que c'est son des
mouvements de rassemblement d'opportun
en quelque sorte maintenant il y a quand
même beaucoup de monde et voilà plus la
l'après-midi va avancer plus la
potentialité de de rassemblement
innervé comme ça vont
va se manifester c'est une évidence
question bête peut-être mais est-ce que
la nuit amène la violence alors on a
perdu une heure non mais vraiment
la lune la nuit n'est pas un élément
facilitateur ça permet de se noyer plus
facilement dans la masse et puis ça
voilà c'est pas la même faune la nuit
qui reste et les manifestants paisibles
sont déjà quand même largement partis
quand la nuit tombe on parle de la brave
ça c'est l'une de ces composantes du
maintien de l'ordre dans ces
manifestations déjà est-ce qu'on peut
expliquer ce que c'est tout simplement
cette brave pas la brave c'est une unité
motorisée on met deux motards sur une
moto et enfin deux personnes sur une
moto un équipage ils sont une
soixantaine la personne vous avez je
crois que c'est 18 et disons une
vingtaine une petite vingtaine
d'équipage comme ça
un conducteur
de de matraque à l'arrière et il se
rendent sur les lieux à la différence
des Voltigeurs
ont laissé un mauvais souvenir dans
l'esprit des Français en fait grosso
modo c'est de la sémantique tout ça oui
en fait c'est des Voltigeurs enfin je
veux dire oui on va pas nous expliquer
que c'est pas les Voltigeurs c'est la
même chose c'est juste que dans leur
mode opératoire le voltigeur avait
tendance à cogner avec sa matraque alors
qu'il était encore assis sur la moto
alors que pour éviter
des coûts démultiplié par la vitesse par
le le mouvement l'action etc pour que ce
soit plus posé on demande tout
simplement l'équipage de poser sa moto
et les deux ensuite interviennent sur le
terrain etc donc voilà vous êtes deux
personnes et il quitte la moto et
ensuite ils ont sur terrain il y en a
pas un qui roulent et pendant tout va
comme on le voit en Iran par exemple
puisque ce sont inspirés de ces modèles
là aussi en Iran par exemple dans les
manifestations qu'on voit actuellement
sur le foulard en Iran c'est tout ce
qu'il faut pas faire c'est ce qu'on veut
éviter de faire chez nous en tout cas
donc il y a dans le mode opératoire une
volonté de rester maître de de l'action
et des dérives en quelque sorte qu'elle
ne se produisent pas voilà de mettre
toutes les chances de son côté
ils sont appelés on leur dit attention
au croisement de cette rue et telle rue
attention
invités ponctuellement à faire une
frappe chirurgicale à aller extraire les
gars à faire Pâques de temps en temps
être plusieurs pour pouvoir dans une
action offensive aller chercher les gens
suffisamment nombreux pour pouvoir faire
de la percussion de la pénétration dans
un groupe elle est extraire quelqu'un en
ressortir et le but du jeu c'est pas de
taper le but du jeu c'est d'arrêter
c'est une police et qui est en fait une
police au service de la police
judiciaire en vérité c'est-à-dire
qu'elle l'a pour extraire les gens
extraire les fauteurs de troubles et les
livrer à la justice normalement c'est
leur c'est leur rôle alors effectivement
il faut le faire avec
toute les formes nécessaires on a vu que
il y a des réglages à faire dans cette
unité parce que visiblement dans sa
composition il y a des gens soit qui
doivent être sérieusement chapitrés et
sanctionnés soit qui doivent la quitter
mais il y a un problème effectivement
dans l'encadrement de cette unité parce
que on a laissé très certainement se
développer un état d'esprit qui n'est
pas sain expliquez-moi ça bah vous avez
vu ce qui s'est passé les vous avez vu
les propos tenus les méthodes
d'interpellation de ces gens une fois en
tout cas à la sortie on rue doit pas le
gibier comme on l'a vu faire avec les
vidéos qui sont sortis dans le monde et
loopsiders ça c'est pas de la police ces
gens là soit il s'amende soit il quitte
la police est-ce que ce sont des
violences policières
à partir du moment moment où on sort du
code de déontologie et où l'institution
elle-même considère que l'IGPN doit être
saisie c'est qu'il y a un problème alors
j'ai vu certaines images notamment un
gendarme qui réprimande les policiers de
la de la Brava gendarme mobile donc
spécialiste du miennes norme qui
s'approche et qui qu'est-ce que vous
faites qu'est-ce que vous faites tout va
bien pourquoi vous l'enseigner grenade
oui alors bon ça c'est pas encore le
pire mais non mais ça montre que même
ils peuvent agacer au sein oui oui mais
l'inverse pourrait aussi je pense que si
jamais on prenait le détail de l'action
des gendarmes on trouvera peut-être des
choses à redire il est sûr que
sainte Soline il y aura tout un débat
sur tirer 4000 grenades
bon ça fait quand même ça fait quand
même beaucoup bon voilà donc il est
évident que nul n'est irréprochable tous
sont animés du sentiment de faire leur
travail de la meilleure façon qui soit
il peut y avoir des brebis galeuses d'un
côté comme de l'autre voilà simplement
il faut institution montre qu'elle est
exemplaire et que elle est capable de
remettre les choses dans l'ordre quand
ça dérape parce qu'aujourd'hui avec les
caméras avec les enregistrements enfin
avec le monde de communication qu'on
connaît qui est le nôtre voilà ça se
voit et puis ça s'enregistre et ça se
garde donc il faut que voilà il faut
vivre avec tout ça et améliorer l'outil
vous avez que le préfet de police ne
veut pas qu'on dit solve les braves qui
ont une utilité opérationnelle évidente
elles permettent d'aller très vite d'un
point à un autre pour régler les
problèmes le plus tôt possible parce que
dans l'ordre public c'est l'action le
plus rapidement possible vraiment
l'action imminente qui qui permet
d'éviter le drame mais comme dans mais
comme dans le secourisme c'est c'est les
premiers instants voilà on évite les
choses les plus graves
ces policiers des braves ils sont sous
quelle responsabilité est-ce que ce sont
des des spécialistes du maintien de
l'ordre ou pas du tout oui par exemple
il y en a pourquoi le reste du temps
d'abord voilà ils sont manifestations
ils donnent aussi un coup de main dans
les commissariats aussi quand on a
besoin d'intervention précise ils vont
se professionnaliser avec le temps il y
aura des réglages à faire ils sont
utiles il n'existe pas qu'à Paris il y
en a notamment à Toulouse par exemple et
ça va se développer sans doute parce que
c'est pas une mauvaise police le concept
est intelligent c'est un outil de
mobilité il faut l'utiliser maintenant
voilà il faut savoir comme toujours
comme toujours dans la police il faut de
l'encadrement qui soit à la hauteur des
ambitions du ministre les images de
Julien Leclerc ici on le voit quand même
quelques vitrines notamment de cette
grande enseigne de cette ancienne de
grande distribution bon finalement on en
avait eu aussi un des des cases comme ça
de vitrine lors des premières
manifestations ça n'avait pas débordé
oui mais ça c'est un peu inévitable
pendant même temps ça a été quasiment la
doctrine d'un ancien préfet de police
qui s'appelait ma Sony et qui préférait
que on casse quelques vitrines voilà
plutôt que d'intervenir systématiquement
sur tout pour éviter de créer un
phénomène d'emballement et alors c'est
Avignon c'est exaspéré les les
commerçants parce que ça tue le business
et puis ça les insécurisait mais ça
permettait peut-être effectivement
d'éviter en gros une escalade
j'ai vu aussi passer des images de la
jeunesse est-ce que ça change quelque
chose lorsque les jeunes sont dans les
manifestations est-ce que il y a des
consignes données aux forces de l'ordre
attention il peut y avoir des mineurs
attention ce sont des jeunes attention
si une population qui a moins conscience
du danger est-ce que ça change quelque
chose alors d'abord c'est inévitable
parce que quand on dit des jeunes c'est
des jeunes hommes et des jeunes femmes
d'abord ensuite parce que les policiers
sont des pères de famille déjà faut
vraiment pas le négliger parce que
souvent quand on écoute le discours syn
on a l'impression qu'on a affaire à des
robots en face non les policiers sont
pas des robots ils ont des enfants moi
je suis fils de policier voilà je pense
que mon père comme disait Giscard
d'Estaing il a un cœur voilà j'ai un
cœur voilà le policier monopole du cœur
exactement
parce que mon père était policier et
voilà donc je pense simplement que les
policiers effectivement sont attentifs
effectivement plus attentifs quoi que
c'est un public plus jeune évidemment
que c'est une information essentielle
pour le formatage des dispositifs et la
manière d'intervenir ils sont très
attentifs à cela et puis d'un point de
vue je dirais de gestion de l'ordre
public tout le monde le sait c'est une
expression qui a fait Flores mais il est
vrai que quand c'est comme le tube de
dentifrice quand les jeunes sortent
c'est difficile de les faire rentrer
dans le tube et ben c'est la même chose
que le type de dentifrice c'est pas bon
alors je crois qu'il y a une un centre
molette villa était sur splato la
dernière fois il l'a expliqué que
l'origine de cette phrase n'était pas
vraiment connue pas vraiment qu'il a
prononcé ok oui cette jeunesse elle est
dans la elle est dans la rue il y a
toujours une crainte parce que on
parlait tout à l'heure des bras des
Voltigeurs il y a le souvenir Malik
poussé quine parce que ça c'est encore
dans les têtes bah disons que c'est dans
le discours oui donc ça reste quand même
dans les têtes en tout cas de ceux qui
dirige institution parce qu'après la
police quand on parle des jeunes mais la
police il y a plein de jeunes dans la
police
faut voir ce que c'est une unité
aujourd'hui et vous avez des gens qu'on
vingt ans 25 ans 26 ans 27 ans enfin
c'est pas des vieux quoi il sort juste
de l'école ils ont quelques années
d'expérience voilà donc il y a beaucoup
de jeunes dans la police donc faut pas
s'imaginer qu'il y a pas d'empathie
c'est les mêmes
voilà donc il y a pas de haine des uns
envers les autres en tout cas en tout
cas il y a pas de haine du policier ou
du jeune policier vis-à-vis de celui qui
l'a en face des fois il a compréhension
mais de la une certaine mentale est-ce
que justement les forces de l'ordre
elles aussi elles sont impactées par par
cette réforme des retraites aussi elles
vont devoir travailler plus longtemps
alors il y a eu au début quelques
réclamations pourquoi ça s'est très vite
calmer ça se calme parce qu'en vérité le
gouvernement a besoin de la police et la
police sait très bien que elle aura pas
de mal à lui vendre l'idée que
puisqu'elle est le dernier rempart que
tout le monde concept quel est victime
de violence que le métier est difficile
qu'il est tout à fait légitime qu'elle
parte plutôt à la retraite elle a le
droit de bénéfice une bonification de 5
ans par la retraite plutôt quand ils ont
fait une carrière pleine bon bah voilà
c'est écrit quasiment dans le marbre
personne n'y touchera à ça donc grosso
modo ils savent qu'ils seront pas
impactés parce que voilà c'est plus
légitime de partir quand on est policier
dans les unités ne serait-ce que celles
qui font les maintient de l'ordre de
partir tôt que pour un cheminot qui
touche la prise de la prime de charbon
alors que le charbon il y avait dans
certaines manifestations je l'ai entendu
des forces des manifestants qui crient
aux forces de l'ordre mais on est dans
le même camp rejoignez-nous
aussi le cas lors des gilets jaunes
souvenez-vous les Forza sont sacrément
mal payés vous aussi vous êtes malade de
la jonction effectivement de de de des
forces de sécurité et du peuple puisque
comme dit Darmanin non sans raison
d'ailleurs la police c'est le peuple
alors on se dit bah oui effectivement ça
pourrait être mon beau-frère ma
belle-sœur mon cousin mon frère après
tout voilà nous sommes tous des êtres
humains non mais en fait plus
sérieusement
ça c'est le grand c'est le grand fant à
gauche alors ça marche un peu avec les
pompiers vous aurez remarqué qu'on voit
des les pompiers bah il y a des pompiers
syndiqués ils sont ils sont ils ont ils
ont l'esprit de groupe l'esprit l'esprit
de cohésion et ils ont une retraite à
défendre aussi donc voilà comme ils sont
plus physiques etc mais voilà de temps
en temps et on a quelques fréquences des
pompiers des interventions de pompiers
dans les différentes les pompiers c'est
des gentils mais
il y a des moments où ils ont une
expression de groupe qui est parfois un
peu limite souvenez-vous enfin je ne
sais pas si vous étiez au journal à
cette époque là mais dans cette rue du
Louvre nous sommes actuellement les
pompiers pour un papier qu'on avait
écrit il y a quelques années qui ne leur
plaisaient pas sur leur organisation
leurs avantages que sais-je était venu
manifester ils avaient balancé les
canapés en bas du patient ils étaient
venus casser des choses au journal un
peu comme la CGT de leur ne le faisait
pas
donc ils ont été je crois que c'est eux
qui ont été les plus loin d'ailleurs
dans l'expression du mécontentement
auprès de notre rédaction en venant
casser les choses c'était les pompiers
bon comme quoi on a survécu puisque vous
êtes là vous êtes là pour pour en parler
Jean-Marc vous garde encore quelques
instants on va essayer de retrouver
Vincent roseron sur le terrain Vincent
vous êtes vous en êtes où cette
manifestation est-ce qu'elle l'avance
progressivement alors je vais vous
donner des chiffres puisque vous avez
fait beaucoup de manifestations selon la
CGT évidemment on attendra les chiffres
officiels du ministère de l'Intérieur
450 000 personnes manifestent
aujourd'hui dans Paris toujours selon la
CGT à cette heure-ci il avait 800 000
manifestants dans les rues de la
capitale vous le flux que vous voyez
passer il a l'air de ressembler à 450
000 personnes ou pas vraiment
alors toujours beaucoup de mal à donner
des chiffres mais effectivement au début
il y avait rien à voir moins de gens
dans cette manifestation et au final
plus le temps passe et en fait on se
rend compte que le principe il y avait
un grand cortège qui est parti d'abord
qui est quasiment arrivé qui arrivait
très vite en fait place de la Nation moi
je me trouve un peu après le point de
départ en fait à Saint-Ambroise qui est
en gros à deux arrêts de métro deux
arènes métro de la place de la
République et en fait depuis un moment
là on est avec une foule qui ne qui ne
s'arrête pas une foule aussi assez
compacte j'aurais beaucoup de mal
effectivement à vous dire s'il y a plus
ou moins de gens que la semaine dernière
merci Vincent roseron en tout cas sur
ces images on voit que ça se passe dans
le calme là on est plutôt Jean-Marc dans
la partie calme traditionnelle de la
manifestation on voit qu'il y a pas de
débordements et pas de profil dangereux
oui oui absolument enfin il y en a sans
doute quelques-uns qui sont agrégés sans
doute sur les points d'abscès peut-être
que on n'a pas la l'image mais en tout
cas on peut pas dire que ce soit
effectivement une manifestation qui
présente un profil inquiétant quand on
voit les images
sur l'histoire du comptage j'aimerais
revenir dessus parce que
on entend souvent dire finalement la
vérité doit être entre les deux entre ce
que dit la police et ce que disent les
centrales syndicales en fait bon pas du
tout moi j'ai ma religion sur le sujet
il se trouve qu'un jour
il y a un certain nombre d'années il y
avait un long cortège important et je
m'étais dit tiens je vais procéder
exactement comme les mecs derrière j'ai
faux je vais mettre sur un point haut et
je vais utiliser leur technique à dire
que on compte des blocs donc on débloque
de rencontrer un bloc de démarrage 300
personnes on voit la physionomie du bloc
et ensuite à chaque point
identifié du défilement du sur un
boulevard du défilement des gens on
considère que ben voilà un bloc de 300
vient de passer un autre bloc de 32
vient de passer et à la louche mais
c'est quand même relativement précis et
alors ça prend un temps fou on prend son
petit carnet on peut mettre une barre et
on fait une barre tous les 3 ans on fait
une barre exactement et puis à la fin de
la manifestation alors ça a pris quand
même quasiment je sais pas de mémoire je
crois que ça a pris 1h30 ou deux heures
et moi j'ai compté 125
[Musique]
000 manifestants avec mon petit cahier
et mon petit truc alors c'est sûr
c'était un travail voilà c'était
beaucoup de monde et et
à ma grande surprise alors je suis bah
moi je me fie à ce que j'ai vu et moi
j'ai pris le temps de compter j'avais eu
aucun autre journaliste qui s'amusait à
faire ça d'ailleurs ce jour-là peut-être
que depuis j'ai des collègues qui
s'amusent à le faire
pour ça il suffit de détacher une
personne et puis de compter c'est cher
vous savez ce que c'est maintenant on
est payé on est payé et donc donc en
fait simplement prendre son temps c'est
sûr c'est un peu la c'est fastidieux
mais on le fait on le fait puis une fois
qu'on est en poivron et qu'on a fait son
comptage éventuellement on prend deux
personnes deux journalistes et deux
journalistes vous voulez vraiment
on prendra des intermittents et donc le
résultat en tout cas c'est que on compte
chacun ensuite on met on croise ces
données et ensuite on voit bien à peu
près si on arrive à peu près à la même
chose et puis à partir de là on
confronte ce qui est annoncé le soir
dans les organisations syndicales et à
la préfecture et quand vous avez pas moi
j'avais 125000 la préfecture a donné 120
000 et les centrales syndicales
n'avaient plus de 400 000 ce jour-là
c'était rigoureusement impossible 400
000 personnes qui soient passées sous
mes yeux jour là rigoureusement
impossible de ce jour-là je ne tiré un
enseignement c'est que les organisations
syndicales mentent systématiquement
qu'avant elle multipliait par trois ou
quatre il y a une dizaine d'années le
nombre que la police annonçait
qu'aujourd'hui ça les dérange pas du
tout de compter 8 à 10 fois plus ça leur
donne pas de bouton ben en vérité si on
prenait le temps de vraiment compter et
bien on se rendrait compte que tout ça
la foutaise que le chiffre est beaucoup
plus proche de celui le fléchis frais
beaucoup plus proche que celui de la
police est plus proche de celui de la
police que celui des organisations
syndicales que ça plaise ou non mais par
contre plaisance on est toujours en
train de nous expliquer parce qu'on veut
pas froisser parce que c'est le
politiquement correct que faut pas être
d'accord avec les chiffres de la police
bah moi si les chiffres de la police ils
sont plus proches de mon comptable
j'estime que les chiffres la police sont
les plus crédibles c'est simple non mais
il y a toujours des gens et je peux les
comprendre qui disent oui mais le
gouvernement a besoin a besoin de faire
baisser les chiffres pour montrer que
cette mobilisation n'est pas si
importante ça peut s'entendre cet
argument Jean-Marc oui sauf que les
Français à une chose dans la police
contrairement à ce qu'on imagine il y a
des représentants de toutes les
chapelles il y a des gens de droite de
gauche il y a de tout dans la police et
aujourd'hui et tout fait quelque chose
truqué les choses dans la police et ben
je souhaite bon courage à celui qui va
donner des ordres pour truquer les
choses dans la police alors que tout est
scruté tout se sait il y a des traces de
tout
voilà c'est
ça me paraît pas une évidence de faire
du trucage généralisé sans que ça se
sache
j'ai encore quelques questions on
parlait ces dernières semaines des gros
bras de la CGT qui tenaient les manifs
ils sont pas là aujourd'hui ils ne sont
pas là aujourd'hui
j'étais très déçu je les ai pas vu
ils ne sont pas là ils sont à
Clermont-Ferrand parce qu'il est un
congrès de la CGT cette semaine avec
l'élection d'un nouveau secrétaire
général vendredi fin du Martinez qui te
son poste parce que ça change quelque
chose quand c'est gros bras de la CGT
les fameux gros bras de la société ne
sont pas là si ça se passe bien on va
dire que finalement c'est parce que
c'est parce qu'ils sont là que ça se
passe mal c'est maléfique si jamais ça
dégénère on dira que c'est finalement la
CGT qui a laissé porte ouverte
puisqu'elle donnait en gros un coup de
main à la police à sa façon en calmant
les choses et bien on dira que la CGT a
anticipé ou à inciter à ce que ça se
passe mal j'ai pas le j'ai pas
l'explication
c'est pas un élément de toute façon
essentiel les gros bras de la CGT ça
protège les cortèges quand ça va mal
mais ça protège les cortèges au sein de
la CGT ils sont censés protéger surtout
leur voix c'est surtout comme ça que ça
se passe c'est ça leur philosophie
d'ailleurs on a bien vu souvent qu'il y
avait des heures entre les Black Blocs
et les voiles de la CGT il se battent
entre eux voilà donc ça prouve bien que
ils ont pas les mêmes intérêts
et je suis pas sûr malgré toutes les
intérêts de la CGT soient ceux de la
police c'est pas la question les
intérêts de la CGT c'est que leur
cortège se déroule correctement et que
ceux de leur adhérents qui sont parfois
remboursés de leur genre de grève par
une caisse dédiée pour venir manifester
et bien puisse manifester en paix sachez
que nous n'avons pas d'image de violence
puisqu'il n'y a pas de violence pour
l'instant ah bah tiens voilà les
premiers vous avez un feu d'un feu non
ou des poubelles des poubelles peut-être
bon ben voilà pour que ça arrive
17h que ça commence à dégénérer on aura
remarqué
et alors c'est vrai qu'il y a un
phénomène lorsque la c'est comme l'odeur
de la poudre lorsque l'odeur de
l'incendie le bruit des pétards et les
premiers et lacrymogène
comment ça se disséminer sur un espace
de manifestation on change de registre
on change de psychologie et ça devient
plus animal et c'est peut-être ce à quoi
on va assister à un moment c'est
peut-être pour ça aussi qu'on dit à les
forces de l'ordre ont agité les tensions
d'une certaine manière dès que les
forces de l'ordre se rapprochent dès que
les premiers gaz lacrymogènes sont
lancés oui parce qu'on rentre dans un
autre registre c'est quasiment dans le
registre avant c'était une marche puis
après ça devient de la chasse c'est à
dire qu'on chasse le casseur on chasse
au tiboule parce qu'on veut le ramener
on veut soit le dissuader soit aller le
chercher donc on change de registre ça
se passe dans un climat ou vous avez les
détentions visibles palpable en plus ça
sent pas bon on a les yeux qui piquent
voilà ça devient inquiétant cette oui ça
devient un climat nauséabond voilà tout
simplement bon nous espérons que
nous reporters sur place vont bien alors
je vous donne une information quand même
difficile à essayer de filmer vous
l'avez vu Jean-Marc tout à l'heure
difficile de filmer les vitrines cassées
par certains manifestants présents dans
cette dans cette marche parce que et
bien
les potentiels
viennent bousculer la caméra
judiciaires
de donner le nombre de casseurs attendus
pourquoi
ne t'ont pas capable de les interpeller
de les arrêter c'est
alors l'explication qui est donnée c'est
que c'est qu'ils sont très mobiles et
qui sont difficiles à arrêter parce
qu'ils courent plus vite et on pourrait
imaginer qu'effectivement le ministre
quand ça va mal il veut donner une
explication à l'opinion alors il faut
qu'il montre que puisse se laisser mal
passé l'institution assuré agir et on
nous sort des chiffres énormes
arrestation de 100 300 400 personnes en
vérité dans le lot on en arrête une
bonne partie et qui était ceux qui
pourraient le moins vite et donc on fait
un effet de masse des fois on n'arrête
même une période même des fois qu'on
arrête les clients les clients qui
sortaient d'un restaurant et qui avait
rien à voir avec des fois même le
serveur du restaurant voilà il y a un
petit peu de il y a un peu de déchets
c'est clair voilà on veut faire un
phénomène de nombres et on mélange un
peu tout parce que voilà faut montrer
que l'institution assurait réagir
il y avait potentiellement les mêmes
personnes à Sainte Soline que
aujourd'hui dans la manifestation il y
avait des étrangers on doit bien
savoir par un moyen
des réseaux sociaux d'Internet de
d'écoute pourquoi nous ne sommes pas
capable d'arrêter et de condamner ces
personnes qui
mettent le bazar dans ces manifestations
écoutez c'est vrai que la tentation
pourrait être grande de ce livre
finalement ça arrange bien la police que
pour discréditer les mouvements sociaux
que
en gros les plus agités et pourquoi pas
même dire d'ailleurs que des policiers
pourraient peut-être même faire partie
de leur rang des fois on l'entend lire
ce qui paraît quand même assez aberrant
mais enfin quoi qu'il en soit
le non je pense que simplement on a fait
un public de gens qui sont aguerris qui
sont qui se sont professionnalisés qui
viennent qui viennent de loin qu'on
comprit des habitudes de dissimulation
ils savent comment travailler la police
ils l'ont étudié au fil des au fil des
manifestations aujourd'hui tout ce sein
y compris d'ailleurs la manière de
travailler la police on le sait
aujourd'hui il y a pas besoin d'aller
grands grands clairs pour qu'il suffit
d'aller sur certains réseaux sociaux sur
certains sites on voit bien il
s'échangent des combines ils discutent
entre eux la police les suit à distance
on essaye d'avoir alors après dans quand
vous avez des gens dans la foule c'est
compliqué et puis ensuite il faut savoir
aussi que la police a essayé de se doter
d'outils enfin il y a un gouvernement
d'outils qui permettent d'agir
préventivement contre les casseurs en
faisant des arrestations préventives ils
se sont quand même une prix des râteaux
au niveau juridiques le gouvernement
avec leur texte et c'est très difficile
d'aller préventivement arrêter les gens
pour leur empêcher de un peu parce que
les lois anti hooligans vous voyez bah
en fait c'est pas si simple et dans un
système où le le jus Eurydice mais roi
en France et bien il est difficile de se
donner les outils de la de la de la
prévention dans ce genre de dans ce
genre de contexte le premier feu de la
journée visiblement en tout cas sur nos
images qui prend de l'ampleur
nous verrons comment évolue la situation
on reste avec ces images
Jean-Marc vous libère et en attendant je
vais voir Vincent roseron qui est sur le
terrain Vincent vous êtes plutôt à
l'arrière avec une manifestation qui se
déroule dans le calme dans cette
deuxième partie de cortège
oui Tibo effectivement toujours dans le
calme cette deuxième partie de de
cortège le Candel a l'air d'accélérer un
petit peu là depuis quelques instants
hop là voilà il y a quelques petits boom
mais c'est totalement maîtrisé c'est en
fait faut cheminot qui fait péter des
pétards depuis le début tout au long de
leur cortège mais sinon la manifestation
se passe complètement dans le calme ici
vous voyez les ballons de FO qui passe
la CGT qui est tout au fond de ces
images et voilà la manifestation qui se
poursuit ici je me trouve toujours à
Saint-Ambroix en fait allant juste pas
très loin en fait du début de la
manifestation
là où sont en fait les partis politiques
parce que vous l'avez vu on a eu
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ça vient Roussel
Yannick Jadot en fait tout au long du
parcours il y a les différents partis
politiques qui ne se mêlent pas
directement à la manifestation mais qui
par contre discute avec des gens qui les
interpellent petit à petit sur le
cortège
merci beaucoup Vincent roserand dans le
cortège vous voyez ces images de la
manifestation à Paris tous c'est plutôt
bien passé jusqu'ici ces premières
images de feu et de violence en bas à
droite nous verrons dans les minutes qui
viennent comment évolue la situation
forentin Colomb bonjour bonjour
journaliste officaro économie
internationale ancien correspondant à
Londres au Royaume-Uni pour le pour Le
Figaro j'ai plein de questions je
voulais vous venir pour nous parler de
ce qu'il s'est passé d'abord la semaine
dernière avec cette annulation de la
visite de Charles III qu'est-ce qu'il
s'est passé pour une fois
Emmanuel Macron gouvernement a entendu
ce qui ne se passait dans la rue et il a
répondu une certaine manière je sais pas
s'il y avait une demande de la rue d'une
annulation sans doute de la visite du
chef d'État botanique il y a des
politiques qui l'ont qui ont beaucoup
insisté dans ce sens avant avant que
qu'elle soit effectivement annulée pour
rappel on est aujourd'hui dans le cadre
de cette
[Musique]
pour essayer de s'en prendre à lui mais
pour perturber la visite on fait on fait
décidé à l'Élysée en particulier à
Emmanuel Macron qui je crois a été le
instrumental dans la enfin qui a été
proactif lui-même dans la le fait de
prendre cette décision parce que
après il avait des conseils de la police
et conseils du gouvernement il y a eu
des relations des discussions entre les
ambassades aussi évidemment avec
l'ambassade britannique qui commençait
un peu à s'inquiéter de ce qu'elle
voyait se dérouler en France mais en
même temps c'est pas venu des
Britanniques c'est c'est l'Élysée qui a
décidé d'annuler cette visite en se
disant que les conditions n'étaient pas
réunies et Emmanuel Macron lui-même a
appelé vendredi matin le roi Charles
pour
discuter avec lui pendant je crois un
quart d'heure une discussion et il lui
et lui dire que c'était pas
recommandable de venir maintenant mais
s'il n'avait pas fait ça je pense que la
visite aurait eu lieu c'est pas les
Britanniques qui ont dit on a trop peur
de venir on vient passer pas le genre
donc voilà donc en fait elle a
conclusion de ça c'est que on a une
crise sociale en France c'est évident on
le voit depuis des semaines on a une
impasse politique et là tout d'un coup
une nouvelle dimension est entrée un
petit peu dans dans le tableau c'est la
dimension diplomatique c'est à dire que
la France est empêchée de mener des
relations diplomatiques normales avec
des des partenaires comme cela se
pratique toujours et ce n'est pas
systématique que des problèmes sociaux
en France est un impact sur le volet
politique étrangère de la France et là
c'est le cas il y a un autre exemple qui
pourrait arriver dans les dans les
semaines qui viennent Emmanuel Macron
doit partir en Chine par exemple oui
mais c'est un peu le cas inverse parce
qu'il doit partir donc personne va
l'empêcher de partir après on pourra lui
reprocher de pas être là c'est ça quand
il y a des tensions en France la
question c'est est-ce que la crise des
retraites est suffisamment grave pour
que plus rien ne se passe dans le pays
que le gouvernement et l'exécutif soit
obligé de d'annuler toutes
toutes conduite de d'autres sujets
politiques et de politique étrangères ça
reste un démontrer quand même
sur notre choix d'Emmanuel Macron qui
doit partir début avril
en Chine quel est le symbole là en
Europe au Royaume-Uni après cette
annulation j'imagine que d'un seul coup
le projecteur qui était franco-français
j'imagine que très peu de médias à
l'étranger de s'intéresser à cette crise
là c'est plus le cas oui exactement ça a
mis un coup de projecteur ça a été un
peu le la conjonction des manifestations
de la qui ont dégénéré en violence jeudi
dernier jeudi soir qui ont donné lieu à
des images apocalyptiques parfois
reprise dans certains journaux
d'incendie de de poubelles
répandues dans toutes les rues enfin au
milieu de rue de casse etc et puis
l'annulation de cette visite du roi
parce que c'est quand même pas tous les
jours qu'on reçoit un roi étranger en
particulier roi d'Angleterre
qu'il s'agissait de la première visite
d'État donc en effet il y a plusieurs
effets induits l'un des effets induits
c'est que après la France le roi Charles
devait se rendre en Allemagne ce qu'il
va faire donc demain
la conséquence que c'est que la première
visite d'État du Roi Charles aura été
finalement pour l'Allemagne et c'est
pour la France sera reporté au
calendrier si je puis dire en fait on a
parlé du début de l'été à savoir comment
quand on a trouvé des dates et puis en
effet un coup de projecteur sur ce qui
se passe en France plus ou moins
alarmiste pour certains médias étrangers
c'est la tradition française dans toute
sa splendeur mais pour d'autres ça
attire l'attention sur une sorte de sur
les violences sur une une protestation
sociale sur la popularité très forte de
l'exécutif et sur une paralysie de la
France pour réformer parce que jusqu'à
présent Macron était plutôt vu d'un bon
œil dans la communauté internationale la
presse internationale comme le Financial
Times etc trouvait que c'était un
référend amateur qui a
Macron et tout d'un coup on se rend
compte que il est empêché dans ses
projets de réforme et entraver et qui
qui l'a vraiment du mal à imposer ses
vues en France et du coup ça soulève
plein de questions sur ce second mandat
sur la crédibilité Emmanuel Macron d'une
certaine manière et entacher il se veut
par exemple leader européen sur la
question de l'écologie sur l'Ukraine par
exemple comme grand médiateur entre
l'Ukraine et la Russie par exemple tout
à fait d'un seul coup les dirigeants
les Européens étrangers peuvent se dire
gentil Macron mais qui gère d'abord ses
problèmes chez lui puis après il y a un
sentiment qui est pas forcément exprimé
mais qui est tout à fait légitime et qui
qui peut se développer alors c'est vrai
qu'il était un Conseil européen jeudi et
vendredi oui jeudi et vendredi dernier à
Bruxelles c'est un sommet européen à
l'Ukraine à l'énergie à plusieurs sujets
économiques aussi
c'est vrai que ça entache sa crédibilité
on l'a vu avec aussi l'annulation de la
visite du roi donc le titre parce que il
s'agissait de renouer des relations
diplomatiques Bretagne qui les relations
ont été plutôt mauvaises ces derniers
temps ces dernières années et tout d'un
coup Macron est un petit peu de fait mis
à l'écart puisque le chef de l'État
britannique va discuter avec les
Allemands et pas avec les Français c'est
symbolique ces protocolaires mais ça
fait partie des relations diplomatiques
et puis et puis en effet il y a cette
question sur sa capacité à réformer dans
son propre pays qui peut lui être
imposer qui peut être lui être rétorqué
quand il s'agit de réformer en Europe en
effet il perd un petit peu des plumes de
son de sa casquette de de leader un peu
autre autoproclamé de l'Europe vous
voyez ces images en direct dans les rues
de la capitale en haut à gauche les
forces de l'ordre qui semble s'approcher
et se déplacer de plus en plus souvent
les voyez assez peu depuis le début
cette manifestation ce n'est visiblement
plus le cas depuis que nous avons vu
arriver les premières images que vous
avez en bas avec ses feux allumés par
des manifestants
nous verrons et nous attendons les
images et les réactions de nos reporters
sur place pour pouvoir donner plus
d'informations sur ce qu'il se passe et
s'il ne s'agit que d'épi phénomènes ou
si la manifestation est en train
d'entrer dans une phase plus violente
avec Florentin Colomb journaliste ça
économie au service de l'économie
internationale et ancien reporters à
Londres comment les Anglais voient la
France sur cette question des retraites
est-ce que en Royaume-Uni on manifeste
est-ce qu'on a cette culture de la
manifestation il y a pas du tout la même
culture et la manifestation il y a des
manifestations parce qu'il y a une crise
sociale aussi d'une autre nature au
Royaume-Uni qui est plus liée au salaire
qu'on connaît aussi en France donc il y
a eu beaucoup de débrayage et il y a
même un record qui n'avait pas été
atteint depuis une quarantaine d'années
au Royaume-Uni depuis la fin des années
pour des manifestations revendicatives
enfin surtout des débrayages des grèves
qui s'accompagnent parfois de
manifestations mais il y a pas cette
culture de grande manifestations
massives politiques et
interprofessionnel très souvent les
manifestations sont un peu corporatives
donc c'est les cheminots qui défilent
pour demander des augmentations ou les
enseignants etc je me souviens pas du
tout et d'ailleurs le la loi l'interdit
les syndicats ne peuvent pas
se mettre en grève pour un mot d'ordre
qui ne les conserve qui ne concerne pas
leur fédération professionnelle le droit
de grève a été très fortement encadré et
restreint et du coup c'est assez rare de
voir ce genre de de manifestation en
Angleterre mais moi je me souviens quand
j'étais correspondant à Londres j'avais
justement suivi une manifestation pour
les retraites des fonctionnaires et des
enseignants et j'avais été assez surpris
stupéfait de la timidité de ces
manifestants les voyait à peine ça
bloquait même pas la circulation c'était
arrangé pour que le parcours ne gène le
moins possible il défilait à pas très
très rapide et en une heure ou deux
heures c'était bouclée et personne ne
s'en était rendu compte et la presse
n'en parlait quasiment pas donc il n'y a
pas du tout en effet cette culture après
sur le fond de la réforme des retraites
c'est aussi intéressant quand on parle
de comparaison internationale de de
regarder un petit peu la vision la
perception de nos florentins ça
m'intéresse on va en parler je veux
juste qu'on aille sur le terrain avant
ça parce qu'on a Damien canivels qui est
proche de ses premiers échauffourés
Damien on a commencé à se parler aux
alentours de 14 heures tout allait bien
les choses sont en train de changer
quelque peu
oui effectivement Thibault Gauthier je
suis proche de là où ça se passe c'est à
dire que vous voyez sur les images de
Julien Leclerc un départ de feu qui a eu
lieu je ne peux pas vous dire ce qui se
passe très exactement parce que nous
nous sommes mis en retrait pour quelle
raison parce que des militants d'ultra
gauche s'en sont pris à des journalistes
on a eu des témoignages ici ou là de de
manifestants pacifistes qui nous ont
demandé de faire très attention parce
que des des des Black Blocs sans son
prix à des journalistes qui tenaient des
caméras des caméras ont été même volées
donc voilà nous nous mettons un petit
peu en retrait il y a des dégradations
ici boulevard Voltaire des départs de
feu on a vu des feux de poubelle
également des dégradations de vitrines
un relais d'une grande enseigne de
distribution a été vandalisée avec des
mortiers d'artifice qui ont été projetés
à l'intérieur un grand opticien
également la vitrine d'un grand opticien
a été pulvérisé bref tous ces symboles
du capitalisme selon ces militants
d'extrême gauche qui on découdre avec la
police ont été mis à mal voilà la
situation est en train de de se tendre
ici c'est vrai que la manifestation
officiellement est terminée puisque nous
sommes arrivés depuis un bon moment au
niveau de la place de la Nation mais on
a vu quelques minutes auparavant les
manifestants les plus radicaux les plus
en colère si j'ose dire rebrousser
chemin parce que ils ont aperçu cette
épaisse fumée noire qui se dégageait du
boulevard Voltaire et ils ont su que
c'est à ce moment-là à cet endroit
précis que que ce passé voilà très
concrètement les violences qui étaient
attendues ici à Paris alors
contrairement à ce qu'on a pu voir la
semaine dernière dans les rues de la
capitale évidemment c'est sans commune
mesure avec les dégradations de des
nombreuses citrines les affrontements
que les forces de l'ordre parce que il
faut savoir Thibault que les forces de
l'ordre sont très peu présentes ici sur
ce boulevard Voltaire on les a beaucoup
vu en début de manifestation devant le
cortège syndical c'est magnifique c'est
force de l'ordre et ses gendarmes de de
contrôler comme il le pouvait la
manifestation de façon à ce qu'un prêt
cortège ne se forme pas devant
l'intersyndical finalement les
manifestants les plus radicaux ont
réussi à faire en sorte que la police
prenne un peu plus d'avance et ce
pré-corpège c'est bien formé et a pris
beaucoup d'ampleur jusqu'à la place de
l'indation vous voyez où des voilà des
dégradations ont lieu avec des slogans
tels qu'on les connaît tout le monde
déteste la police et puis également des
slogans anti-bras m dont on a parlé tout
à l'heure vous savez c'est c'est brigade
motorisé à Paris qui sont très décrié
depuis ces dernières semaines alors vous
savez Gérald Darmanin a déclaré ces
dernières ces derniers jours que les
Black Blocs étaient des blackburges pour
reprendre son expression ce serait des
des enfants gâtés vous savez des des
enfants issus de bonne famille des
jeunes des des jeunes manifestants ce
que l'on peut constater ici c'est que ce
n'est pas forcément le cas on aperçoit
un mouvement de foule déjà donc je vais
permettre en hauteur parce que là c'est
manifestement peut-être les forces de
l'ordre qui viennent d'entrer sur ce
boulevard Voltaire c'est souvent ce
qu'on constate lorsqu'il y a ceux ce
mouvement de foule pour en revenir au
profil des des des des de de ces
militants on se rend compte en réalité
qu'il y a aussi beaucoup de de d'hommes
d'acheter peut-être d'une cinquantaine
d'années on n'est pas du tout sur un
profil d'étudiants qui s'ennuient dans
dans sa chambre voilà c'est vous le
voyez d'ailleurs sur les images de
Julien Leclerc il n'y a pas que des
personnes habillées en noir il y a
peut-être aussi des curieux qui sont là
pour assister à ce qui se passe mais
voilà vous vous rendez compte que le
profils est assez est assez varié voilà
je ne vois pas exactement ce qui se
passe vous voyez très certainement mieux
que moi sur les images de de Thibault
Gauthier en attendant il est fort
probable que la police arrive boulevard
Voltaire si ce n'est déjà fait
sur ces images pour que vous puissiez
voir ce qu'il se passe il faut voir
Voltaire on a vu la quelques instants en
prenant les forces de l'ordre en effet
Damien de notre sur le sur le boulevard
suivi des pompiers ça semble pour cela
que les forces de l'ordre ont avancé
très rapidement en charge pour écarter
la foule pour que les pompiers puissent
accéder à ces différents feux que l'on
commence à voir s'éparpiller le long de
la manifestation ensuite évidemment ce
qui se passe Damien faites attention
on continue dans dans d'en parler
ensemble de parler de la vision de la
France à l'étranger j'ai vu passer le
hashtag BIM of French soyez plus
français je sais pas si vous avez vu ça
au Royaume-Uni il y a une grève de plus
longtemps notamment avec des infirmes
voudrais être plus français je voudrais
voir ça dans les régions c'est vrai
qu'il y a plusieurs pays qui voient ce
qui se passe et qui voit le résultat par
le résultat il est pas obtenu encore le
retrait de la réforme mais enfin qui
voit qu'il y a une action quand même
assez efficace des syndicats et des
représentants salariés et qui certains
se disent il faudrait peut-être
s'inspirer des méthodes françaises pour
être plus revendicatif et plus musclé
dans les revendications les
revendications à l'étranger qui a en ce
moment en Allemagne une grande grève
lundi par exemple au Royaume-Uni oui il
y a plein de conflits pour addict dans
la santé dans le rail dans
l'enseignement dans la fonction publique
elles sont salariales en général pour
l'instant il y a peu de
sur les retraites il y a aussi quand
même beaucoup de gens à l'étranger qui
regardent ce qui se passe en France et
qui disent qui sont quand même un peu
médusés de voir que on en est à la
dixième journée de protestation contre
une réforme qui vise à monter l'âge de
du départ à la retraite de 62 à 64 ans
alors qu'à 62 ans on est il faut le
rappeler quand même parmi les plus c'est
l'âge de départ à la retraite le plus
tôt le plus jeune de l'Union européenne
de l'Union européenne avec la Grèce avec
la Norvège qui n'est pas dans l'Union
européenne
et en Suède la Suède figurait 62 ans
mais en réalité on ne peut pas partir à
taux plein 62 ans en Suède il faut
attendre au moins 65 ans la moyenne est
plutôt
il y a pas mal de pays qui sont à 66
voire 67 ans aujourd'hui 67 ans c'est
pas des pays ultra libéraux c'est nos
voisins italiens c'est
l'Espagne c'est l'Irlande
Allemagne est à 66 pour l'instant mais
c'est acquis qu'elle va passer à 67
Royaume-Uni ils sont à 66 et d'ailleurs
le gouvernement britannique de
richissounac la semaine dernière a
décidé en toute discrétion sans aucune
contestation mais peut-être en voyant ce
qui se passait en France de reporter à
plus tard l'extension de la vie active
jusqu'à 69 ans qui était prévu à
l'horizon 2040 ça veut dire qu'il y a un
report de 66 à 67 ans qui est déjà à
pied au Royaume-Uni alors ça c'est l'âge
légal mais je veux partir avant on peut
partir avant mais avec une décote de
toute façon bon les systèmes sont très
différents d'un pays à l'autre au
Royaume-Uni il y a une très grosse part
de capitalisation puisque la retraite
publique elle ne vous donne droit qu'à
quelques centaines en cette autour de
400 euros par mois si vous avez une
retraite à taux plein de de du public
donc
après on peut varier en effet sur selon
vos économies si vous avez fait fortune
oui vous pouvez partir plus tôt mais si
vous avez besoin de d'avoir cotisé le
nombre d'années nécessaires y compris
par capitalisation on peut pas plutôt
donc dans beaucoup de pays il y a quand
même beaucoup d'étonnement de voir que
les Français en viennent là et qu'il y
ait une mobilisation aussi forte aussi
dure aussi soudée aussi des syndicats et
une résistance politique
assez unanime à part le parti au pouvoir
pour rejeter cette réforme qui fait que
si même si les 64 ans qui ont été
adoptés après la le 49.3 il y a deux
semaines entre en vigueur on restera
quand même à l'âge le plus le pays qui
parle le plus tôt à la retraite d'Europe
est-ce que à l'étranger on a envie les
Français d'une certaine manière ou au
contraire on se dit mais regardez-moi
ces fainéant un peu les deux j'imagine
oui il y a beaucoup de pays qui se
disent qu'on travaille pas beaucoup en
France que on part tout à la retraite
qu'on est au 35 heures qu'on a beaucoup
de vacances et puis il y a des gens dans
les pays dans les pays étrangers qui en
vie aussi
les acquis sociaux français qui sont
exceptionnels quand même le rappeler
c'est vrai qu'on entend quand même
beaucoup en France que les acquis
sociaux sont rognés que ça devient de
plus en plus difficile mais les
conditions y compris l'assurance maladie
gratuite
y compris l'enseignement gratuit public
y compris l'indemnisation chômage même
s'il y a eu des réformes de de du
chômage qui est quand même encore très
généreuse par rapport à beaucoup de pays
et les retraites aussi le niveau des
pensions est parmi les plus généreux au
monde donc
il faut relativiser aussi tout ça enfin
je suis pas là pour dire que qui a
raison qui a tort mais j'apportais une
perspective un peu internationale voilà
sur ce débat qui est souvent quand même
ici
franco-français ou alors où on a
tendance à dire on est la France donc
c'est comme ça et on ne peut pas on n'a
pas à tenir compte de ce qui se fait à
l'étranger ce qui était vrai mais en
tout cas on peut sans forcément tenir
compte dans nos réformes ou les
décisions l'avoir à l'esprit merci
beaucoup florentin Collomb journaliste
au service économie international du
Figaro ancien correspondant à Londres
pour Le Figaro nous avons expliqué
donner des infos sur ce qu'on voit à
l'étranger de la France sur la vision
des étrangers
de la France merci beaucoup on retrouve
Damien Canivez Damien vous êtes sur
place
ça a basculé en un quart d'heure ou
presque alors est-ce que c'est
l'ensemble de la manifestation qui est
touchée par ces violences qu'on voit
l'image ou non c'est dans un endroit
très précis sur le boulevard Voltaire
écoutez Thibault ça basculé en même
moins de 10 secondes parce que il faut
savoir que les manifestants radicaux
étaient statiques depuis plusieurs
minutes vers la fin de la manifestation
boulevard Voltaire et les policiers sont
venus comme d'un seul homme en surgit
comme c'est le cas depuis maintenant de
nombreuses semaines dans la stratégie
voulue par le préfet de police ils ont
surgi d'une rue parallèle ils étaient
invisibles jusque là et ont chargé des
manifestants qui ont couru sprinter
direction la place de la Nation qui se
trouve à seulement 100 mètres de là où
nous nous trouvons et
c'est manifestants étaient de plus en
plus violents ils ont allumé des feux de
poubelle ils ont dégradé des vitrines
aussi là vous voyez sur les images de
Julien Leclerc une poubelle en feu et
très certainement ces policiers ont
voulu voilà voulu les maîtriser et faire
en sorte qu'ils arrivent place de la
Nation peut-être pour mieux les
contrôler parce que vous savez que la
police préfère lorsque les manifestants
sont Nasser dans un endroit sont
statique plutôt plutôt que des
manifestations sauvages telles qu'on les
a connues d'ailleurs les Black Blocs
sont conscients de cette stratégie de la
police puisque nous avons surpris des
conversations entre ces militants
radicaux qui parfois souhaité partir en
manifestation sauvages c'est impossible
il faut le savoir puisque la
manifestation qui s'étend aujourd'hui de
la place de la République à la place de
la Nation est très encadrée par la
police même si elle est invisible il
voilà il
ceinture
le cortège le cortège parisien autre
point important aussi c'est militants
radicaux étaient extrêmement nombreux
vous entendez au loin des grenades de
désencerclement qui sont lancés par la
police avec des bombes lacrymogènes
aussi on en a eu quelques-unes sur le
boulevard Voltaire qui ont été lancés il
y a quelques instants le groupe des
Black Blocs a été scindé en deux de
façon peut-être à mieux les à mieux les
les contrôler on en a vu certains
rebrousser chemin remonter le boulevard
Voltaire à l'opposé de de la place de la
Nation peut-être pour faire en sorte que
ces petits groupes soient beaucoup plus
facile
à gérer voilà l'ambiance est très tendue
ici ce n'est pas du tout représentatif
de la manifestation que l'on a couverte
aujourd'hui nous sommes devant le
cortège syndical évidemment le reste de
la manifestation se passe j'imagine pour
le mieux c'est toujours devant voilà ce
cortège syndical que des dégradations
ont lieu que des éléments radicaux se ce
rassemble et passe parfois à l'action on
pensait qu'aujourd'hui il restera calme
et bien finalement ils ont fini par agir
en cette fin de de manifestation qui
arrive là donc comme je le disais tout à
l'heure place de la Nation
17h09 nous sommes toujours en direct une
poussée de fièvre il y a un petit quart
d'heure de cela vous avez vu les forces
de l'ordre intervenir pour laisser
passer les pompiers qui sont venus
éteindre quelques feux allumés sur le
boulevard Voltaire nous suivons
évidemment ce qui se passe dans les rues
de la capitale et
facile
feu d'artifice d'exploser ce sont des
gestes d'artifice sur les territoires de
l'ordre des cours dangereux comment ça
va
très bien
adjointe au service économique du Figaro
je garde un œil sur ces images toujours
très impressionnante avec ses forces de
l'ordre obligé de de reculer encore une
journée à l'appel des syndicats est-ce
qu'ils ont encore la main les syndicats
lorsqu'on voit ce qui se passe
la main
oui dans le sens où il reste une île une
intercer syndicale tient bon il y a
toujours pas eu de scission ils sont
toujours
unis donc mais effectivement il y a ces
événements violents qui savait très bien
commencé le calme tout le monde louait
les services d'ordre etc et puis bah
forcément ça dégénère et c'est
d'ailleurs c'est ça le problème c'est la
responsabilité c'est c'est pas notre
montrer les gens à descendants dans la
rue quand les syndicats appellent la
population a manifesté à descendre dans
la rue il faut gérer après avec ce
risque que ça dégénère qui est des
violences
qu'on bloque le pays qu'on bloque la
liberté des autres la liberté de
travailler la liberté de enfin je pense
aussi à tous ces commerçants qui sont
sur le parcours des cortèges qui ont des
journées perdues les journées de
d'activités perdues
et c'est aussi ça le responsabilité des
syndicats quand ils appellent
il faut il faut durer canaliser et puis
bon là on voit bien que c'est ça devient
de plus en plus compliqué
justement il y a la question de
l'opinion publique qu'il ne faut pas
perdre c'était le trésor de guerre d'une
certaine manière de de l'Inter syndical
visiblement
l'opinion publique peut basculer en
voyant ces images et ça ça inquiète en
tout cas les syndicats je pense que oui
ça les inquiète ils savent que ils sont
plus forts en ayant l'opinion avec eux
et je pense que l'opinion elle ne peut
pas rester indifférente quand on a vu
les violences à sainte-solines sur les
méga bassines c'est un autre sujet mais
c'est concomitant c'est arrivé ce
week-end
et ce weekend
or tout le monde ne le dit pas oui le
manifester est un droit légitime mais
bloquer le pays
casser les vitrines casser brûler les
voitures enfin et ça non ça n'est pas
possible et il faut le dire faut le dire
fermement certains syndicats ne
condamnent pas si j'ai l'impression que
la plupart en tout cas
certains partis politiques temps à
expliquer donc excuser
on condamne pour l'instant la France la
plus dure de la CGT aussi a appelé par
moment même physiquement à mettre le feu
c'est ce que disait notamment Olivier
matheux le syndicalisme du sud de la
France des Bouches-du-Rhône de
représentant fédéral des
Bouches-du-Rhône à la CGT je vous
rappelle qu'il voulait mettre là que les
franges des syndicats voulaient mettre
la France à genou bloquer le pays enfin
s'il fait démonter c'est des mots très
durs quand vous les dites vous savez que
c'est répercuté il y a une forme de
responsabilité à avoir puisque vos mots
ils sont ils sont suivis ils sont
entendus par les militants donc
voilà je rappelle quand même que
aujourd'hui avec le télétravail beaucoup
de cadres ne sont pas gênés par le par
les manifestations je vous signale aussi
de la RATP fonctionne pas si mal que ça
perturbations
autour de moi qui ont pris le métro qui
m'ont dit oh mais sauf fonctionne très
bien ça parce que il y avait eu aussi
plein de négociations en amont propre à
la à la RATP avec Jean Castex des
augmentations de salaire donc finalement
le mouvement il est suivi un peu
mollement voyez à la RATP alors que
habituellement c'était le fer de lance
des luttes
la SNCF c'est pas non plus
complètement bloqué vous voyez et donc
en fait les gens qui sont gênés
aujourd'hui par ces manifestations et
ses grèves c'est quand même les gens qui
ne peuvent pas télétravailler c'est tous
ces gens cette fameuse première ligne
dont on a beaucoup parlé enfin
voilà donc le mouvement
c'est son but c'est de
c'est pratique
qui montre les manifestants arrivés sur
la place de la Nation ou s'achève ce
cortège il y a une petite musique moins
importante quand on voit les images 450
000 personnes à Paris c'est ça
les chiffres officiels du commissaire de
l'Intérieur tomberont un peu plus tard
dans dans la journée bon on a eu une
petite poussette fièvre en images en
tout cas lors du dernier quart d'heure
on surveille ça Marie Cécile on essaie
de rentrer un peu plus dans les
négociations
la technique alors cette journée à
l'appel des des syndicats on pensait que
cette interditaire syndical elle est
exposée un très souvent attention la CGT
elle veut faire différemment de la CFDT
allez tiens on y croit vraiment
ils savent que l'union fait la force
ils ont bien tenu alors maintenant vous
avez vu la nouveauté c'est que Laurent
Berger donc le numéro 1 de la CFDT a
proposé une voie de sortie par le biais
d'une médiation il a appelé à une
médiation pour trouver un compromis j'ai
envie de vous dire il nous refait un
petit peu le coup de 2019 Laurent Berger
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez mais
en 2019 là
il était du côté du gouvernement mais je
vous rappelle qu'on a eu un mois de
décembre de grève de grève dure et
c'était complètement bloqué et Laurent
Berger avait proposé de sortir la
question de l'âge c'est lui c'était
c'est lui qui avait fait cette
proposition alors à l'époque c'était pas
recul de l'âge de 62 à 64 ans c'était si
vous vous en souvenez un âge pivot le
gouvernement d'Édouard Philippe voulait
mettre instaurer un H pivot à 64 ans si
vous partiez avant vous aviez une décote
si vous partiez après vous aviez
éventuellement une surcote un système
plus souple mais il y avait déjà cette
question de l'âge or ça bloquait tout
bloquait autour déjà de cette question
de l'âge et donc Laurent Berger avait
dit tout le monde a dit très bonne idée
on sort la question qui qui énerve tout
le monde on la sort du projet de loi
comme ça le projet doit peut continuer à
l'Assemblée parce qu'il y avait des
mesures que effectivement la CFDT
défendait sur des points plus sociét sur
la retraite des divorcées
n'était pas au courant bien sûr
c'est quelque chose que la CFDT prône
depuis très longtemps depuis
françoischerel sur une réforme
systémique avec une vision sociétale
voyez il veut vraiment voir les règles
d'attribution des pensions de réversion
les pensions des divorcés etc
bon bref donc Laurent Berger elle est
dit mais sortons cette question de l'âge
qui crispe tout le monde de l'âge pivot
et on avait mis sur place je sais pas si
vous vous en souvenez une conférence de
financement c'est pas le problème c'est
que quand même une conférence de
financement ou si j'ai tous les
syndicats autour d'un haut fonctionnaire
qui sont elle s'appelle Jean-Jacques
Marette
c'est lui qui était le maître d'oeuvre
de la réforme 2019
très compétent très respecté de tout le
monde
[Musique]
si vous vouliez partir avant bah vous
partez avant vous aviez une décote
chacun fait ses choix et si vous vous ne
vouliez pas si vous vouliez avoir votre
pension à taux plein bah vous attendiez
64 ans et finalement il y avait il y
avait une il y avait une place pour le
choix les gens n'étaient pas prisonniers
c'est pas arbitraire il y a finalement
une place pour le choix et finalement
peut-être que cet âge pivot serait passé
plus facilement
[Musique]
le ministère de l'Intérieur 516.000
personnes manifestées dans l'Hexagone à
17h il y a titre de comparaison le 23
mars donc jeudi dernier 768000 le 7 mars
962000 donc nous assistons donc il y a
une journée de mobilisation
avec moins de manifestants ils auront
les chiffres définitifs un peu plus tard
dans dans la soirée
[Musique]
nous parler de cette réforme de 2019 qui
avait amené des gens dans la rue mais
qui étaient plus populaires
notamment parce qu'elle était plus
souple et parce qu'elle ramenait tout le
monde sur un même pied d'égalité en
enlevant ces régimes spéciaux pourquoi
Emmanuel Macron a-t-il donc pas reposer
cette peur alors cette réforme est il y
avait certains certaines aspects qui
étaient positifs on pense que cette idée
de l'âge pivot finalement était plus
facile à défendre mais il y avait aussi
beaucoup de complexité parce que quand
vous remettez le système à plat
complètement dans les retraites cette
série on l'a vu c'est terriblement
compliqué c'est un empilement de
décision de toucher un petit fil et tout
tout s'écroule on dit souvent que dans
le social le diable se niche dans les
détails mais c'est c'est archi vrai quoi
enfin ça se vérifie chaque jour qui
passe et donc la réforme a été trop
compliquée en plus l'idée c'était de
vraiment de mettre tout le monde sur un
pied d'égalité tous les régimes vous
savez bon au départ tout le monde a
applaudit mais bien sûr et l'égalité un
neurocotisé donne les mêmes droits pour
tous plus de transparence de simplicité
qui pouvait être contre tout le monde
était pour sauf qu'on s'est aperçu que
on voulait fusionner des régimes qui
sont très différents l'origine des
fonctionnaires le régime du privé et le
régime des indépendants des professions
libérales ils ne fonctionnent pas pareil
donc c'est difficile d'aligner les modes
de calcul des retraites vous voyez par
exemple des un indépendant une
profession libérale un médecin un
commerçant ils vont commencer par
s'endetter pour acheter leur fonds de
commerce pour acheter leur cabinet ils
font un prêt professionnel et et et ils
ont un actif un cabinet
une charge d'avocat enfin que sais-je un
commerce qui servira plus tard quand il
le revendront à financer leur retraite
donc on peut comprendre que leur mode de
calcul de la retraite ne soit pas le
même qui n'est pas éventuellement les
mêmes taux vous voyez puisque leur
fonction c'est très différent du
salariat et de même on s'est bien rendu
compte que c'était compliqué d'aligner
aussi les fonctionnaires sur les sur les
salariés puisque
notamment pour les enseignants les en
parce qu'on voit ces images en direct
avec cette force de l'ordre obligé de
reculer Damien canivelez est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer ce qu'il se passe
autour de vous si vous pouvez parler je
sais je vois les gaz lacrymogènes on
reprendra évidemment si vous avez du mal
à vous exprimer
écoutez pour le moment ça va je dois
vous avouer qu'effectivement j'ai des
glandes lacrymales qui commencent
légèrement à couler mais des
affrontements ont lieu la récemment
enfin il y a quelques secondes entre les
manifestants radicaux et la police qui
qui vient de charger qui vient de lancer
des des grenades lac des bombes
lacrymogènes enfin des grenades
lacrymogènes c'est assez étendu il y a
eu une pluie de pavés qui vient de
s'abattre sur les forces de l'ordre qui
se sont approchés de la rue Voltaire
direction le boulevard Voltaire et
c'était c'était assez compliqué pour
elle de se faire un chemin parce que il
y a énormément de monde ici sur ce
boulevard Voltaire beaucoup de
manifestants ultra violents de l'ultra
gauche alors il n'y a pas que des
manifestants qui sont issus de cette
mouvance de gauche il y a également des
des jeunes de banlieue qui ont rejoint
ce mouvement c'est ce qu'une
sympathisante de l'ultra de l'ultra
gauche que vous a déclaré tout à l'heure
parce qu'elle était en train de de jeter
également des pavés elle était très
heureuse justement de savoir que il y
avait une sorte de convergence des
luttes contre la police et
et elle a effectivement elle s'est
félicité que d'autres personnes et
rejoint ce mouvement contre Antipolis
voilà alors c'est vrai que c'est assez
étendu tout le monde a les yeux qui qui
ont tendance à couler les menus nuages
de lacrymogène vient de s'évaporer tout
doucement mais on imagine que les forces
de l'ordre devrait appliquer dans les
quelques instants parce que c'est un peu
le jeu du chat et de la souris ici c'est
à dire que les forces porte charge les
militants reculent et dès qu'il recule
les forces de l'ordre et bien c'est à
nouveau les forces de l'ordre c'est à
nouveau les les manifestants qui
cherchent en direction de de ces
policiers et et ces gendarmes on sait
pas trop dans quel sens ça va évoluer
cette situation parce que c'est
extrêmement tendu les éléments radicaux
vous savez qui était au nombre de
plusieurs centaines qui étaient
redoutées par les services territoires
par les renseignements territoriés par
les renseignements territoriaux pardon
et bien ils sont là ils sont très
présents ici sur cette fin de cortège
boulevard Voltaire et c'est assez
compliqué de vous parler pour être c'est
avec vous Tibo Gauthier en raison de ses
larmes qui coulent sur le visage
de filmer ce qu'il se passe toujours
avec Marie Cécile Renaud
un angle économique et quand je vois ces
images moi je pense aux chiffres qui
sont tombés aujourd'hui un chiffre de la
dette publique la dette publique alors
le gouvernement s'en organise le
gouvernement s'enorgueille qu'elle soit
à
116,6% du PIB en 2022 contre 112,9 donc
c'est mieux ça se réduit mais en valeur
absolue ça c'est les chiffres en
pourcentage mais si on regarde en valeur
absolue
c'est plus simple en euros
pourcentage du PIB c'est toujours très
compliqué mais en euros ça fait 2950
milliards d'euros de dettes la France à
2950 milliards d'euros donc
elle a augmenté exactement c'est ça donc
on communique sur les 30% tâches du PIB
et qui montre que ça ça baisse mais
c'est presque on frôle les 3000
milliards et par rapport à l'an dernier
ça fait quand même 126,4 milliards
d'euros de plus en 2021
on est dans un pays très endetté on a un
déficit public qui lui aussi c'est un
peu mieux mais ça reste à 4,7% du PIB
donc c'est c'est très important
l'objectif c'est d'arriver à 3% et donc
dans ce contexte
la réforme des retraites
elle est absolument nécessaire je
rappelle que la France va encore devoir
emprunter sur les marchés 270 milliards
d'euros cette année que
si on ne fait pas cette réforme ce sera
très mal perçu par nos partenaires
européens par les marchés financiers et
qu'on aura et que
on risque d'avoir des conditions de
d'emprunt supérieures des taux
supérieurs donc
voilà il faut savoir après ce que l'on
veut
une réforme des retraites celle de 2019
qui a été oubliée aucune possibilité de
revenir dessus est-ce que la CFDT par
exemple
pour elle a proposé
je pense que le gouvernement a pas
complètement évacué l'idée
alors bon là ça c'est
tendu
mais
dans leur tête je me souviens je
discutais avec Olivier dussof de
ministre du Travail il y a quelques
semaines
et il me parlait d'un codicile de mesure
qui viendrait peut-être après dans la
loi travail vous savez ils ont prévu en
mai une loi pleine emploi qui s'appelle
loi pleine emploi ou normalement il
devait y avoir après ces mesures un peu
salées de la réforme des retraite des
mesures sucrées et cette loi pleine
emploi devait être un peu une loi
fourre-tout il y aurait eu des choses
positives comme le partage de la valeur
vous savez pour permettre à tous les
Français enfin plus largement plus de
Français de bénéficier d’intéressement
de participation etc
et puis ils avaient aussi dans l'idée de
reprendre quelques points de la réforme
universelle concernant les retraites qui
étaient plus larges qui étaient pas
strictement financière donc il ne
n'hésitez pas à cette à ce plfs parce
qu'on est toujours dans le cas d'un
PLFSS où j'ai de petit enfant de la
sécurité sociale rectificative vous avez
prévu d'autres d'autres mesures
retraites dans cette loi travail je ne
sais pas si elles y sont toujours parce
que parce qu'une fois que l'idée c'est
surtout ne fermer la page de tourner la
page des retraites pas sûr qu'il leur
réouvre le sujet mais enfin voilà il
voulait faire des mesures justement plus
sociétales plus systémique peut-être à
l'époque il pensait revenir sur les
pensions de réversion sur le calcul des
pensions de la version qui est lui aussi
un sujet
très sensible
donc je ne sais pas si s'il le feront
voilà il voulait reprendre certains
points qui étaient dans la dans cette
réforme pour un système universel donc
c'est pas totalement sorti de leur tête
et il reste encore trois ans et demi
enfin
pour le quinquennat donc presque 4 donc
il y aura peut-être d'autres
occasions de revenir par des petits
points vous savez maintenant on
saucissonne les lois on fait des
activités
bavard des et longues
c'est à dire que des lois plus courtes
alors que moi c'est les images des
forces de l'ordre qui tentent de
disperser les manifestants violents oui
des lois plus courtes pour faire voter
une fois par le droit une fois par la
gauche mais avant qu'elle sera la
stratégie adoptée par le ballon sur les
différents plats de la loi immigration
et de la loi pleine emploi théoriquement
avec deux V qui devrait
au mois de mai Laurent Berger veut faire
une pause dans la réforme des retraites
dans cette réforme ça veut dire quoi une
pause
on a un peu du mal à comprendre une
pause ça veut dire reporter à plus tard
on va pas fermé
fermer le sujet pour le réouvrir en
septembre et on
se retrouvera mon cher Thibault pour de
nouvelles journées on
sera là à parler de la rentrée sociale
chaude comme on le fait
vous voyez
je pense que c'est très compliqué mais
je vous dis ça ça rappelle son idée de
2019 quand il avait c'était son idée à
lui c'était vraiment Laurent Berger de
faire cette conférence de financement
pour sortir les sujets qui gêne et
sortir du du débat et les traiter à côté
mais est-ce qu'il y a une peur de
l'essoufflement du côté des syndicats
que dans
deux une semaine deux semaines trois
semaines c'est manifestations et alors
qu'on le voit aujourd'hui les chiffres
sont en baisse c'est manifestation
rassemblent de moins en moins et que les
syndicats perdent toute la crédibilité
acquise depuis deux mois toute leur
puissance toute leur force parce que
crédibilité mais en tout cas il est
possible que le mouvement s'essouffle je
resterai prudente il faut être vraiment
humble parce que la météo sociale c'est
une science très très compliquée mais
enfin ce qu'on peut voir c'est que il y
a quand même les vacances de Pâques qui
vont les vacances scolaires de Pâques
qui vont arriver on a vu déjà en février
les vacances avaient marqué un peu un
ventre mou et et que le bon le dans
l'essoufflement du du mouvement donc là
il va y avoir les vacances de Pâques et
ensuite il va y avoir les ponts de mai
et donc bon ça va
peut-être mais je vous dis il faut
rester très très humble
qui avait beaucoup de
dans cette vidéo syndicats beaucoup de
travailleurs qui ont pris leur carte par
exemple ce sont ces lors de cette
période si tous ces gens qui sont pas
forcément issus du milieu syndical se
disent les syndicats ils peuvent nous
aider et qu'au final tout en bas l'eau
et cette réforme passe c'est que rien ne
tient bon les services
[Applaudissements]
que ce soit la CFE-CGC la CGT la CFDT
tous nous ont dit qu'ils avaient eu un
regain d'adhérents en janvier plus 50%
mais c'est valable pour tous les
syndicats c'est valable à chaque fois
qu'il y a un grand mouvement social
parce que forcément ils sont mis en
avant les gens veulent non c'est pas
nouveau à chaque grand mouvement social
il y a ce regain du bien parce que ça
fait des années qu'on dit que les
syndicats sont morts
enfin ils sont pas morts mais ils ont
des bases qui ça me nuisent donc à
chaque grand mouvement social c'est des
gens qui ne peuvent pas forcément parler
des manifester adhère en se disant c'est
de ma façon à moi de les soutenir après
les gens peuvent aussi espérer avoir des
accords en entreprise parce que je vous
rappelle que bon il y a les
confédérations au niveau national mais
finalement les entreprises les syndicats
ils sont aussi présents dans les
entreprises pour signer des accords avec
les directions et là chacun au cas par
cas peut se dire bah aucun moi dans mon
entreprise finalement ils peuvent ils
peuvent appuyer donc
je ne sais plus quel est votre question
peuvent se décourager d'avoir suivi des
syndicats et que cela ne cherche pas à
grand-chose
[Musique]
et que dans un mois et demi c'est
manifestation on aura semble plus que
100000 personnes 5 ans plus personne à
travers non les syndicats ont pu montrer
qu'ils pouvaient être unis qui pouvait
essayer de limiter enfin de
de
tenir enfin des cortèges où il y a pas
trop de violence
mais je pense que le mouvement peut
s'essouffler
la loi ben on attend la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel mais la loi une
fois qu'elle sera promulguée la CFDT
l'égalisme
en 49,3 démocratique on va continuer
d'en parler mais d'abord on retourne sur
le terrain parce que vous entendez aussi
l'arsenal
République vous avez raison de le dire
Damien Canivez vous êtes sur le terrain
avec autour de vous des affrontements et
ses forces de l'ordre c'est CRS ou ces
gendarmes qui se protègent derrière leur
bouclier parce que ils sont canardés de
projectiles de poubelles de pavés
il y a un peu de tout ça absolument Tibo
Gauthier il y a des projectiles des
poubelles des pavés même parfois on a vu
aussi un moment donné une trottinette
qui a essayé d'être projeté vers les
vers les forces de l'ordre sans succès
ils sont acculés la rue Bouvier qui
donne directement sur le boulevard
Voltaire où se trouve toute les
manifestants les plus les plus radicaux
on a le sentiment que ces forces de
l'ordre sont un petit peu en manque
d'inspiration actuellement dans la
mesure où il déboule sur le boulevard
Voltaire pour séparer en deux le cortège
de manifestants ultra gauche et
finalement après il repartent dans les
rues adjacentes pour se protéger
derrière leur bouclier et derrière et
bien ce sont les les manifestants
ultra qui qui prennent la main et qui
font des études parce que vous voyez par
exemple des assurances en l'occurrence
qui sont dégradés il y a eu également
une enseigne de de distribution aussi
tout à l'heure la devanture qui a été
pulvérisée des
des abributs évidemment j'en parle même
pas et là vous avez la charge des forces
de l'ordre vous voyez qu'ils sont
plusieurs dizaines à charger les
manifestants et là je peux vous assurer
que ça va mater parce que je peux vous
assurer que ça fait quelques minutes
maintenant qu'ils attendent dans cette
rue Bouvier et et et là c'est en train
de de charger avec des grenades de
désencerclement il lance aussi des des
bombes lacrymogènes pour disperser tous
ces manifestants peut-être vont-ils
réussir à à à apprendre le pas cette
fois-ci sur sur les manifestants mais
c'est assez compliqué à vrai dire parce
que ils sont assez cool ils sont assez
peu de voilà il y a une grenades une
grenade de défenseur Clément là qui qui
éclate juste à côté de nous parce que
ben écoutez nous sommes entre les
policiers et les manifestants il y a une
dame aussi là qui vient de se prendre
les pieds dans le tapis à la suite de la
charge avec avec les policiers c'est
c'est assez confus là effectivement
parce que
tout le monde et et et police justement
et en train de prendre vraiment le pas
sur ce boulevard Voltaire avec les
manifestants qui là pour le coup sont
obligés de reculer
Leclerc on continue de suivre ce qui se
passe et on revient régulièrement vers
vous vous appelez dès qu'il se passe
quelque chose
sur ce boulevard Voltaire à proximité de
la place de la Nation je suis toujours
avec Marie-Cécile Renaud service
économie du Figaro ça coûte combien ces
journées de mobilisation alors
ça coûte paradoxalement d'un point de
vue macroéconomique ça ne coûte pas
si cher que ça on a vu que ça coûtait 01
02 points de PIB parce qu'en fait il y a
un effet rattrapage qui n'a pas été fait
durant les journées de manifeste de
mobilisation de grève de ma
manifestation peut être rattrapé ensuite
et puis par exemple si vous prenez pas
le métro ou peut-être que vous prenez un
uber ou pas
donc l'Insee avait calculé que
finalement d'un point de vue macro le
coup n'est pas si important que ça après
pour les entreprises j'avais cherché les
chiffres en 2019 je crois que c'était
8 milliards d'euros pour
aller chaque jour de grève coûtait 20
millions d'euros à la SNCF 3 millions
pour la RATP 8 millions pour Air France
en 2019
tout est quand tout est bloqué bon mais
il y a aussi des répercussions sur les
secteurs qui ne sont pas en grève
eux-mêmes par exemple la restauration
l'hôtellerie si vous n'avez pas pu
prendre votre train bah forcément votre
chambre d'hôtel vous l'avez annulé etc
donc il y a quand même des secteurs qui
sont gênés et au-delà de cet effet
macroéconomique qui peut donc se
rattraper ce lycée ensuite dans le temps
il y a un effet d'image un effet d'image
à l'étranger
notamment l'annulation de la visite de
Charles III quand vous voyez les rues de
Paris
enfin
couverte de poubelle
avec des feux qui qui brûlent enfin vous
voyez est-ce que ça a un impact sur les
investisseurs étrangers est-ce que c'est
un impact sur les touristes il y a aussi
un impact d'image et d'attractivité et
je vous le rappelais la situation des
finances publiques françaises j'ai une
dernière question parce qu'après je vous
relâche
sans cette réforme confirmer nous serons
déficitaires en 2030 à hauteur de 10
milliards d'euros par an
il y a une caisse qui ne l'est pas du
tout j'ai bien compris celle du prix
complémentaires ce que c'est parce que
apparemment on pourrait piocher dans
cette caisse
il y a une tentation de piocher
moi qui ne suis pas un spécialiste c'est
très compliqué à comprendre
effectivement cette caisse elle est
bénéficiaire ils ont eu ils ont
enregistré un excédent l'an dernier de
2,6 milliards d'euros quand est-ce que
l'argent rentre c'est bon
regardez votre fiche de salaire donc il
y a des cotisations agirco
et donc bon comme l'an dernier il y a
une reprise de la croissance foscovide
des cotisations sont bien rentrées ils
ont fait une très bonne année ils ont
pris un excédent et ils doivent
d'ailleurs annoncer leurs résultats pour
2022 demain
priori je n'ai pas de secret mais a
priori à nouveau ça devrait être une
bonne année parce que les cotisations
sont rentrés
les salaires d'augmenter et ils ont une
règle d'or parce qu'en fait l'agirco
c'est géré par les partenaires sociaux
c'est géré partenaire sociaux c'est à
dire par les syndicats et par le
patronat c'est c'est une gestion
paritaire et d'ailleurs les syndicats
sont orgueil de cette caisse agircargo
qu'ils disent bien géré ils disent mais
vous voyez nous quand on est à la
manœuvre on fait mieux que l'État on
gère très bien que ce régime et donc a
été en a été en déficit mais ils ont
pris des mesures difficiles pour le
remettre en excédent et ces mesures
difficiles c'était notamment c'est ça le
comble les syndicats dont la CFDT a
signé pour que pour faire travailler les
gens un an de plus pour inciter à
travailler un an de plus à l'agirco
comment en appliquant une décote si vous
décidiez de partir plus tôt comme c'est
une une mesure qui a été appliquée à
partir du 1er janvier 2019 depuis le 1er
janvier 2019 quand vous êtes salarié du
privé si vous partez si vous voulez
avoir votre retraite à taux plein et
bien vous départir un an plus tard sinon
vous avez une des codes de 10% pendant 3
ans d'accord
[Musique]
gestionnaire ce sont
appliquer une règle d'or et ils disent
il faut qu'on ait 6 mois de réserve 6
mois de prestation c'est à dire et ce
petit matelas enfin ce matelas ce petit
matelas il fait 68 milliards d'euros
on regarde 2300 manière de droit
accumulés vous voyez les droits que
qu'il faudra honorer et donc c'est 68
milliards ça correspond à 6 mois de
versements
qui permettent d'assurer si il y a des
aléas économiques des aléas
démographiques et alors bien sûr comme
vous le dites ça fait envie ce McDo de
68 milliards donc la grande tentation
notamment de l'État ça serait de pouvoir
le mettre dans un pot commun de le
mélanger avec d'autres qui sont d'autres
régions
ne veulent pas on n'entend parler ah bah
certainement pas merci beaucoup de nous
avoir expliqué tout ça Marie-Cécile
Renaud je vous relâche et on retourne
sur le terrain Damien canivevez tension
aux abords de la place de la Nation
alors je vois beaucoup de mouvements de
foule j'ai l'impression que c'est quand
même moins violent pour l'instant mais
je ne suis qu'ici en plateau moi violent
que je dis dernier
alors oui très certainement moins
violent que jeudi dernier Thibaut
Gauthier parce que jeudi dernier on
avait vraiment le sentiment que c'était
le chaos en plein Paris là les violences
sont contenues au niveau du boulevard
Voltaire même si les forces de l'ordre
sont vraiment vraiment mises à
contribution aujourd'hui par tous les
manifestants qui se trouvent autour de
moi parce que je peux vous assurer que
il y a une pluie de pavés qui s'abat sur
sur ses forces de l'ordre qui cette
fois-ci ont réussi à prendre possession
du boulevard Voltaire et un assez les
manifestants à un endroit bien précis
donc le ils ont réussi à reprendre le
contrôle sur sur les éléments radicaux
en tout cas c'est la perspective que je
vous donne depuis l'endroit où je me
trouve parce qu'il y a peut-être encore
d'autres groupuscules d'extrême gauche
qui se trouve derrière moi voir
peut-être même devant moi mais en tout
cas voilà on est revenu un petit peu sur
le schéma du début de la manifestation
c'est à dire que le cortège aussi
violent soit-il se dirige vers la place
de la Nation avec les policiers qui sont
juste en face et qui l'encadrent de
façon à ce que la foule soit continue et
on sait que c'est vraiment ce que la
police c'est dans ces conditions que la
police arrive à travailler à travailler
le mieux mais là je peux vous assurer
que les éléments radicaux qui étaient
redoutés par la préfecture de police de
Paris et par le renseignement
territorial et bien ne se sont pas
trompés ils sont ici en nombre en cette
fin de manifestation et ça n'a ça ne
ressemble pas du tout à ce qu'on a pu
voir tout à l'heure vous avez vu cette
manifestation on voit une charge
d'ailleurs là-bas au loin une charge des
forces de l'ordre qui qui avance assez
vite et qui quelque part se font aussi
courser paradoxalement par certains
certains manifestants on voit des
départs de feu aussi là-bas au niveau de
la place de la Nation c'est assez
difficile de savoir ce qui se passe
parce qu'il y a tellement de de
groupuscules qui sont éparpillés sur
cette sur cette fin de boulevard
Voltaire que contrairement à ce qu'on a
l'habitude de voir avec un black bloc
c'est à dire une foule très compacte
d'homme ou de femmes d'ailleurs aussi
habillée en noir cette fois-ci c'est
c'est assez confus on a l'impression
qu'il y a des des groupes un petit peu
partout
on a compris la teneur de votre propos
attention merci de rendre compte avec
Julien Leclerc derrière la caméra de ce
qu'il se passe aux abords de la place de
la Nation Jacquot Olivier Martin bonjour
bonjour directeur du site Le Figaro
point fr qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
ces images
évidemment de la violence mais c'est
moins pire que prévu oui absolument
on sait pas ce qui va se passer dans les
heures qui viennent il fait encore jour
où on a eu un changement d'heure qui
peut avoir un impact la nuit n'est pas
encore là donc il y a quand même un peu
de radicalisation et un peu de violence
en tout cas beaucoup moins que ce qu'on
a pu voir ce week-end à Sainte-Souline
dans d'autres circonstances et la
semaine dernière lors de la
manifestation je trouve que c'est plutôt
rassurant c'est une chose qui est plutôt
positive parce que le spectacle de la
semaine dernière était extrêmement
choquant et inquiétant ça c'est le
peut-être le premier élément l'autre
enseignement en tout cas sur le front de
la rue c'est que la mobilisation est un
peu inférieure
on était à plus d'un million les
chiffres très clairement les chiffres à
17h les chutes du ministère de
l'Intérieur
516000 personnes dans l'Hexagone contre
le 28 mars 768000 et le 7 mars 1962000
donc oui on est clairement baisse à 17h
évidemment qu'il devrait y avoir une
tendance égale lorsque les chiffres
définitifs tomberont voilà donc c'est
quand même un élément dont il faut tenir
compte c'est à dire que on a le
sentiment il y a ces manifestations qui
a moins de mobilisation que la
mobilisation est en baisse il y a
d'autres éléments qui pourraient la
tester le taux de grévistes et ton être
recul notamment dans l'enseignement on a
eu alors faute de manifeste de grévistes
la reprise annoncée en tout cas en
milieu de journée de la collecte des
déchets à Paris suspendu à Paris
suspendu je pense qu'il y a peu de
chance qu'elle reprenne moi j'y crois
pas quand on a suspendu faute de
participants je pense qu'on va avoir du
mal à renoncer le mouvement bon c'est de
la alors moi je me déplace en transport
en commun et partir clairement en métro
ce matin j'ai pu prendre le métro il y a
pas trop de problèmes pas trop de
problèmes donc c'est la mobilisation
baisse c'est vraiment un enseignement
important le deuxième enseignement c'est
que et pourvu que ça dure il y a moins
de violence après ça peut faire
l'affaire de l'exécutif d'un point de
vue du gouvernement parce que finalement
c'est les deux points qu'on regarde
est-ce qu'il y a du monde dans la rue
est-ce que les gens sont bloqués premier
point ça c'est la question syndicale au
fond deuxième point est-ce qu'il y a des
violences est-ce que on est obligé
d'intervenir est-ce que l'image de Paris
et de la France est une nouvelle fois
dégradée aujourd'hui elle est pas
terrible ce qu'on voit là
mais on est on est dans quelque chose de
beaucoup moins radical que je dis
dernier absolument donc c’est donc la
mobilisation a tendance affaiblir
sa règle pas le problème politique pour
autant
la première ministre est en train de
consulter ce soir
il y a LeBron Pivet la présidente de
l'Assemblée et Gérard Larcher le
président du Sénat il y a des
discussions
mais ils cherchent une voie de sortie
ils ont pas trouvé une voie de sortie
cette crise qui devient une crise
vraiment
politique
majeur n'est pas réglé pour autant il
faut trouver une voie de sortie
lorsqu'il voit cette manifestation
aujourd'hui nous verrons pour la suite
ce qu'il peut souffler un peu
j'entends par là que il y a une décision
qui doit être rendue c'est celle du
Conseil constitutionnel que tout le
monde attend pour savoir si oui ou non
cette réforme des retraites est validée
constitutionnellement il faut attendre
jusque là est-ce que en voyant ça il
peut se dire c'est pas mal ça prend
moins le mouvement c'est souffle
tranquillement gentiment et je vais
laisser faire pendant quelques mois
jusqu'à ce que les syndicats soient
incapables de faire descendre les gens
dans la rue alors il espère probablement
et c'est plutôt ça va quelques parts
c'était soufflement qu'on constate
aujourd'hui va peut-être plutôt
peut-être assuré mais ça ne règle pas la
crise politique majeure et la colère des
français même si elle se manifeste pas
forcément aujourd'hui il faut trouver
une solution on est bloqué aujourd'hui
politiquement bloqué pourquoi comment
cette réforme des retraites va passer
Emmanuel Macron n'a pas besoin d'être
élu on est d'accord alors la seule ou
aujourd'hui le seul obstacle c'est
qu'elle soit retoquée en totalité par le
Conseil constitutionnel on a c'est d'ici
le 21 avril donc ça sera pas encore le
cas c'est très rare donc je pense que
pour l'instant pas de problème
en tout cas de problème majeurs après
quand on s'est mis à dos
majorité de Français qui ne veulent pas
de cette réforme que les syndicats sont
vendus que la majorité même toute
relative des
au sein de du mouvement Renaissance
finalement eux aussi se disent
répondant à la main tendue enfin la main
tendue à la à la proposition de la terre
syndicale de faire une pause et de
nommer une médiation sont plutôt
favorables alors que le gouvernement on
parlait des députés du MoDem notamment
oui des députés du MoDem mais il y en a
certains de renaissance qui se disent
aussi que c'est peut-être pas une
mauvaise chose on sent que politiquement
il est dans une situation il était
extrêmement affaibli le le chef de
l'État son gouvernement aussi mais il y
a une vraie colère contre Emmanuel
Macron
faut trouver tout à l'heure 28% de
popularité ce qui est très bas on peut
il se doit trouver
une solution s'il veut continuer à
reformer c'est son souhait la redit à la
Olivier Vérand l'a dit à la sortie du
Conseil des ministres de continuer à
réformer Elisabeth borne aussi qui est
probablement sursis
ces éléments-là sont importants c'est
pas parce que je pense que ça se calme
dans la rue que ça règle les problèmes
aujourd'hui politique
il y a plus de problèmes dans le pays
non exactement donc c'est c'est
véritablement je pense
ça peut peut-être l'aider à réfléchir
sereinement ça aurait été dramatique une
explosion comme la semaine dernière
voire pire que la semaine dernière
là c'est peut-être un petit peu plus de
calme je on n'est pas à l'abri que une
nouvelle manifestation
moindre dérapage la moindre phrase et
tout peut tout peut redémarrer la vraie
question aujourd'hui c'est de savoir
comment le chef de l'État peut trouver
une solution de sortie de cette crise
qui est majeure est-ce qu'on manifeste
aujourd'hui
contre la réforme des retraites plus
vraiment finalement c'est autre chose on
manifeste contre manuel Macron c'est
probablement ce qui est en train de se
produire
il y a toujours les syndicats sont là
contre la réforme des retraités pas et
particulièrement le passage de 62 à 64
ans mais effectivement il y a plusieurs
profils de manifestants il y a une série
de jeunes alors je dis pas que les
jeunes se préoccupent pas la retraite
mais la forte mobilisation des jeunes
moins concernée en tout cas concerné
probablement que c'est une mobilisation
sous une forme de colère c'est aussi
l'expression des colères il y a
plusieurs j'ai envie de dire que
aujourd'hui
il y a plusieurs expressions dans ces
cortèges
contre les retraites mais aussi contre
la politique du gouvernement une forme
de colère qu'il faut réussir à terre et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement
n'a pas trouvé la solution celle qui
consiste à dire ce qu'il y en a une de
ces solutions parce que politiquement
cela semble impossible
il ne peut pas dissoudre l'Assemblée
nationale est-ce que vous me confirmez
vous risque de perdre un peu après on
sait pas ce qui peut se produire si le
pays devient totalement incouvernable il
peut décider de faire une dissolution
alors oui ça lui se fera probablement
pas favorable mais ça c'est c'est à la
c'est entre les mains du chef de l'État
j'ai pas l'impression que ce soit le cas
aujourd'hui
ils perdrait sans doute sur cette
question donc il n'a pas l'intérêt à le
faire ouais alors ça mettra du temps il
y a quand même une colère là il y a les
semaines il faut régler la situation ou
en tout cas améliorer la situation dans
le mois qui vient
peut-être un changement de gouvernement
[Musique]
améliorer
ou de redonner un petit peu de
possibilités de gouverner et de réformer
parce que le drame c'est que on est loin
notamment là dans les lois qui doivent
arriver à l'Assemblée nationale la loi
immigration loi pleine emploi comment
faire alors il y a une technique
Emmanuel Macron l'a évoqué lors de son
interview faire des lois plus courtes on
fait voter un peu à gauche et puis un
peu à droite parce que ça c'est jouable
on verra pour moi c'est pour moi c'est
c'est un peu de la cuisine
sans souci les Français sont plus dupes
qui connaissent maintenant et puis je
pense qu'il faut
on ne peut pas une loi c'est une loi
elle a un sens réel et une dimension
politique on peut pas s'amuser à faire
du découpage non c'est pas comme ça que
ça marchera moi je suis surpris je vais
en parler là de la
en tout cas les prises de position
la désordonnée du gouvernement sur toute
cette réforme jusqu'au bout y compris
encore le week-end dernier quand
Elisabeth borne dit je n'utiliserait
plus le 49 oui alors ça très étonnant
alors c'est peut-être elle veut apaiser
les choses
l'affaiblit sa prise de position la
semaine d'avant et puis elle se prive
d'un outil qui est constitutionnel qui
est qu'on a le droit d'utiliser pour je
ne saisis pas cette stratégie je pense
qu'elle quelque part ça conduit à un
affaiblissement et en aucun cas une
solution la réalité politique elle est
là il y a un gouvernement qui ne
s'appuie pas sur une une majorité
absolue mais une majorité relative à
partir de ce moment-là il faut
effectivement tenter d'aller chercher
plus large possible
des parlementaires pour pouvoir faire
adopter des lois et puis s'appuyer sur
tous les outils mis à la disposition le
49-3 en état c'est pas une honte et je
trouve que c'est pas forcément
politiquement très astucieux cette prise
de parole du week-end vous n'avez
visiblement pas aimé la communication du
gouvernement depuis de mois
caché favorable à cette
réforme des retraites même si même on la
trouve même un peu timide il faut il y a
une raison de la faire c'est très forme
après
je suis extrêmement surpris de voir à
quel point le gouvernement s'est pris
les les pieds dans le tapis à provoqué
une crise politique c'était pas simple
de mener cette réforme mais là on est
dans un spectacle quand même qui est
dramatique
en matière de colère des Français et de
blocages politiques merci beaucoup
jacolivier Martin je vous laisse
remonter dans les étages du Figaro pour
diriger le Figaro.fr on peut suivre sur
le live tech notamment toutes les
dernières informations et dans le live
texte vous pouvez apprendre par exemple
qu'il y a eu 22 interpellations depuis
le début de la journée à Paris
d'ailleurs on va retrouver Damien
Canivez qui est sur place il y a eu un
pic là de violence dans la dernière
heure ça a pas de duré très très
longtemps est-ce que ça s'est calmé là
dans les dernières minutes Damien
oui ça s'est calmé très certainement
parce que la stratégie des gendarmes et
des policiers présents sur ce boulevard
Voltaire a été payante on les a vu
effectivement chargé encerclé cette fin
de boulevard Voltaire nous sommes
vraiment il faut le savoir en quelques
mètres de la place de la Nation les
manifestants formés un groupe très
compact je ne parlerai pas de Black Bloc
cette fois-ci Thibaut Gauthier parce que
le black bloc vous savez c'est c'est
vraiment quelque chose de très
particulier c'est c'est une méthode
d'action avec des personnes constituées
constituées enfin tu donnes noires avec
des cagoules avec voilà des codes bien
particuliers là on est vraiment dans
autre chose on a des personnes vraiment
qui balançaient des pavés à visage
découvert donc on est vraiment dans du
casseur primaire si j'ose dire de façon
assez triviale et et c'était très
compliqué pour les forces de l'ordre
parce que ils avaient affaire à vraiment
des des éléments qui étaient capables de
lancer des des bouteilles vides des
pavés parfois même des trottinettes on a
vu voler on a vu même des poubelles
aussi qui était dirigées vers vers les
forces de l'ordre c'était assez
compliqué pour elle mais elles ont fini
elles sont quand même parvenues
encercler cette cette place de la Nation
et là c'est l'international vous savez
ce champ révolutionnaire là qui est
applaudit c'est pour ça que vous vous
entendez les manifestants qui qui
applaudissent autour de moi et c'est
force de l'ordre sont réussis à
encercler ce boulevard Voltaire à ce
disperser de façon à ce que ce cortège
qui était très compact puisse scinder en
deux voir trois parties et ensuite à
base de charge ils ont réussi en fait à
disperser à disperser voilà les les
éléments qui étaient en train de de
mettre le trouble dans dans la
manifestation pour l'instant le on ne
voit pas forcément les les autres
syndicats qui arrivent sur cette
manifestation peut-être que Vincent
roseron se trouve à leur côté nous on
est vraiment avec finalement voilà
toujours c'est c'est manifestants qui
cherchent à en découdre avec les les
forces de l'ordre le calme est revenu
ici mais je peux vous assurer qu'il le
tient que sur un fil
il est 18h point de vue spécial ce soir
évidemment vous avez suivi tout
l'après-midi les manifestations autour
de la réforme des retraites nous sommes
donc au coeur de cette actualité ce soir
dans le point de vue on aura très aucune
des dernières images notamment celle des
affrontements même s'ils ont été plus
minimes entre casseurs et forces de
l'ordre dans les rues de la capitale
trois invités ce soir dans un instant
nous accueillerons carré Lyon sociologue
spécialiste des syndicats Grégory Joron
syndicalise policier sera ici mais
d'abord parce qu'elle Perrino est avec
nous bonjour parce qu'elle bonjour
politologue professeur à assurance Pau
Paris alors on pensait que le mouvement
avait basculé jeudi dernier avec ses
violences qui n'avaient pas eu lieu lors
des dernières manifestations est-ce que
finalement non c'était un
épiphénomène et ça ne se poursuivra pas
ces violences bon à tantôt de voir
comment cette manifestation va se
terminer puisqu'on sait souvent qu'il y
a des affrontements en fin de
manifestation et que ça peut tourner
vinaigre mais jusqu'à maintenant
quels sont les constats qu'on peut faire
d'abord une manifestation qui rassemble
moins à Paris mais aussi dans d'autres
villes je regardais à Lyon et à Bordeaux
qui rassemble moins de manifestants que
la dernière fois environ 20 et parfois
même 25% de baisse des effectifs donc la
mobilisation elle est toujours là mais
elle semble quelque peu s'essouffler
deuxième élément apparemment après avoir
atteint un point d'acné en termes
d'utilisation de la violence lors des
dernières manifestations et bien sûr sur
un enjeu différent dans les
manifestations qui ont posé les forces
de l'ordre et les manifestants dans les
Deux-Sèvres on a l'impression d'un léger
d'une légère décrue de la violence c'est
peut-être dû aussi au nombre des
policiers et aux changements que le
préfet de police Laurent nunies
annonçait en matière de maniement des
forces de l'ordre on voit en particulier
que la segmentation des têtes de
manifestation ou en effet on sait qu'il
y a les individus les plus les plus
violent les plus redoutables et bien les
policiers ont réussi cette fois-ci à
segmenter à éviter l'effet de masse au
début de la manifestation à 14h ils
étaient très présents ils ont ouvert le
cortège voilà un qui peut nourrir en
effet la violence parce que vous savez
dans la violence il y a toujours un
effet d'imitation des gens qui sont
passés peu violents au départ peuvent
par imitation devenir extrêmement
violent pour manifester à la base
tranquillement auprès des autres
syndicats et puis un ou deux casseurs
les gaz lacrymogènes le feu la chaleur
et on le voyait très bien dans les
manifestations des gilets jaunes et puis
troisième élément de diagnostic tout de
même la grève ça n'est pas une franche
réussite donc on pourrait avoir
l'impression qu'il y a les premiers
signes d'une décrue et vous savez que
pour l'instant au fond le gouvernement
le président de la République joue
plutôt une stratégie d'usure à long
terme oui que certains appellent une
stratégie du pourrissement pourquoi
parce que ça correspond toujours à ce
qui s'est passé en termes de réforme des
retraites toutes réforme des depuis 25
ans est impopulaire elle suscite une
mobilisation
toujours et on pourrait expliquer
pourquoi elle suscite une mobilisation
une mobilisation importante qui a le
soutien de l'opinion et puis après ça se
tient et là au fond le cas un peu
nouveau cette fois-ci c'est que ça met
du temps assez violet mais apparemment
il y a les les premiers signes d'usure
il faut dire aussi que la stratégie
adoptée par le front syndical qui est
une stratégie de manifestation
rapprochée voilà au bout d'un moment les
ardeurs même les plus manifestantes ces
rod peu à peu oui ça coûte cher
notamment en période d'inflation est-ce
qu'on parle aujourd'hui dans la rue
encore de la réforme des retraites non
parce que c'est plus vraiment
j'espère que dans parmi les CGTistes les
cfditistes
l'une ça etc la mobilisation voilà reste
une mobilisation avant tout contre la
réforme des retraites et la faible place
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire qui a
été accordé aux forces syndicales dans
la mise en oeuvre de cette réforme mais
on voit bien qu'il y a toute une série
en particulier de jeunes manifestants
qui s'agrègent qui ça n'est pas la
clientèle habituelle des réformes contre
la retraite où il y a des actifs des
salariés qui sont prêts
occupés par l'avenir de leur retraite ou
l'avenir des retraites de leurs enfants
là il s'agit d'autres choses et au fond
si on avait à déceler un point de
cristallisation de toutes ces
revendications inquiétudes colères
frustrations différentes il y aurait
peut-être l'antimachronisme alors
justement Emmanuel Macron est clairement
visé oui on voit bien les gens
manifestent Macron oui
le président de la République a pour de
bonnes et de mauvaises raisons un peu
focalisé toute une série de d'opposition
très diverses des oppositions à son
style des oppositions à sa politique des
oppositions à la méthode qu'il a utilisé
pour réformer des oppositions à son
passé des oppositions à ceux qui
savaient appris dans la République par
définition il est en haut de la pyramide
dans le dispositif de la 5e République
et il focalise parfois rarement tous les
attraits toutes les qualités du monde et
parfois il focalise tous les rejets
j'allais dire du monde on est plutôt
dans la phase d'un homme qui
focaliserait tous les rejets du monde
alors justement pourquoi la magie
n'opère plus autour de lui tout a marché
au début il réussissait tout ce qu'il
voulait il y a plusieurs choses il y a
d'abord l'usure du pouvoir tout le monde
est atteint de l'usure de pouvoir même
bien sûr même quand on est un jeune un
jeune président même le général de
Gaulle avait connu
du pouvoir deuxième point il était
porteur d'un schéma alternatif faut pas
oublier Macron quand il arrive il dit
voilà il y a un vieux monde on va
dégager le vieux monde et je vais
inventer un nouveau monde il a beaucoup
contribué à dégager le vieux monde il
envoie les effets pervers dégager je me
souviens de ce mot ouais et le Nouveau
Monde n'est pas venu et il y a là si
vous voulez un espèce de trou d'air
maintenant nous avons une société
française et c'est assez périlleux ou
entre le Président de la République et
des citoyens français complètement
atomisés et plutôt en colère il n'y a
plus aucun corps intermédiaire il n'y a
plus aucun amortisseur alors c'est lui
qui voulait le sang séparer il voulait
parler directement avec quand on sait
genre quand on sépare de corps
intermédiaires il faut mettre d'autres
corps intermédiaires d'autres
amortisseurs en oeuvre c'est ça un des
principaux échecs du président Macron il
y a un choix qui est fait depuis
quelques jours du côté de l'exécutif
c'est d'incarner l'ordre on ne cherche
plus depuis longtemps à convaincre les
manifestants on essaie de convaincre
ceux qui sont d'accord avec le
gouvernement on dit regardez
vous embête pour pas dire plus vous
pouvez pas
vous balader dans les rues de Paris sans
voir les poubelles vous pouvez pas aller
chez votre commerçant l'après-midi de
manifestation on veut parler à ces
gens-là et on veut incarner l'ordre bien
sûr parce qu'il y a un combat d'opinion
on sait très bien que nous traversons
une grave crise sociale une grave crise
politique qui va falloir en sortir et
éventuellement pour en sortir il pourra
y avoir à terme des élections ou des
consultations du peuple il s'agit
d'avoir si vous voulez un rapport de
force qui est favorable donc il y a une
querelle devant l'opinion et c'est vrai
que les Français quel que soit leur
mauvaise humeur ils aiment pas le
désordre
voilà il n'aime pas ça et donc on le
sent bien d'ailleurs dans les réactions
en particulier des leaders du
syndicalisme réformiste non paquet de
leur berger Laurent Berger s'aperçoit il
commence à s'apercevoir en effet que si
la violence est maintenant de manière
coutumière associée à toutes les
manifestations syndicales et bien ce
sont les syndicats qui paieront les pots
cassés et non pas les quelques jeunes
trublions ou jeunes voyous qui jettent
des des pavés sur les forces de l'ordre
donc
on voit bien que cette question de la
violence cette question de l'ordre
républicain c'est pas l'ordre pour
l'ordre c'est l'ordre républicain qu'une
société ne peut vivre dans le désordre
quotidien ou les gens peuvent plus aller
leur travail ils peuvent plus se rendre
à leur loisirs le soir ils ne savent pas
quoi faire de leurs enfants qu'ils
amènent à l'école si vous voulez ça ne
peut pas durer très longtemps et donc on
commence peut-être à voir les les effets
pervers de cette stratégie de
l'attention et le mouvement syndical va
être obligé de se poser maintenant les
moyens d'action est-ce qu'il continue
comme il le fait depuis plusieurs
semaines avec grève et manifestations ou
est-ce qu'il utilise d'autres types de
stratégies et le fait que Laurent
bergerisme on a besoin de médiateur vous
voyez ça veut dire quelque chose c'est
d'autres stratégies peut-être revenir à
la table de négociations
ils ont quoi à se dire aujourd'hui
Emmanuel Macron ou ses représentants ou
les membres du gouvernement et les
syndicats des syndicats veulent le
retrait de la réforme mais en tout cas
le retrait de cette mesure de l'âge
c'est pas du tout alors question pour le
gouvernement non non le gouvernement
pour l'instant reste droit dans ses
bottes il dit voilà le texte est adopté
l'état adopté n'est pas question de
revenir là-dessus on verra cependant
avec la décision du Conseil
constitutionnel s'il y a une marge de
négociation qui se réouvre telle ou
telle dispositif de la loi étant
invalidée deuxième deuxième élément on
peut imaginer qu'après un délai
raisonnable les forces syndicales
reviennent autour de la table pour
discuter en particulier de l'avenir et
des évolutions qui touchent le travail
on le voit bien alors ça ça devait être
l'objet d'une loi plutôt au mois de mai
on voit pleine emploi mais est-ce que et
syndicats pourront se laisser pardon je
mets des guillemets berner en disant
ouais bon finalement regardez cet âge de
départ se terminant n'en parle plus on
vous propose ça et écoutez c'était prévu
à l'agenda en effet il y aura de la
frustration syndicale etc mais aucun
syndicaliste ne peut être indifférent à
une réflexion qu'on lui propose et à des
mesures qu'on lui propose sur le terrain
de l'organisation du travail sachant
qu'en plus de ça si vous voulez c'est le
rapport même au travail des Français qui
a changé avec le travail à distance et
la covid on le sent tous on est tous
responsable dans des organisations des
entreprises on sent bien que le rapport
des travail au travail des Français a
changé et c'est peut-être un des
éléments du mouvement d'opposition
du passage de 62 à 64 ans c'est un des
éléments certainement qui est là et donc
il faut aborder calmement cette affaire
pour l'instant on est encore trop dans
le fracas et les mois des manifestations
et des violences mais je suis sûr que
dans quelques semaines on aura tout
intérêt toutes les forces vives comme on
dit de la nation à discuter sérieusement
de ce problème qui est un problème qui
nous touche plus personnellement je
reviens à ces manifestations qui
semblaient devenir un peu plus violente
avec Emmanuel Macron qui a clairement
dit qu'il était du côté de l'ordre on
l'a vu aussi avec Olivier Véran pas plus
tard que tout à l'heure à la sortie du
Conseil des ministres un temps assez
martial
comparaison chez une comparaison
peut-être risqué est-ce que c'est
l'exemple de 1968 lorsque De Gaulle
avait laissé faire les choses et puis au
mois de juin a fait la mise lors des
élections législatives est-ce que ça
peut être l'idée d'Emmanuel Macron la
société française a beaucoup changé en
effet la réaction à un mois après Mai 68
dans les législatives avaient été au
fond celle d'une France profonde qui
disait non aux minorités actives dans la
rue en disant c'est 16 désordre il faut
en sortir bon là on s'aperçoit que le
rapport de force en termes d'opinion une
majorité encore de français soutiennent
le mouvement donc le président doit être
assez large assez large même si elle
commence à baisser là aussi un autre
signal d'une éventuelle d'une éventuelle
érosion mais nous sommes loin d'une
capacité du président a organisé
j'allais dire de manière détendue des
législatives anticipées regardons par
exemple même si ça n'est pas grand chose
mais ce qui s'est passé dans l'Ariège la
législative partielle oui il s'agit d'un
véritable effondrement de la majorité
dans cette dans cette circonscription et
donc cela veut dire quelque chose il y a
deux candidates de gauche une gauche
réformiste de gouvernement et la gauche
et les filles et on voit bien que voilà
soutenu par la nupaisse et une autre
soutenue par les anciens ténors du Parti
socialiste et là on verra qu'est-ce
qu'il l'emporte de la culture de la
contestation radicale dans et les filles
et la nupesse sont de plus en plus
porteurs et au fond de la culture de
gouvernement dont cette élue socialiste
soutenue par la présidente de la région
Occitanie madame Carole dégât et
porteuse il y a bien là deux types de
culture dont on voit qu'elles sont en
train de s'affronter en ce moment aussi
bien au sein de la gauche de manière
vive que de la droite parce qu'à la
droite c'est la même chose il y a une
droite de gouvernement d'ailleurs Macron
et Madame borne font des appels à cette
droite de gouvernement je crois qu'en ce
moment le président du Sénat Gérard
Larcher est reçu par Madame
Elisabeth borne
tout à l'heure donc voilà il y a une
droite de gouvernement est-ce que cette
droite de gouvernement elle se centriste
de gouvernement
aideront ou non les majorites la
majorité à gouverner et puis on en a une
autre droite qui est le rassemblement
national qui lui n'est pas du tout dans
le souci ou la volonté créer des
coalitions pour gouverner petit
justement
18h14 là où on se parle et ce qui est
manuel Macron c'est rien ne bouge peu
gouverner il a une opinion favorable
très faible 28% oui 28%, c'est c'est le
niveau qui l'avait au moment de la crise
des gilets jaunes et peu à peu il avait
reconstruit sa popularité il avait eu
cette idée du grand débat national et de
la sortie de crise qui peu à peu lui
avait permis de sortir de cette zone en
effet extrêmement faible de 28%
d'opinions favorables mais une des
forces de Macron j'allais dire encore
dans ce spectacle un peu désolant et
désolé c'est que en face de lui il n'y a
pas d'alternatif clair vous savez oui
c'est ça s'il y avait des législatives
anticipées après une décision je crois
personnellement que
le résultat qui en serait issu ça serait
pire que la dernière fois il y aurait
encore moins de majorités
donc même s'il y avait le rassemblement
national en tête mais avec qui le
rassemblement national gouverneur est
donc si vous voulez les Français se
rendent bien compte même lorsqu'ils sont
opposés au président actuel et à sa
majorité que pour l'instant il n'y a pas
de majorité
alternative mais le président peut
gouverner vous savez parce que la
Constitution de la Cinquième République
ça a été créé pour ça tous ces articles
dont les Français
à mon avis c'est une bêtise
parce que si ça a été créé par le
général de Gaulle et Michel Debré c'est
que ça avait un sens c'était pour
permettre à la République dans des
situations de crise de pouvoir continuer
à gérer les affaires du pays donc il y a
là certainement
il faut jamais se laisser culpabiliser
comme ça quand on est premier ministre
faut assumer j'ai une dernière question
parce qu'elle Perrineau certains
appellent un retour de la politique
est-ce qu'il faudrait faire de la
politique est-ce qu'on sait en faire
dans ce gouvernement je pense à
Elisabeth borne qui est très techno dans
laquelle je suis comme ça veut dire quoi
refaire de la politique faire de la
politique c'est ce que ça changerait les
choses faire de la politique savoir deux
choses le sens de l'intérêt général et
avoir comme méthode le compromis le
compromis c'est-à-dire discuter avec les
autres qui sont toujours éventuellement
des adversaires mais jamais des ennemis
c'est ça
comme on dit c'est peut-être populiste
et on l'a vu
à l'émission en septembre 2022
la réforme des retraites était soutenue
par une majorité de Français et en fait
c'est une communication déplorable une
explication de cette réforme
contradictoire confuse qui a amené cette
position qui était favorable en
septembre à la réforme à la situation
actuelle où vous avez 70 % de Français
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui savent faire de
la politique peut-être retourner
l'opinion mais le sens du compromis ça
ne l'a pas non oui ça il n'a pas il a un
certain sens de l'intérêt général sur
lequel on peut s'interroger en tout cas
le compromis c'est véritablement une
planète sur laquelle il n'a jamais
débarqué merci beaucoup Pascal Perino
politologue et professeur Sciences Po
Paris merci d'être venu d'un point de
vue retourne sur le terrain dans une
manifestation qui a semble-t-il retrouvé
son calme Vincent roseron on en est où
on arrive place de la Nation enfin
alors non Thibault moi je ne suis
toujours pas sur la place de la Nation
je suis toujours sur le boulevard
Voltaire boulevard Voltaire on a passé
la place Voltaire d'ailleurs justement
je suis plutôt vers la fin du cortège et
les manifestants arrivent petit à petit
dans le calme toujours de ce côté à la
manifestation on voit sur les différents
édifices des des tags on voit des des
abribus qui ont détaillés effectivement
mais pour l'instant rien enfin voilà on
a dans cette partie du cortège tout
était très calme en tout cas sur
l'arrière de ce cortège ou tous les
manifestants ont manifesté dans le calme
ok d'accord merci beaucoup Vincent
roserand nous sommes toujours en direct
en un point de vue spécial consacré à la
réforme des retraites il est 18h18
bonjour Karen bonjour sociologue
spécialiste du syndicalisme merci d'être
ici alors certains syndicats appellent à
faire une pause dans la réforme des
retraites c'est une bonne idée en tout
cas c'est une prise de position qui au
départ avait été initiée par le grand
berger qui a été relayé par
l'intersyndical puisque Philippe
Martinez a on a aussi parlé tout à
l'heure et il me semble que c'est une
manifestation supplémentaire du grand
sens de la responsabilité des
organisations syndicales en tout cas
c'est elles ont essayé à plusieurs
reprises de de proposer des sorties de
crise au pouvoir en dépit d'une
manifeste d'une opposition très massive
qui s'est encore exprimée aujourd'hui
qui s'exprime dans l'opinion qui
s'exprime sur tout un tas de de
mobilisation donc l'idée de proposer de
suspendre la réforme de d'entamer un
processus de médiation c'était une
proposition qui permettait de recréer un
espace de dialogue possible sans pour
autant contraindre le président de la
République à ce à se dédier donc on peut
supposer que c'était une main tendue
parce qu'il y a je sais pas des prémices
de négociation possible alors qu'il y a
une semaine c'était encore impossible je
pense que la négociation sur la question
de de l'allongement de l'âge de départ
en retraite reste impossible oui ça oui
ça c'est très net c'est ce qui c'est le
ciment de l'Inter syndical c'est le
ciment c'est unité syndicale qui permet
à la mobilisation de se maintenir à un
tel niveau de de participation
du gouvernement cette réforme qui ne
lâchera pas oui c'est le ciment du
gouvernement effectivement c'est le
ciment en tout cas d'un pouvoir exécutif
mais qui peut paraître de plus en plus
isolé une des conséquences par exemple
de la demande de la proposition de
suspendre la loi ça a été par exemple
j'ai entendu ça tout à l'heure que le
groupe modem le groupe parlementaire du
MoDem c'était montré favorable donc ça
voilà d'un certain point de vue ça ça
renforce un peu plus les divisions dans
le camp du pouvoir exécuter ce qui me
propose pas ces syndicats des
négociations justement parce qu'ils ont
peur de de l'essoufflement on voit
aujourd'hui des chiffres en baisse et
puis c'est dur de faire grève dans deux
mois dans les même dans trois semaines
date à laquelle le Conseil
constitutionnel doit rendre une décision
à propos de cette réforme des retraites
il y aura peut-être plus grand monde
dans la rue là aussi les syndicats sont
obligés de revenir à la table de
négociations pour peut-être sauver les
meubles oui je pense pas qu'ils ont soit
à ce point c'est sans doute ça peut se
poser à un moment pour les organisations
syndicales évidemment ce qu'on
constatait aujourd'hui dans la
manifestation c'est en particulier une
participation extrêmement forte de la
jeunesse et ça c'est c'est un fait
nouveau c'est un fait important
politiquement qu'on avait déjà constaté
la semaine dernière la mobilisation de
jeudi dernier il est possible que un
printemps de la jeunesse
à l'hiver de mobilisation syndicale et
je pense que d'une certaine manière
c'est peut-être aussi là dessus que que
les que l'Inter syndicale peu tabler en
fait on l'avait vu par exemple lors de
précédentes mobilisation quand on
regarde la dynamique de la mobilisation
contre la loi travail en 2016 on voit
différentes phases de mobilisation qui
se succèdent en fait on a eu une
mobilisation étudiante alors là qui pour
le coup avait été plutôt une
mobilisation qui avait impulsé la
protestation sociale qui avait ensuite
été relayée par la mobilisation
syndicale et qui ensuite avait été
relayée par le phénomène de nuit debout
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui on est en train
d'assister à quelque chose qui soit de
de cet ordre en fait
c'est une histoire de l'utilisation du
49-3 que les choses ont changé pourquoi
cet article a fait descendre la jeunesse
dans la rue bah je pense comme la
perception l'interprétation d'un d'un
coup de force de plus de la part du de
la part du du pouvoir exécutif qui
avait décidé de d'engager une procédure
accélérée après pour la discussion de ce
projet de loi en utilisant un véhicule
législatif qui était pas évident pour
une réforme de cette ampleur un projet
de loi rectif et une loi de financement
la sécurité sociale ensuite de mettre en
place le vote bloqué au Sénat vous
rajoutez le 49-3 là dessus de la part
d'une la jeunesse en fait elle a cette
caractéristique assez qui peut paraître
contradictoire qui est de pas forcément
être la plus participative aux élections
politiques enfin
pour autant elle est très investie très
soucieuse de son avenir très investi sur
les questions par exemple le climatique
très présente dans les dans les
mobilisations sociales et donc il y a
une vision de la démocratie qui passe
peut-être parfois davantage par la
participation directe en fait par la par
la mobilisation par les engagements
associatifs etc que par le vote et donc
de ce point de vue là l'idée que la
procédure parlementaire qui était pas
forcément ce qui préoccupait le plus la
jeunesse auparavant y compris des rails
de ce point de vue là ça a pu être ça a
pu être perçu comme une provocation si
ce n'est pas un problème que la jeunesse
ne voit plus le vote comme
l'apanage démocratique
je pense pas que la jeunesse déjà je
pense pas qu'on puisse parler de la
jeunesse de manière de manière uniforme
en fait il y a des jeunes qui sont très
très diverses mais voilà elle est assez
partagée sur le vote à la présidence
beaucoup votent Emmanuel Macron beaucoup
votre Marine Le Pen et beaucoup votent
évidemment Jean-Luc Mélenchon
parce que je reviens à ma première
question
cette jeunesse là est-ce qu'elle
elle n'a pas un souci avec d'une
certaine manière le vote la démocratie
telle qu'elle est actuellement utilisée
en France je n'en ai pas l'impression
j'en ai pas l'impression il y a en fait
une une collègue de Pascal pereno qui
était là juste avant qui s'appelle
anuxelle avait parlé du moratoire
politique de la jeunesse en fait les
années de jeunesse sont des sont des
années d'apprentissage civiques et cet
apprentissage civique qui passe il peut
passer par le vote mais il passe aussi
par la participation collective à des
actions citoyennes à du volontariat des
manifestations voilà diverses formes
d'action et en réalité plus qu'une
opposition entre ces diverses formes de
participation politique ce que ce qu'on
bien montré justement les travaux de
politique c'est qu'il y a une espèce de
continuum en fait de participation et
que les les jeunes qui qui se mobilisent
dans les manifestations peuvent aussi
ensuite se retrouver dans les urnes
est-ce que les jeunes qui se mobilisent
dans les manifestations
ont plus d'appétence à la pour la
violence que les manifestants qui
étaient présents avancent là avant la
semaine dernière dans la rue
en tout cas je ne l'ai pas perçu puisque
j'étais moi-même dans la dans la
manifestation jusqu'à 17h qui qui m'a
surpris justement par la l'importance
des jeunes dans les cortèges c'était je
pense un gros tiers d'une manifestation
enfin en tout cas du parcours que j'ai
vu parce qu'il y avait deux parcours
parallèles donc c'était très très jeune
très très dynamique
jusqu'à ce que je sorte de la
manifestation moi j'ai pas du tout vu de
heure d'affrontement de violence je les
ai vu en arrivant de dans vos locaux en
fait en voyant ce qui se passe à
l'arrivée un peu de la manifestation et
par rapport à ce qui s'est passé la
semaine dernière on peut faire un
parallèle entre l'arrivée
massive donc je mets des guillemets
parce que c'est difficile de compter
précisément combien de jeûne dans une
manifestation à partir de quand les
jeunes à partir de quand on les plus et
l'arrivée également des violences jeudi
dernier est-ce que justement l'arrivée
des jeunes a vidé la rue de tous les
autres des retraités qui ne veulent pas
se retrouver au milieu de ces casseurs
non je pense je pense que ce qu'a fait
la l'arrivée de la jeunesse c'est qu'il
y a une forme d'imprévisibilité dans ces
formes de mobilisation c'est sûr qu'on
est plus nécessairement dans le la manif
qui part d'un point A et qui arrive à un
point B le un des phénomènes qu'on a pu
découvrir la semaine dernière c'est ce
phénomène de manifestation dites sauvage
en fait et les le phénomène de de monter
en puissance de d'affrontement il est
surtout lié à ça en fait des à des
phénomènes de tentatives de de
d'empêcher ces mobilisations il y a eu
aussi des formes de répression qui qui
se sont manifestées de manière assez
massive et puis finalement
des des poubelles renversées des
poubelles brûlées effectivement c'est
des choses qui ont plus se faire dans le
cours de la des soirées est-ce que les
syndicats ont encore la main sur le
mouvement on a l'impression que le
flambeau de la contestation est passé
des politiques au début au syndicat qui
ont largement pris la main en montrant
qu'ils étaient capables de faire
descendre un très grand nombre de
Français dans la rue
au casseurs non non je pense pas je
pense que la mobilisation est polie et
polyphonique je pense que la jeunesse
est si la jeunesse pouvait être réduite
au casseurs on n'aurait pas autant de
jeunes dans les rues aujourd'hui
je pense que les l'intersyndical elle a
encore fait la démonstration aujourd'hui
de sa capacité de mobilisation comme
elle a fait la semaine dernière avec des
cortèges qui sont des cortèges
pacifiques
sont légèrement
ils sont légèrement en baisse ils
avaient beaucoup beaucoup augmenté la
semaine dernière donc on est encore dans
une forme d'oscillation si vous voulez
et il me semble plutôt que l'intersey
syndicale continue de jouer son rôle
c'est à dire de fixer des grands
rendez-vous de mobilisation qui rythme
là qui rythme la contestation à la
réforme et puis dans les interstices de
ces grands rendez-vous se logent
effectivement des formes de mobilisation
qui sont plus du ressort des
organisations syndicales en tout cas qui
sont plus du ressort de l'Inter syndical
national puisqu'il peut y avoir aussi
tout un tas d'actions coup de poing de
blocage symbolique de choses comme ça
qui sont organisés par des réseaux
syndicaux à l'échelle locale et puis des
manifestations plus sauvages qui vont
davantage et de porter effectivement par
des des manifestants plus jeunes parfois
quel est le poids réel des syndicats
parce qu'on les a vu capables de
mobiliser les Français de descendre dans
la rue largement notamment dans le mois
de janvier dans le mois de février
encore récemment mais le gouvernement
n'a pas reculé pas du tout
la semaine dernière violence importante
dans Paris avec des images très fortes
évidemment ce n'est pas un recul sur la
question des retraites mais la venue de
Charles III est annulé est-ce qu'il n'y
a qu'à la violence que le gouvernement
répond bah c'est vous qui le dites en
tout cas ce en tout cas ce cheminement
il se il a dû sans doute s'opérer dans
la tête d'un certain nombre de
manifestants nous parliez tout à l'heure
de gens qui étaient justement pas des
Black Blocs qui se retrouvaient à
balancer des pavés je suis pas dans leur
tête je sais pas ce qui peut conduire à
ça mais on peut supposer que ce type de
conclusion que vous que vous sugg que
vous suggérer tout à l'heure ça a pu se
dérouler aussi dans la tête de certains
manifestants il y a des exemples
précédents Emmanuel Macron sur les
gilets jaunes là il avait réagi
pas que peut-être les syndicats se
disent et bien s'il faut laisser faire
par exemple il y avait pas les gros bras
de la CGT aujourd'hui dans la
manifestation est-ce que pardon pour ma
question elle est peut-être un peu
provoque et syndicats ont un intérêt à
laisser faire la violence honnêtement je
pense vraiment pas d'une la présence de
la CGT était moins visible aujourd'hui à
Paris en tout cas parce que c'est le
congrès de la Confédération et donc une
grande part de ces de ces militants sont
en ce moment réunis à Clermont-Ferrand
d'autre part les organisations
syndicales avaient précisément elles
l'ont souligné à maintes reprises a mis
en garde le président de la République
contre les risques de violence si jamais
ils devaient ne rester sourd en fait aux
demandes de l'intersyndicale et là pour
le coup c'est un fait social et
historique en fait le la présence
syndicale a plutôt un effet la
pacificateur sur les relations sociales
qu'un effet de brutalisation ou de ou de
d'accroissement de la violence les
organisations syndicales ce sont des
structures qui qui permettent justement
à des formes de colère qui peuvent
s'exprimer parfois de manière
individuelle ou destructive date de
prendre une direction plus constructive
par la négociation et
voilà historiquement le développement du
syndicalisme et la conduit à ce que les
grèves ne se traduisent plus par des
saccages des outils de travail mais par
des négociations
la les syndicats ont un trésor de guerre
ça s'appelle la l'opinion publique donc
c'est très fort ce qu'il y a une terreur
à perdre cette opinion publique en tout
cas il y a un souci de de conserver ce
ce cet adhésion extrêmement massive de
l'opinion publique les plus des deux
tiers des Français plus de 9 dixièmes
des actifs qui sont opposés à cette
réforme et c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles
les organisations syndicales quel que
soit leur sensibilité par ailleurs leurs
appréciations sur le déroulement
tactique de la séquence sont
particulièrement attachés à maintenir
leur unité dans cette intercire
syndicale pourtant les syndicats n'ont
jamais vraiment réussi à amener
l'ensemble de ces Français défavorables
à la réforme dans la rue pourquoi
pourquoi
il n'y a pas eu ce petit déclic alors
déjà on peut quand même se dire que on
était aujourd'hui je crois à la dixième
journée de mobilisation si on si on s'en
tient au principal parce qu'il y en a eu
d'autres décentralisés il y a le 8 mars
pour les droits des femmes etc sur 10
journées de mobilisation il y en a la
moitié 5 sur 10 j'ai je comptais ça en
venant qui ont tourné autour du million
de manifestants ou plus d'un million de
manifestants c'est c'est du jamais vu
dans l'histoire sociale de ce pays en
1995 on prend souvent comme exemple le
mouvement de novembre décembre 95 il y a
une journée de mobilisation qui atteint
un million de manifestants en 2019 0 en
2016 contre la loi travail zéro donc on
est vraiment en fait dans une
médisation très massive qui se constate
aussi dans l'ampleur des des
manifestations dans les petites villes
plus de 300 cortèges qui sont organisés
c'est quelque chose d'assez exceptionnel
donc de ce point de vue là la force des
organisations syndicales et c'est un
résultat justement de leur unité parce
que les différents réseaux de
mobilisation qui peuvent être implantés
dans des secteurs dans des lieux de
travail dans des dans des localités
différentes il se il se renforcent
mutuellement et c'est ce qui c'est ce
qui a permis jusqu'à maintenant à ce que
la mobilisation puisse être à ce point
massif mais à quoi bon puisque le
gouvernement n'a pas reculé et l'un des
derniers grands recul d'un gouvernement
c'est lorsque Alain Juppé était au
pouvoir il y avait eu un blocage du pays
certaines organisations syndicales ont
appelé au blocage du pays la CGT pour ne
pas la citer moi ça n'a pas pris
impossible de bloquer le pays alors
c'est beaucoup plus difficile pour
plusieurs raisons pour des raisons qui
tiennent à un affaiblissement du
mouvement syndical puisque c'est le
paradoxe un peu c'est qu'on a à la fois
des grosses journées de mobilisation en
termes de manifestants mais finalement
des taux de grévistes qui alors peuvent
être très élevés les les jours de
pendant les journées d'action appelées
par l'intersyndicale mais qui qui peine
à se maintenir dans la durée sous la
forme de grève reconductible notamment
ça ça renvoie une fragilisation des des
infrastructures syndicales il y a voilà
une présence une présence militante qui
est moins forte donc il y a il y a un
affaiblissement de ce point de vue là il
y a des conditions structurelles aussi
qui rendent le coup de la grève beaucoup
plus difficile ça a été dit à maintes
reprises l'inflation
avant de se mettre en grève
il y a voilà des formes de moi j'ai dû
discuter avec des jeunes salariés qui
étaient dans qui sont dans la dans le
commerce qui avait organisé de manière
complètement spontanée des piquets de
grève là il y en a un qui s'est fait
convoquer par son par son patron qui lui
a donné un avertissement donc il y a des
formes de représailles qui peuvent
s'exercer aussi contre les salariés donc
tout ça ça participe à rendre la grève
plus difficile parce que les liens entre
politiques et syndicats se sont encore
distendus au cours de cette séquence
Emmanuel Macron voulait se passer des
corps intermédiaires des partenaires
sociaux tout ça ça m'intéressait plus
parce que une fois de plus on ne peut
plus discuter entre syndicat et le
gouvernement alors les liens entre
syndicats et gouvernement pour exécutifs
ça c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
après est-ce que le lien entre les
syndicats le monde politique au sens
large et notamment les partis politiques
se sont distendus j'en suis pas certain
parce que ce qu'on a vu c'est finalement
une stratégie
des facto pas forcément derrière
consciente mais des facteurs articulées
entre une opposition dans la rue qui
était qui était animé par l'Inter
syndical et puis une opposition
parlementaire qui qui a surtout été
porté par par la nups parfois par
l'intergroupe de l'opposition de gauche
de fait il y a une espèce de d'action
qui s'est qui s'est manifestée qui
allait dans dans la même direction même
si il pouvait y avoir des sensibilités
différentes on l'a vu au moment du vote
sur l'article 7 par exemple il y avait
des accords importants entre les
syndicalistes et les accords sur le non
sur le fait de le faire
sur le fait d'amener chaque
parlementaire à assumer son vote sur
cette sur cet enjeu merci beaucoup
carillon
accompagné expliquer donner votre point
de vue sur cette mobilisation sur cette
dixième journée de mobilisation je
rappelle que vous êtes sociologue
spécialiste du syndicalisme retourne sur
le terrain pour savoir comment évolue la
manifestation Damien canivevez on a eu
tout à l'heure un pic de de violence
c'était aux alentours de 17h mais ça
s'est rapidement calmé hein finalement
on est sur une manifestation qui
ressemble plus à toutes les précédentes
celle du mois de janvier celle du mois
de février
voilà exactement le calme est revenu ici
place de la Nation nous sommes sur un
point en hauteur avec Julien Leclerc
grâce auquel vous décrivez vous
découvrez les images de cette place où
se termine le cortège et je peux vous
assurer que depuis le boulevard Voltaire
c'est un flux assez sang de de
manifestants qui déferlent sur cette
résonation il y a énormément de monde
alors nous on n'a pas les chiffres ici
dans la manifestation je sais pas s'ils
sont aussi nombreux que ceux qu'on a
connu la semaine dernière mais je peux
vous assurer qu'il y a énormément de
monde le cortège syndical est en train
d'arriver on a vu le syndicat solidaire
là vous voyez Sud Santé qui est en train
d'arriver les pompiers aussi il y a
quelques secondes sont arrivés sur cette
place de la Nation parce qu'il défile en
nombre également lors de ces
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites et ils ont été copieusement
applaudis par la foule qui s'est massé
ici sur cette place parisienne le
dispositif policier est toujours là
visible et présent les policiers et
gendarmes
encadre la place de la Nation donc sur
les rues qui débouchent sur ces places
de la police nationale il y a également
des des véhicules lourds en cas de
débordement mais pour l'instant en tout
cas l'ambiance se l'ambiance est plutôt
calme avec des slogans que vous entendez
derrière moi Macron démission on va te
chercher chez toi enfin vous vous
connaissez ces slogans que l'on entend
maintenant depuis le mois de janvier
date à laquelle
les manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites a commencé voilà Thibault ici
pour l'instant en tout cas les
manifestants arrivent dans le plus grand
des calmes et les tensions que l'on a pu
connaître tout à l'heure avec ces
débordements avec ses affrontements face
aux forces de l'ordre et bien tout cela
pour l'instant c'est derrière nous
merci Damien canivas 18h37 nous sommes
en direct pour un point de vue spécial
consacré à cette dixième journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites Grégory Joron bonjour bonsoir
regrette un secrétaire général unité svp
police FO c'est bien ça c'est bien ça
merci d'être ici de la violence
aujourd'hui beaucoup moins est-ce que ça
vous étonne vous attendez à plus de
d'affrontements oui on s'attendait
réellement à pire d'ailleurs les les
renseignements territoriaux avaient
informé d'un risque avéré dans une
cinquantaine de grandes villes
d'incidents plutôt graves avec une
participation de la jeunesse accrue et
c'est toujours ce qui est peut paraître
problématique parce que finalement c'est
l'expression de la jeunesse et souvent
difficile d'encadrer parmi mes tismes
ils peuvent aussi se mettre en danger
sur des actions et c'est vrai qu'il y
avait énormément de crainte autour de
cette journée et globalement sur Paris
particulièrement ça se passe plutôt bien
finalement et tant mieux comment vous
l'expliquez est-ce que c'est le
dispositif policier qui est à la hauteur
ou non c'était une manifestation où les
fournisseurs ne voulait pas se rendre
n'avez pas l'intention de se rendre mais
je pense que je pense clairement c'est
ça parce que et d'ailleurs c'est plutôt
rassurant que ça soit ça ça démontre
bien que c'est pas la police qui est à
l'origine des troubles dans les
manifestations contrairement à certains
fantasmes qui peuvent être relayés et le
dispositif était pas énorme mais plus
développé que je dis dernier il y avait
6 ou 7 forces mobiles de plus qui est
pas non plus dentiste et globalement qui
était à peu près positionné de la même
manière alors donc je pense surtout
qu'il y avait moins d'éléments radicaux
très clairement ce qui facilite
forcément l'action de mes collègues pour
faire de la gestion de foule un peu plus
un peu plus
ordinaire on va dire que des situations
extrêmement dégradées qu'on avait pu les
connaître vous étiez sur le terrain
aujourd'hui oui j'étais pendant j'étais
dans la manifestation dans le dans le
dans le cortège Force ouvrière et c'est
très bien passé pour nous on n'a pas vu
un seul un seul heur ni une seule charge
ni aucun problème parce que vous êtes
j'ai la double casque
je voulais vous poser ces questions à la
fin mais je poser tout de suite quel est
votre position sur la réforme des
retraites vous les les flics les
policiers et on est je crois que c'est
94% des actifs qui est contre il me
semble dans les derniers chiffres et
donc on fait partie de ceux-là très
clairement pour des raisons qui sont
assez évidents évidentes pardon
premièrement on a une accélération de la
loi Touraine même si elle était déjà
voté mais ça s'est accéléré pour nous
donc on a un vrai impact pour pour les
agents qui qui sont frappés par cette
mesure deuxièmement on a un empilement
des réformes depuis 20 ans qui font que
aujourd'hui c'est une réalité je prends
mon gars parce que c'est le plus simple
à expliquer en 25 ans de police on m'a
rajouté 6 ans de carrière d'accord pas
pour gagner plus pour gagner la course
je suis rentré au début je devais
arrêter à 54 ans en ayant une retraite à
taux plein et aujourd'hui je suis obligé
d'aller jusqu'à 60 ans si je veux la
même retraite à taux plein et alors
est-ce qu'il y aura une forme de
négociation un privilège un régime
spécial
on a une catégorie active clairement qui
fait qu'on a 50 bonifications au-delà de
27 ans de service ce qui permet à un
policier dans un monde normal de
terminer de à qui on va demander 38 ans
de service au lieu de 43 pour le pour le
pour le pour le pour le privé pardon
est-ce qu'il y a une négociation pour
l'instant moi je suis confédéré à FO on
a une revendication qui mais qui date
pas d'hier c'est à dire que vu qu'on
nous a allongé notre carrière on demande
à ce qu'on nous rajoute une année de
bonification c'est à dire qu'on est 6
ans de bonification en lieu de 5 voire 7
pour les carrières très longues au lieu
de au lieu de 5 pour l'instant ça
évidemment pas dans pas dans l'air du
temps puisque de toute façon on est on
n'est pas en égaux comme on peut comme
on peut l'entendre habituellement sur
cette réforme pour autant c'est une
revendication qui est dans de l'ordre
pérenne au niveau des syndicats de
police parce que vous le voyez bien ça
c'est très dégradé pour nous et on
attend qu'il y a un geste aussi parce
que le métier c'est pas c'est pas n'est
pas moins compliqué qu'avant au
contraire et on estime que plus on nous
rallonge notre carrière et ça mérite
forcément le regard j'entends dans les
manifestations parce que j'y suis allé
j'entends des manifestants crier aux
forces de l'ordre en face rejoignez-nous
et dans le même camp
est-ce que certains chez vous une sorte
de dissociation entre leurs conviction
et le travail qu'ils ont à faire non
parce qu'on a une culture
professionnelle donc c'est ce qu'on fait
on est là pour ça ça nous empêche pas
d'avoir un regard citoyen d'avoir un
avis sur ce qui se passe autour de nous
parce que on est quand même des citoyens
à part entière et évidemment on est
contre cette réforme des retraites mais
on est là pour faire un job donc on y va
on le fait on essaye de le faire de la
manière la plus professionnelle possible
tout en sachant qu'en effet on est aussi
contre cette réforme donc c'est vrai que
c'est assez ça peut ça peut ça peut
sembler dichotomique mais je veux dire
quand on est policier c'est très souvent
qu'on vient on a vécu des moments très
difficiles je vous parle de parler
d'autres sujets mais quand vous êtes à
Calais au tout début des grandes vagues
migratoires et qu'on vous demande de
sortir des familles complètes de four ou
de camions qu'on laisse au bord de la
route sans exactement savoir ce qu'on
fait ça pose des vrais cas de conscience
quand même quand vous êtes policier et
qu'on vous demande de faire ça sauf
qu'en fait encore une fois on est
policier et on est dès lors que l'ordre
n'est pas il on ne peut pas s'y
soustraire et je rappelle parce que ça
va dans le sens de votre question on n'a
pas le droit de grève non oui donc
aujourd'hui vous manifestiez sans être
en reste un jour de reposer dans la
police nationale alors justement je j'en
profite je continue cette question ça
m'intéresse beaucoup parce que j'ai vu
les images de sainte Soline ce weekend
du les voir aussi avec des images assez
hallucinantes une forme de ridicule
aussi avec ses affrontements au milieu
des champs sans y voir voilà sans enjeux
est-ce que les forces de l'ordre savent
toujours pourquoi elles se battent
lorsque c'est CRS c'est le gendarmes
mobiles sont à Sainte-Soline est-ce
qu'ils se disent mais qu'est-ce que je
défends qu'est-ce que je fais
c'est la mission alors je vais pas vous
dire que voilà comme réfléchir c'est
commencer à désobéir tout ça c'est dans
l'armée qu'on le dit mais pour autant
c'est vrai que
la police nationale ou les forces de
sécurité donc la gendarmerie aussi
malheureusement c'est le cas quand vous
arrivez c'est une manifestation comme à
Sainte Soline ou comme aujourd'hui parce
qu'aujourd'hui il faut voir ce qui était
balancé aussi sur mes collègues à
Saint-Nazaire à Lyon et ailleurs et à
Paris sûrement on verra ça tout à
l'heure mais quand vous arrivez en
manifestation avec des marteaux des
hachettes des boules de pétanque des
bouteilles d'acide qui sont accrochées à
des pétards des cocktails Molotov
je pense qu'ils ont les loin du symbole
c'est à dire qu'on s'en prend pas on est
on peut quand on fait du maintien de
l'ordre aller au bout si j'ai une 30
secondes en fait on est on est capable
de comprendre que de temps en temps on
puisse servir d'exutoire ça fait partie
du jeu ça fait partie du job voilà quand
c'est dans un dans un maintien de
l'ordre et une gestion de fou
l'habituelle où on a des manifestants
qui respectent un peu la distance qui
s'en prennent à vous de loin avec avec
deux petits cailloux et quelques
insultes etc ça reste du domaine de
l'acceptable et on sait qu'on est là
pour ça et qui a la forme de on peut
servir de cible et dès que je dois par
rapport à ça à partir du moment ça
dépasse un certain niveau d'anglais de
violence et que forcément on commence à
avoir des blessés voire même des
atteintes de cette gravité comme à
Sainte Soline forcément quand on est
policier on est aussi père ou mère de
famille on peut pas l'accepter parce que
notre intégrité physique pour le coup
imaginer une boule de pétanque un
cocktail Molotov vous avez vu ces images
de gendarmes en flamme on avait déjà
communément CRS sur à d'autres périodes
c'est quand même extrêmement inquiétant
depuis plusieurs semaines les
manifestations contre cette réforme des
retraites était calme est-ce que vous
vous attendiez à ce que
jeudi dernier et peut-être dans les
jours qui viennent aujourd'hui ça a été
un peu plus violent que lors des mois de
janvier du mois de février vous
attendiez à ce que qu'il y ait des
débordements parce que nous ça nous
avait presque surprise de voir des
manifestations calmes on se demandait si
on savait encore faire c'est surtout ça
ouais c'était cool à on est revenu à un
modèle d'expression on s'est dit bah
voilà enfin on peut retrouver une
manifestation d'ampleur parce qu'il y
avait énormément de monde qui arrive à
passer son message parce que pour le
coup il n'était pas brouillé justement
par par l'effet loupe et focus qu'on a
il y a des violences et du coup on
traite pas le sujet intéressant pour
lequel les gens sont tous venus en masse
dans la rue et c'est vrai que ça faisait
du bien de retrouver justement et
d'ailleurs au sein des manifestations il
y a une vraie Concorde et c'est plutôt
sympa comme ambiance il y a pas de ça se
passe plutôt bien et donc c'est vrai que
ça faisait du bien parce que je pense
que c'est voilà c'est aussi un droit
complètement démocratique et
constitutionnel de pouvoir manifester et
il faut et il faut le préserver et c'est
vrai que jeudi quand on a revu ces
images là même si ça avait un peu un peu
chiffonné on va dire sur certaines
manifestations il y avait rien de
marquant je dis quand on a vu ce retour
là voilà d'éléments extrêmement radicaux
extrêmement violents notamment à Paris
forcément mais aussi à Nantes vraiment à
Rennes à Lorient on pouvait s'inquiéter
alors est-ce qu'il y a pas aussi quand
même
les fesses insolites avec on le sait
énormément de renfort qui ont été
renforts
qui ont été envoyés des blablox qui ont
été renvoyés de pays frontaliers c'est
ça notre réalité aussi avec des
Allemands des Espagnols des Belges qui
viennent renforcer un peu les troupes et
et je crois qu'ils étaient là jeudi à
Paris c'est une certitude et je crois
qu'ils sont pas fait peut-être le match
retour cet après-midi tant mieux comment
vous pris l'intervention du ministre de
l'Intérieur hier qui est venu parler
publiquement avant une manifestation
pour expliquer de manière assez martiale
le dispositif de sécurité plutôt
positivement ou plutôt à l'inverse dit
tiens ce que ça n'exacerberait pas les
tensions avec même chez vous sous forme
de veiller d'armes avant d'aller au
combat hier ce matin comment avez-vous
pris cette décision de l'intérieur de
parler je pense que c'est moi je pense
que c'est toujours bien de d'expliquer
ce qui va être fait et pourquoi ça va
l'être je crois que le maintien de
l'ordre souffre d'une chose assez assez
qui date d'assez longtemps c'est
justement le le manque de communication
l'endroit des manifestations d'abord en
direct également parce que on parle de
ce qu'on peut faire avant il faut
débriefer je pense ce qu'on a fait après
évidemment et je pense que c'est
important aussi de parler aux gens
pendant et c'est ce qui manque
aujourd'hui dans les dispositifs de
maintien de l'ordre c'est ce qu'il
faudra travailler c'est ce que je
proposais de toute façon encore une fois
au ministre c'est que la communication
dans l'endroit des manifestants elle est
super importante parce qu'à un moment
donné il faut aussi responsabiliser les
gens je veux dire l'engagement de la
force ça a un sens le cadre légal il est
en général et plus qu'en général
respecté et à partir du moment de ce
moment là il manifestants ils doivent
savoir exactement ce qu'il doit faire
déjà une ça va les responsabiliser je
veux dire je vais prendre deux images
pour que tout le monde comprenne quand
vous êtes dans une manifestation qui a
des sommations parce que la dispersion
doit être faite et que et que
malheureusement soit personne ne
comprend ce que c'est qu'une sommation
et c'est parce que ça veut dire soit ils
n'ont pas entendu parce que les éléments
qui qui diffusent la sommation sur le
porte-voix c'est pas assez assez
puissant et donc on a des gens qui se
retrouvent là qui potentiellement se
font gazer indirectement qui sont
frustrés parce qu'ils sont agressés
alors qu'en fait pas du tout ils sont
visés voyez et tout ça faut qu'on arrive
à le déconstruire et à un moment donné
trouver des modes de communication qui
pourraient permettre de dire justement
manifestants attention là on engage la
force ne vous retrouvez pas là parce
qu'autrement et vous risquez forcément
un problème et après ça me fait penser
aux gens qui restent malheureusement et
qui vont skier hors piste ou qui vont se
baigner quand le drapeau est rouge après
chacun prend ses responsabilités est-ce
que les consignes ont changé c'est ces
derniers jours ce qu'on vous a dit
attention maintenant on se protège plus
on est plus offensif plus incisif est-ce
que ça changeait non je pense pas parce
que dans toute franchise vous pouvez
bien poser le plusieurs dispositifs de
maintien de l'ordre du monde de toute
façon ça se passe jamais comme vous
l'avez prévu donc à partir de là il faut
s'adapter et s'adapter avec pour le coup
des principes généraux c'est qu'est-ce
que c'est qu'une action de maintien de
l'ordre c'est quoi un bon offensif
comment on manœuvre c'est quoi
l'utilisation des moyens intermédiaires
à quel moment on doit les utiliser donc
quel but et ensuite on met en oeuvre
tout ça par rapport à ce qu'on doit
affronter entre guillemets et gérer sur
le terrain donc je pense pas qu'il y ait
de consignes très ferme ou on nous dit
attention vous allez subir ça serait pas
acceptable on nous dit attention on va
falloir charger fort légèrement entendu
au CRS et en fait on fait souvent
exactement comme on peut par rapport à
la menace qu'on est en face de nous
est-ce qu'on doit accompagner est-ce que
certains de vos collègues ont perdu leur
mère ces derniers jours
oui mais parce que parce que la police
est humaine et par définition elle est
faillible et que et que malheureusement
dans certaines circonstances moi ce que
j'aime c'est rappeler le contexte je dis
pas que ça l'excuse je dis pas que ça
excuse certains actes et ou certains
propos mais pour autant faut juste un
moment donné se dire que déjà jugé des
policiers sur 30 secondes de vidéos ça
me paraît un peu hasardeuse au-delà de
ça rappelait toujours le contexte et
puis ensuite dire qu'on est dans un état
droit moi je je sais ce que c'est pour
avoir représenté les policiers aussi en
conseil de discipline contrairement
aussi à ce qu'on peut croire sur l'IGPN
l'IGPN fait son travail quand on l'a une
enquête à à faire sur des policiers
qu'on ou des manquements déontologiques
voire même répréhensible par par
l'aspect pénal bah il s'explique ils
sont traduits en discipline il faut
savoir que les policiers on a quand même
quelque chose d'assez particulier c'est
que nous on a toujours la double peine
et c'est bien normal on a une
responsabilité très forte on nous donne
mandat pour utiliser de la force
publique quand malheureusement pour des
raisons X ou Y vous un usage de cette
force qui est inapproprié ou illégitime
ben vous avez en général une sanction
administrative et aussi une sanction
pénale un scan CRS n'est pas censé mieux
maîtriser ses nerfs
garder son sang-froid plus facilement
que n'importe qui d'autre mais les
policiers en général sont appelés à
faire ça tous les jours c'est à dire
qu'on demande à des gens ordinaires de
faire face à des situations
extraordinaires et de rester dans un
calme olympien face à des situations
dans le dans lesquelles n'importe quel
personne lambda réagirait d'une manière
peut-être des fois inappropriée même les
plus gentilles des personnes donc c'est
ce qu'on demande en effet aux policiers
sauf qu'à un moment donné encore une
fois je le répète la police est humaine
quand moi j'aime qu'on se
on cherche un peu les causes des fois de
ce qui peut de ce qui peut arriver
jeudi dernier deux unités de CRS ont
travaillé 24 heures d'affilée est-ce que
vous pensez qu'au bout de 24 heures vous
avez un discernement qui est
identique que celui que vous aviez dans
les premières heures de service je pense
pas encore une fois je dis pas ça
l'excuse je dis que ça peut l'expliquer
quand vous êtes donc face à des
situations extrêmement tendues comme
celle-ci et il y a pas que même la
journée qui vient de se passer quand ça
fait une semaine que vous êtes engagé
que vous dormez pas beaucoup que vous
enchaînez l'évacuation ou finalement
c'est extrêmement tendu vous avez des
situations de stress parce que quand
vous êtes quand votre intégrité physique
peut être mise en cause tout le monde
craint ça il y a pas de surhomme et donc
forcément voilà moi je pense que c'est
de temps en temps intéressant d'aller
chercher quand même certaines réponses
et certains certaines visions par
rapport à justement au quotidien des
policiers dans dans ce genre de séquence
extrêmement engageant pour elle et pour
les organismes j'ai encore de deux
questions grégorien est-ce que tous les
policiers qui sont sur ces
manifestations sont formés au maintien
parce qu'il n'y a pas que des CRS c'est
des gendarmes mobiles dans dans ces
manifs est-ce que ça ce n'est pas un
problème c'est c'est un problème mais de
toute façon moi je je l'ai écrit à
plusieurs reprises en commission
parlementaire le maintien de l'ordre
c'est avant tout une affaire de
professionnel donc vous avez l'échelon
lourd les CRS les escades de gendarmes
Uruguay les compagnies d'intervention de
la préfecture police ou ailleurs
lorsqu'elles sont départementalisées
et ensuite vous avez tous les services
qui viennent en plus pour pour être un
peu plus mobiles faire des
interpellations même si moi là-dessus
pas développer mais pas un grand fan de
la judiciarisation du maintien de
l'ordre je pense qu'il faut faire
attention à ça pour autant
les jetons lourds c'est celui-ci si vous
voulez parler des bravesm en direct
d'un gendarme qui reprend assez
vertement un membre vous faites
n'importe quoi mais faut pas faire ça
mais et on nous a dit de venir ici un
peu alors attention cette vidéo elle
date de 2020 ah c'est vrai oui ah bah
oui vous avez donc juste voilà elle date
de 2020 merci pour autant je m'excuse
d'avoir
elle existe quand même la formation
c'est arrivé sauf que c'est juste un peu
daté mais mais pour autant ça démontre
une chose c'est-à-dire que si vous
voulez moi les bravesm au tout départ si
vous voulez vraiment mon avis en toute
transparence j'étais assez dubitatif à
dubitatif
il faut très vite faire la différence
justement pour pas que ça s'installe à
mon sens la bravem c'est c'est
simplement une capacité de projection il
y a pas de maintien de l'ordre avec une
grande matraque où on va au passage
matraquer les gens etc c'est pas du tout
c'est pouvoir c'est pouvoir remporter
une section d'un a un point B quand on
voit des situations dégradées comme ça
imaginez un moment qu'on est aussi
fallait que vous preniez une colonne de
fourgon vous allez mettre un certain
temps pour arriver j'ai mis un certain
temps pour arriver ici c'était assez
compliqué donc j'imagine en fourgon même
si vous avez le gyro c'est compliqué de
traverser des fous les et avec les
circulations qui sont bouchées donc la
moto au regard des risques et c'est ça
le problème du match alors c'est
s'adapter aussi par rapport au risque
parce que évidemment la l'expression de
la colère peut évoluer on s'adapte par
rapport à notre matériel et on s'adapte
aussi par rapport à notre capacité de
mobilité et la bravème c'est simplement
ça c'est de la mobilité en fait les
fonctionnaires qui sont dessus derrière
les fonctionnaires qui font partie des
compagnies d'intervention de la
préfecture de police donc ils sont
habilités à faire du maintien de l'ordre
donc tout le monde sait faire du
maintien de l'ordre logiquement oui ça
n'empêche pas de rappeler qu'il faut de
la formation ça empêche pas de rappeler
qu'il faut de l'encadrement de proximité
pour pour avoir les bons ordres et les
bonnes réactions ça n'empêche pas de
rappeler que le maintien de l'ordre
voilà c'est une question professionnelle
et qu'il faut le maintenir comme ça
[__] de navigation est-ce que dans ces
moments il y a une peur chez les
policiers ou plutôt une envie d'aller au
combat il y a un peu les deux c'est de
l'adrénaline donc après chacun chacun la
gère comme comme il peut avec avec son
vécu envie d'aller au combat oui quand
il y a allez on va pas se mentir quand
ça fait trois heures que vous ramassez
des cailloux et que et que vous faites
insulter quand on vous dites chargez bon
ben vous y allez parce que c'est le job
maintenant ce qui est intéressant c'est
justement la bonne gestion de la force
publique c'est-à-dire que quand on vous
dit tcharger vous avez un but à
atteindre et une fois que le but est
atteint ça s'arrête c'est ça qui est
important merci beaucoup Grégory Joron
secrétaire général Unité SGP Police FO
le dit de plus en plus vite merci à vous
donner votre point de vue votre avis vos
explications ici au Figaro live on va
retourner sur le terrain avec Damien
Canivez Damien on a eu tout à l'heure un
quart d'heure une demi-heure de tension
et puis tout est rentré dans l'ordre
j'ai l'impression que c'est plutôt calme
désormais place de la Nation
c'est plutôt calme Thibault hormis le
fait que les manifestants continuent
d'affluer sur cette place de la Nation
il ne se passe pas grand chose les
cortèges syndicals continuent d'influer
on a l'impression que c'est interminable
que les manifestants de cesseront jamais
d'arriver place de la Nation parce que
voilà ça fait quand même un moment
maintenant que nous sommes arrivés ici
peut-être trois quart d'heure et ça fait
trois quarts d'heure que les
manifestants continuent d'arriver alors
cette manifestation c'est globalement
déroulé dans le calme parce que si on
prend la manifestation d'un point A à un
point B c'est à dire sur toute sur
l'ensemble de la du cortège ça c'est
globalement bien déroulé alors c'est
vrai que nous avons connu tout à l'heure
cette hausse de la température avec des
jeux de projectiles sur les forces de
l'ordre avec ces groupements de
d'éléments radicaux sur la fin du
boulevard Voltaire vers la fin de la
manifestation mais grâce à l'action des
forces de l'ordre c'est c'est
manifestants énervés ont pu se disperser
et le cortège a bu continuer
de bonnes conditions son chemin donc
voilà on arrive à la fin de la
manifestation ce qui a été assez
étonnant et je pense que Vincent roseron
voulait également indiquer c'est qu'il y
avait énormément de jeunes et on s'en
rend compte maintenant puisque nous
étions sur Le Havre du cortège donc nous
avions pas cette vue d'ensemble mais ce
qu'on peut constater là maintenant c'est
qu'il y a énormément d'étudiants de
lycéens qui étaient présents lors de
cette manifestation et ils sont
déterminés on les a entendus
effectivement échanger entre eux ils ont
bien l'intention de poursuivre ce
mouvement alors il manifeste pas
uniquement contre la réforme des
retraites mais il manifeste contre ce
qu'ils appellent une certaine oppression
de l'État c'est ce qu'on a entendu ici
ou là dans dans le cortège parisien donc
on sait pas véritablement si l'Inter
syndical va appeler à une nouvelle
mobilisation au cours des prochains
jours mais ce qui est certain c'est que
la jeunesse va continuer à se mobiliser
dans les rues de la capitale
merci beaucoup Damien Canivez merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis je vous donne
ces derniers chiffres 740
000 manifestants dans tout le pays selon
les chiffres du ministère de l'intérieur
on avait un peu plus d'un million je dis
dernier une mobilisation en baisse donc
93000 personnes se sont rendus dans les
rues de Paris merci de nous avoir suivi
vous continuez à
avoir toutes ces informations sur le
Figaro.fr avec le live texte et puis
nous on vous laisse avec avec ces images
de la place de la Nation avec la nuit
qui va tomber sur Paris et sur
l'ensemble du pays en espérant que
qu'il n'y ait pas de nouveaux
échauffourés ça a été le cas tout à
l'heure aux alentours de 17h mais tout
est rentré assez vite dans l'ordre je
vous laisse avec ces images merci de
nous avoir suivi excellente soirée sur
le Figaro live
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
France
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un truc avec
[Musique]
les forces de l'ordre dans les miens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà tirer la
maison
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu as l'air de se calmer sur ce côté-là
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on a tout le monde avec nous
déterminée donne rendez-vous le 6 avril
à l'appel de l'intersyndical ce sont
plus de 2 millions de travailleurs et
travailleurs jeunes et retraités qui se
sont mis en grève et ont manifesté le
monde du travail c'est une nouvelle fois
mobilisé dans toute la France de façon
massive et déterminée pour le retrait de
la réforme des retraites la jeunesse a
encore une fois été très présente dans
l'immobilisation
après deux mois d'un mouvement social
exemplaire et inédit depuis 50 ans très
largement soutenu par la population et
un parcours parlementaire chaotique
l'absence de réponse de l'exécutif
conduit à une situation de tension dans
le pays qui nous inquiète très fortement
on ne répondant pas à la demande de
retrait en usant du 49.3 l'exécutif a
fait le choix d'accentuer la crise
démocratique et sociale
pourtant dès le début les organisations
syndicales et de jeunesse avaient
prévenu l'exécutif
du risque d'explosion sociale que
pouvait provoquer cette réforme injuste
injustifiée et brutal le gouvernement à
la responsabilité de garantir la
sécurité et le respect du droit de grève
et de manifester alors que le calme a
toujours caractérisé le mouvement
l'intersyndical déplore le nombre de
volets
depuis des semaines nos organisations
fait preuve d'une grande responsabilité
aujourd'hui encore nous demandons au
gouvernement de prendre la sienne
l’inter syndicale soutient les
mobilisations manifestations les actions
intercendicales et grève qui perdurent
depuis janvier
elle appelle les millions de
travailleurs et travailleuses les jeunes
et les retraités à continuer de se
mobiliser
elle appelle à des rassemblements
syndicaux de proximité définito calmant
et à une nouvelle grande journée de
grève et de manifestations le jeudi 6
avril partout dans le pays
l'intersyndicale se réunira
prochainement merci
c'était le communiqué de
l'interventicale nous sommes à votre
disposition
comme à l'addition
si vous le voulez le communiquer avec il
est disponible
il y en a plusieurs
j'en ai là
[Musique]
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui a été gravement blessé la semaine
dernière mutilé par une grenade dans les
manifestations parisiennes voilà d'où au
niveau de solidaire on déplore très très
largement l'utilisation forte de la
violence qui a pu exister on a vu
qu'aujourd'hui ça a l'air de d'avoir
baissé d'un cran et certainement parce
qu'on a interpellé très fortement
l'exécutif le rappeler à sa
responsabilité sur sur les
manifestations
non on pense que comme on l'a écrit
aujourd'hui l'Inter syndicale elle est
tout à fait responsable parce que elle
cherche aussi une voix de sortie pour
pour l'ensemble des salariés pour nous
évidemment la voie de sortie c'est
d'abord le retrait de cette de cette loi
mais on est aussi sur différents outils
pour quelque part faire en sorte que
cette loi ne s'applique pas c'est une
manière aussi de dire à l'exécutif
prenez ma langue vos responsabilités
nous on a pris les nôtres mais à un
moment donné pour sortir de cette crise
sociale il va falloir faire les choses
et on appelle à la responsabilité du
gouvernement va pour agir par rapport à
cette réforme des retraites qui est
refusée par une majorité de la
population dans quel état est
l'interventicale ce soir est-ce qu'elle
est toujours
petite divergente non bah vous voyez on
est Unis déterminé soudés on est un pack
qui avance très très fortement et
puisqu'on voit bah c'est que de l'autre
côté l'exécutif il recule il se divise
on entend toutes ces petites phrases et
c'est cette difficulté complexité qui
ont l'air d'exister aujourd'hui dans
l'exécutif et pas seulement on voit que
dans les Alliés différents alliés ils se
questionnent sur la façon de faire bah
nous on continue d'avancer on est très
soutenu parce qu'il y a des millions de
travailleurs de travailleurs de jeunes
qui participent à nos mobilisations donc
aucun souci du côté de l'intersyndical
évidemment ça avance rien du tout on
parlait d'une lettre justement pour tout
de suite fait passer à Emmanuel Macron
que j'avais c'est compris
on a des prémices de réponse on dira
pour l'instant mais on verra
certainement d'ici la fin de la semaine
comme on réagira à cette prémisse à se
prémisse de réponse voilà vous êtes pour
une médiation
alors on pense que un moment donné quand
il y a un profil trop important il faut
qu'on sorte aussi de se confie là pour
nous évidemment le plus simple et pour
que tout ça s'arrête quelque part ce
serait pour le gouvernement de d'enfants
entendre et enfin retirer cette réforme
injuste on sait que c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça malheureusement pour
l'instant donc on essaye de d'avoir
différentes voix on sait aussi que on a
fait des contributions au Conseil
constitutionnel parce que c'est
peut-être aussi une manière de ne pas
avoir l'application de cette point
injuste de d'utiliser ce biais là mais
pour l'instant nous ce qu'on voit c'est
que on n'a pas de réponse satisfaisante
et que du coup on continue les grèves on
continue les manifestations clairement
aujourd'hui non mais on est à la dixième
journée de mobilisation donc
l'essoufflement s'il devait avoir lieu
ça serait on serait 100 000 dans la rue
qui est un petit peu moins que la
semaine dernière où il y a eu un effet
d'entraînement avec le 49-3 avec le
déclarations de Macron et peut-être
qu'il faudrait qu'ils prennent la parole
une fois de plus pour pour aider
réellement la mobilisation mais
sérieusement on est dans des niveaux
extraordinaires en termes de nombre de
personnes qui participent à une journée
de grève et de manifestation dans le
troisième mois de mobilisation souvenez
vous ça a commencé début janvier donc on
est très très satisfait de ce qui se
passe et on sait qu'il va y avoir tous
les jours il y a des actions tous les
jours il va y avoir des choses qui vont
se passer localement on se donne aussi
les moyens de remobiliser très très
largement et un rendez-vous qui va être
très très fort le 6 avril qui va être
encore une journée énorme de
mobilisation
on s'ignorait pas un communiqué commun
avec la CFDT je pense que vraiment enfin
on reste sur notre notre ligne rouge
c'est à dire bon on veut pas c'est 64
ans veut pas de travailler deux ans de
plus et je pense que si on signe un
communiqué commun c'est pas c'est pas
quelque chose de mou et de femme au
contraire c'est encore une fois appelé
une nouvelle mobilisation et évidemment
que la CFDT aussi signataire comme nous
de se communiquer de ce soir
merci à vous
je suis désolé
je suis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est là du coup
mais il est sympa il sait pas qui c'est
ça
on est gentil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la bonne odeur de lacrim
[Musique]
oui c'est vrai parce que là on va faire
des trucs
[Musique]
ils sont du coup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok je suis sur ta gauche là regarde à
gauche non
[Applaudissements]
on est là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous serez sur la
banque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en fait
elle m'a dit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh là là c'est bon
messieurs sur la route s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le service du peuple et il se sert
à rien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]